Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Folge Nr. 42 von Alternativlos.
Heute mit einem Gast, der uns hoffentlich helfen wird, der Folgen Nr. ausreichend genüge zu tun, nämlich Joscha Bach. Der eine oder andere von euch wird ihn sicher kennen von den Vorträgen, die er seit Jahren auf den CCC-Kongressen hält. Und wer noch nichts gehört hat, der soll sich mal anschnallen und entspannt zurücklehnen. Das wird hoffentlich ein interessanter Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ja, wer vielleicht wisst, ist ja 42 die Antwort auf die Frage nach dem Universum und überhaupt und allem, bekannt aus dem, per anderem die Galaxis. Und die wird ja gefunden von einem Supercomputer, der genau dafür gebaut wurde, die Frage zu beantworten. Wie weit sind wir denn noch weg von diesem Supercomputer, der die Frage nach allem beantworten kann?
Supergute Frage. Ich meine, Alpha Zero war in der Lage, innerhalb von sechs Stunden gegen sich selbst spielen, Menschen zu zeigen, dass die 2700 Jahre Go-Geschichte, die sie haben, sie bloß im lokales Optimum geführt haben. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass wir eigentlich erst seit 160 Jahren moderne Physik haben oder 170 Jahren, wenn man das ernsthaft mal anschaut, wir haben so ein Puzzle. Dieses Puzzle ist das Standardmodell, ungefähr eine halbe Seite Code. Und die Vorsagen des Standardmodells stimmen ziemlich gut mit dem überein, was wir experimentell beobachten können. Das sind also ungefähr die Constraints. Wir wissen, das Standardmodell ist unvollständig. Und wir haben sozusagen nicht den richtigen Formalismus gefunden, um das auf eine Formel runterzubrechen, die noch eleganter ist als alles andere und auch die dunkle Materie noch mit enthält. Und dieses Puzzle ist möglicherweise nur ein kleines bisschen über der intellektuellen Kapazität von unseren jetzigen Physikern. Und wahrscheinlich werden wir lang genug dran knobeln, kriegen wir das raus. Aber eigentlich müsste das auch mit KI gehen.
Also, aber brauchen wir KI oder geht das vielleicht auch so? Ist es vielleicht nicht, dass die, dass es über der Kapazität unserer Physiker ist, sondern irgendwie andere Probleme, vielleicht die trauen sich nicht, wirklich radikale Ideen mal durchzuspielen oder so?
Na, ich glaube, die trauen sich schon. Die Physiker gehören zu den schlauesten Leuten und die haben am Ende der interessantesten intellektuellen Traditionen am Laufen. Das Ding ist, weil das unsere intellektuellen Traditionen normalerweise nicht so lang sind. Im Grunde könnte man sich vorstellen, dass die Menschheit damit beschäftigt, ist so eine Art zusammenhängende Maschine zu bauen, die die Welt versteht. Das ist ein riesengroßes mechanisches Modell der Welt, so eine Art globalen Intellekt. Und der einzelne Wissenschaftler ist so eine Ameise, die Zeug zu diesem Intellekt heranträgt. Und das Gebäude ist im Augenblick noch so ein bisschen disconnected, aber im Großen und Ganzen gibt es eine gemeinsame Epistemologie. Man könnte sagen, in unserer Kultur geht das vielleicht so 620 los, als Francis Began festgestellt hat, die Konfidenz in deinem Belief muss genauso groß sein, wie die Evidenz, die den Belief stützt. Also wenn jemand von berg zurückkommt, dann hat man im brennenden Wurscht gesprochen, der hatte wahrscheinlich keinen Case. Und irgendwann musst du deine ganzen Evidenzen zurücktracken, also alle Beliefs auf ihre Prior's reduzieren. Und das heißt, du kommst irgendwann auf eine Art Ring, auf so ein Ding, wo sich die Katze in den Schwanz beißt, auf eine mathematische Tautologie, also irgendein mathematisches Universum, das möglicherweise mit deinen Beobachtungen beeinstimmt. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie viele mathematische Universen gibt es, die geschlossen sind, die in sich komplett konsistent sind und eine komplette Physik produzieren können? Und welche von denen stimmen mit unseren Beobachtungen überein?
Aber du sagst ja, de facto ist die Frage, ob unsere Physiker schneller schlauer werden oder ob unsere KI's schneller schlauer werden.
Ich glaube, dass die KI's ein Teil dieser Übung sind, in einer gewissen Weise. Also dieser Intellekt ist ja auch damit beschäftigt, draus zu finden, wer wir sind und wie wir funktionieren. Und wir sind wahrscheinlich sowas wie universelle Funktionsapproximatoren, wenn man uns genügend Zeit gibt.
Zumindest für einen Teil unserer Funktion.
Vielleicht sollte man das ein bisschen länger aufrollen.
Ja genau, das sind so Tomaten.
Genau. Eine der coolen Entdeckungen, die wir gemacht haben im letzten Jahrhundert, war diese Idee mit der universellen Computation. Das heißt, es gibt so eine Menge von Regeln und wenn man die befolgt, dann kann man mit denen jede Menge von Regeln, die berechenbar sind, berechnen. Das ist ein universeller Computer. Und es gibt sehr viele universelle Computer, die man definieren kann und das ist auch gar nicht so schwer. Also das Game of Life ist eine Turing-Maschine, jeder Programmiersprache ist einer. Und all diese Dinger können das gleiche. Der Unterschied zwischen den Programmiersprachen ist letztendlich nicht, was die berechnen können, sondern nur, wie sie uns helfen, darüber zu denken, was wir berechnen wollen. Aber zum Schluss können sie alle dasselbe. Und diese Church-Turing-These, die ist schon ein bisschen eher entdeckt worden, eigentlich vor Church und Turing. Zum Beispiel Kante Wittgenstein, die schon, als der 1929, was glaube ich, seinen Traktatus veröffentlicht hat, da wusste er das im Prinzip schon, hat versucht, eine Sprache zu finden, die so eine Art symbolisches KI-Programm war. Hat noch nicht ganz geklappt, er ist ziemlich weit damit gekommen. Die Philosophen haben es, glaube ich, nicht ganz verstanden, haben gedacht, er redet über natürliche Sprachen oder philosophische Sprachen, haben nicht verstanden, dass er versucht, die Sprache an sich zu analysieren. Und die Menge aller Sprachen, das ist die Mathematik. Die Mathematik ist Wohnung des, des alle formalen Sprachen sind da drin. Und das ist das Reich der Spezifikation. Und ein ganz kleiner Teil der Mathematik ist das, was funktioniert. Das ist die Komputation. Für die Mathematiker, die konstruktive Mathematik. Für die Mathematiker ist eine ganz kleine Nische, weil das meiste ist ja nicht berechenbar in der Mathematik. Jedenfalls nicht richtig. Zum Beispiel Pi hat unendlich viele Stellen und ist nicht wirklich berechenbar. Wenn doch, sag mir mal jemand die letzte Stelle. Pi ist aus der Sicht der Komputation keine Zahl, sondern eine Funktion. Wir, wir führen das ein als Konstante, die halt nur so viele Stellen, wie du, wie du gerade brauchst, genau, aber wie du speichern kannst. Aber normalerweise ist Pi eigentlich ein Algorithmus. Und je länger du den laufen lässt, desto teurer wird das. Und irgendwann kannst du es dir halt nicht mehr leisten. Das heißt, in diesem Universum werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht rauskriegen, wie die letzte Stelle von Pi aussieht.
Weil es wahrscheinlich keine gibt.
Ja, klar.
Allen, was wir wissen.
Genau, beziehungsweise es gibt keinen Computer, der unendlich viele Schritte in endlich kurzer Zeit ausführen kann.
Mit viel Energie, ja.
Und das ist der Witz, der Unterschied zwischen der normalen Mathematik, der klassischen Mathematik und der Komputation. Die klassische Mathematik ist zeitlos. Sobald ich da aufgeschrieben habe, was die Constraints sind, geht der Mathematiker davon aus, dass das Ergebnis im Prinzip klar ist. Die eigentliche Berechnung, die kann man seinen Doktoranden überlassen oder zu künftigen Generationen. Aber für die Informatiker ist anders.
Naja, deswegen ist ja dann auch in diversen Seitenbereichen Physik auch nur möglich, indem man halt sehr generöse Annahmen darüber trifft, wie eigentlich die Welt aussieht. Weil sonst wird halt deine Berechnung zu komplex und zu lang wie rechnen.
Das Verrückte ist halt, dass reelle Zahlen, also diese Mathematik der reellen Zahlen, möglicherweise nicht implementierbar ist. Und ich vermute, alles, was existiert, muss auch irgendwie implementiert sein. Das muss es irgendwie geben. Und wir können konstruktiv ein Computer ohne Weiteres bauen, aber ein Hypercomputer, also so ein geometrisches Ding, was in der Lage ist, Zahlen mit unendlich vielen Nachkommastellen in endlicher Zeit zu bewegen, sodass du einfach nur zu 2 und p addieren kannst, indem du zum Beispiel zwei unendlich fein aufgelöste Stöckchen zusammenklopft und dann das Ganze misst. Könnte man sich ja intuitiv vorstellen, dass sowas geht. Praktisch geht es nicht in unser Universum, weil die Stöckchen eine begrenzte Auflösung haben.
Ich finde das aber einen schwierigen Schritt, das einfach zu behaupten. Also, ich habe jetzt natürlich kein Gegenbeispiel, aber ich stelle mir das so vor, wie ein Drittel hat auch unendlich viele Nachkommastellen. Und bevor wir verstanden haben, dass man die nicht alle hinschreiben muss, hätte man ja auch so argumentieren können. Also ich stelle mir vor, im Universum könnte es irgendwie ein reales Vorkommnis, ein nicht abstraktes Vorkommnis von Pi geben. Aber das merken wir erst irgendwann in der Zukunft. Und bis dahin sieht das aus wie, was weiß ich, ein ungrades Vielfaches von Pi.
Das, was wir tun, ist, dass wir, wir finden ja Abstraktionen für diese Funktion. Also was wie ein Drittel lässt sich ja schön hinschreiben. Damit kann man rechnen, ohne es auszurechnen. Pi kannst du auch hinschreiben und damit kannst du irgendwie mit einer hinreichenden Nährung für alle praktischen Umstände. Also ich glaube, mehr als irgendwie 100 Stellen oder so wurde noch nie in der Praxis gerechnet.
Oh, doch, doch.
In der Praxis? Also ich meine so für...
Also wir wissen mehr Stellen als...
Also wo halt Pi eine praktische Anwendung hat und nicht nur die Neugier dich halt irgendwie in die Unendlichkeit führt.
Gibt's eigentlich Pi-Coin?
Ich glaube bisher noch nicht, aber hey, wir könnten... Aber ich glaube, dass halt dieser Punkt, dass wir Menschen halt irgendwie uns dann halt einfach Abstraktionen für solche schwierigen Probleme suchen, also diese Abkürzung suchen, macht es halt überhaupt nur möglich, darüber nachzudenken. Genau.
Naja, aber auch nur, du denkst ja nicht über die tatsächliche Sache nach, sondern über Abstraktion. Nee, aber das finde ich immer einen wichtigen Punkt, weil Abstraktionen sind nicht nur da, um dich über Dinge nachdenken zu lassen, über die du vorher nicht nachdenken willst.
Das machen sie praktikabel.
Abstraktionen funktionieren auch andersrum, dass sie dich beschränken in dem, worüber du nachdenken kannst, wenn es in der Abstraktion nicht vorgesehen ist. Naja, aber das ist ein Problem. Und ich finde so Aussagen von unseren aktuellen Abstraktionen auf das Universum immer so ein bisschen schwierig an der Stelle, weil es könnte halt sein, dass einfach unsere Abstraktion schon falsch war.
Die Mathematiker hatten das gleiche Problem. Das heißt, die Pythagoree haben Brüche zugelassen. Und dann war aber irgendwann die Frage, gibt es Zahlen, auf den Zahlenstrahl, die keine Brüche sind, da nicht richtig drauf passen? Und dann haben Leute innerhalb der Pythagoree, das war so ein Keimbund, rausgefunden, dass das so ist und das hat zu schlimmen Verwerfungen geführt.
Das muss auch heute jeder Matheunterricht einmal durch exerzierende Beweise. Ja, ne, das stimmt natürlich.
Und das kriegst du dann hin durch irgendwelche Limit-Geschichten. Kannst du diese Zahlen bestimmen, aber es läuft im Prinzip darauf hinaus, dass du einen Algorithmus angibst, mit dem sie bestimmt war, während, wenn jemand Zeit hätte, diesen Algorithmus auszuführen. Und man kann sozusagen zeigen, dass es im Prinzip gehen würde. Aber in der Informatik, in der Berechnung sieht es halt so aus, dass solange wie du es nicht berechnet hast, weißt du es halt nicht. Bis dahin kannst du nur eine Art Wahrscheinlichkeit angeben, dass es so ist.
Und das sind unsere Approximatoren? Am Ende, genau.
Bei Fließkommazahlen kann man zum Beispiel ganz gut sehen, dass einige Zahlen, die in Dezimal einfach aussehen, zur Basis 2 plötzlich eine Periode haben. Und ich kann mir einfach, ich finde das, was nicht wahrscheinlich ist, ist nur so eine Intuition, aber ich finde das irgendwie vermessen zu sagen, was wir im Moment für blockierend halten, ist auch so. Also ich stelle mir einfach vor, morgen könnte jemand kommen, der jetzt nicht bei Wurzel 2 und Pi und E, aber der einfach Kategorien von Problemen, die wir im Moment für unpraktikabel hielten, eben doch irgendwie lösbar macht. Und gerade wenn wir uns fragen, ob das Universum irgendetwas abbildet oder lösen kann, dann ist es aus meiner Sicht auch ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, okay, das Universum muss das berechnet haben. Was ist denn, wenn wir sozusagen etwas, das wir nur als Algorithmus kennen, im Universum vorfinden, aber als fertig berechnet irgendwo? Und wir wissen nicht, wo das herkam. Ja, sowas könnte ja vorkommen. Und dann kann man daraus eigentlich nicht folgern, dass es berechnet wurde, oder kann man das doch folgern?
Also, wenn irgendwas fertig berechnet ist, heißt das, du hast irgendwo praktisch eine Konstante reingetan, die du dann ausliest an der Stelle. Das ist einfach eine nicht komprimierbare Funktion. Berechnung heißt nichts anderes, als dass du in nicht komplett zufälliger Weise von Zustand zu Zustand gehst. Und in gewissen Weise ist die Physik damit beschäftigt, die Funktion zu finden, die benachbarte Zustände im Universum korreliert. Und natürlich können wir nicht rauskriegen, wie das Universum wirklich ist, solange wir drin sind. Und es sieht auch nicht so aus, ob wir herauskommen aus dem Ding. Das heißt, die Wahrheit finden wir nicht raus. Was wir herausfinden, ist ungefähr so die Karte der Theorien, die möglicherweise die Beobachtung erklären. Und dann können wir unsere Konfidenzen auf dieser Karte rumschieben. Und im Augenblick ist es so, dass wir noch keine komplett Karte haben. Es gibt keinen kompletten Kreis, den man irgendwie gefunden hat, wo man sagt, wenn ich diesen Automaten aufschreibe, dann kommt ein Universum raus. Aber es ist so, dass der Großteil der Physik mit einem geometrischen Universum beschäftigt ist. Das heißt, geometrisch heißt, dass es kontinuierlich ist, dass du einen Raum hast von bestimmter Dimensionalität oder mehreren von bestimmter Dimensionalität, die auf eine bestimmte Weise interagieren und halt dabei unendlich viele Nachkommastellen haben. Und es ist möglich, einen Großteil der Diskretheit der Quantenwelt abzuleiten aus diesem Continuum relativ natürlich. Das heißt, es gibt aus bestimmten Gründen, kriegst du dann so harmonische Requenzen und solche Sachen, aus denen dann diese ganz zahligen Verhältnisse kommen. Aber die spannende Frage ist, ist das möglicherweise falsch? Müssen wir den anderen Weg gehen? Und das Universum ist gar kein Hypercomputer, sondern ein digitaler, diskreter Computer. Was dafür spricht, ist erstmal, wir können sehr einfach einen diskreten Computer bauen. Wir wissen, wie das geht. So ein Automat aufzuschreiben ist super simpel. Wir können eine Mathematik aus Null sehr einfach einbauen. Und es ist sehr schwer, also wir wissen nicht, wie das geht, in der Mathematik einen Hypercomputer zu bauen, den das kontinuierliche Berechnung machen kann. Es gibt keine Sprache, in der das geht. Wenn es keine Sprache gibt, in der das geht, kann Gott das sozusagen nicht machen. Auch wenn er eine Sprache benutzt, er müsste etwas anderes benutzen, was nicht konstruktiv ist, über das man nicht reden kann, das man nicht beobachten, nicht zerlegen, über das man nicht nachdenken kann, das man auch nicht beobachten kann. Also stell dir vor, du hättest so ein Ding, was das Halteproblem löst. So ein Problem, wo du halt unendlich viele Schritte brauchst, um dahin zu kommen. So eine Art Orake, so ein Box. Kann das überhaupt existieren? Kannst du eine Beobachtung geben? Wenn ich dieses Ding aufmache, kann ich, das weiß ich schon mal, keinen Mechanismus sehen, der das tut, weil wir haben bewiesen, es gibt keinen Computer, der das Halteproblem lösen kann, keinen digitalen Computer. Also ist da drin auch kein Mechanismus, sozusagen erkennen kann, der das tut. Weil alles, was wir berechnen können, kann mit Mechanismus gemacht werden, umgekehrt.
Naja, das beinhaltet doch aber Annahmen über die Mechanismen, die es gibt. Es ist nicht denkbar, dass es einen Mechanismus gibt, den wir einfach nicht kennen.
Oder kann es vielleicht sein, dass es einfach nicht einen Mechanismus gibt? Also ich meine, die Welle-Teilchen-Dualität des Lichts ist ja schon mal ein erster Hinweis darauf, dass es möglicherweise mehrere parallel existierende Mechanismen gibt.
Wieso?
Naja, weil die die Ableitung vom einen auf das andere, soweit ich weiß, bisher noch nicht gelungen ist. In vollständiger Weise.
Es gibt mehrere Kandidaten, wie man die Welle-Teilchen-Dualität interpretieren kann. Die einfachste, das war die von Boehm und de Broglie, die Pilot-Wave-Theorie, die im Augenblick wie so ein Revival hat. Es gibt so ein paar Experimente, makroskopisch, kann man sich auf YouTube angucken, wo so eine Ölflüssigkeit nehmen und dann Tropfen mit der richtigen Viskosität aus dem Öl da drauf tropfen lassen. Wenn man das richtig macht, dann löst sich dieser Tropfen nicht auf in dem Öl, sondern springt zurück. Und dabei stößt er natürlich auf diese Oberfläche von dem Öl und es gibt eine Welle. Und wenn man den richtig aufbranen lässt, dann trifft er beim nächsten Wellental drauf und wird also immer weiter vorwärts katapultiert und erzeugt dabei gleichzeitig die Welle, auf der er vorwärts katapultiert wird. Das heißt, es gibt ein Teilchen und eine Welle. Und die Welle bestimmt, wie das Teilchen katapultiert wird. Und mit diesem Ding kann man Doppelspaltexperiment machen, makroskopisch und das reproduziert sozusagen diese Effekte vom Doppelspaltexperiment. Zum großen Teil. Die Nicht-Ortlichkeit bedeutet, dass es tatsächlich noch irgendwelche nicht-ortlichen Links zwischen verschiedenen Tröpfchen geben muss, aber das ist lösbar.
Möglicherweise, ja.
Ja, also die wichtige Implikation, aus der welchen Ungleichung es seit den 1960er-Jahren ist, dass es den Raum nicht als solchen gibt. Der Raum ist nicht elementar. Also die Welt ist nicht so eine Art Excel-Tabelle mit Zeitspalten und Raumzeilen, sozusagen, sondern es kommt vor, dass ich sozusagen in der einen Zelle was schreibe und es verändert sich drüber in der anderen Zelle gleichzeitig was. Und das bedeutet, diese Zelleninhalte sind eigentlich Pointer auf etwas, was außerhalb vom Raum liegt. Die Daten im Universum werden außerhalb von ihren Raumpositionen gespeichert. Das Universum ist nicht so eine Art großer Schwamm, wo lauter Zellen sind und in den Zellen steht dann die Information drin. Sondern es ist wahrscheinlich besser, stellt man sich das vor, als so eine Art Graphen. Und in diesen Graphen kann Information fließen. Und aus einem bestimmten Grund ist es so, dass dieser Graph, wenn man sehr weit rauszoomt, sich in einen dreidimensionalen Raum einbetten lässt. Wenn man sehr weit reinzoomt, ist er viel hochdimensionaler.
Um noch mal ganz kurz dabei zu bleiben, weil ich finde, diese Frage von diskret versus kontinuierlich ist schon relativ elementar für den Rest der Diskussion. Und trotzdem, selbst wenn wir annehmen, dass diese Pilot-Wave-Theorie, dass es die Wellen des Teilchens des selben Phänomenen sind, die eng miteinander verbunden sind, bleibt aber trotzdem der Punkt, dass das Teilchen eine diskrete Entität ist und die Welle eine kontinuierliche Entität ist. Das heißt also, wir hätten dann tatsächlich diese Dualität nicht aufgelöst, sondern nur ihren Zusammenhang erklärt.
Die Idee ist, dass es praktisch ein Feld gibt und ein Element gibt, das wie so ein Feld interagiert. Und die beiden beeinflussen sich gegenseitig. Es steht also eine Art stehende Welle, so ein Informationsbündel, was sich selbst erhält und weiter katapultiert. Und es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, darüber nachzudenken, wie das funktioniert. Und in der klassischen Quantenmechanik läuft es, glaube ich, darauf hinaus. Also in der Nicht-Pilot-Wave-Quanten-Mechanik, dass diese Wellen so was wie Solitonen sind. Soliton ist eine Welle, die sich selbst nicht verliert, die sich nicht auflöst. Man kriegt die zum Beispiel in Wasser hin, wenn man einen sehr schmalen Kanal hat und so eine Bugwelle von einem Schiff genau richtig timet, dann hat man eine Welle, die sich nicht verändert und nicht den ganzen Kanal durchläuft, weil sie halt in diesem Kanal irgendwo hinfließen kann, um ihre Informationen zu verlieren. Wenn man eine flache Oberfläche hat und dann eine Welle breitet sich in alle Richtungen aus und zerfließt. Aber es gibt auch noch flachen Oberflächewellen, die sich nicht auflösen. Zum Beispiel so Wasserwirbel. Die gehen durch die Reibung irgendwann weg, aber ansonsten sind die Rotationen stabil. Die Rotation führt dazu, dass die Information lokal bleibt. Eine Rotation ist so eine Art kontinuierliche Permutation. Und mathematisch kann man jetzt gucken, welche Arten von kontinuierlichen Permutationen gibt es. Zum Beispiel ist auch ein Rauchring so eine Art Soliton. Das ist eine Art kontinuierliche Permutation, dieser Torus, der sich da weiter dreht. Und witzigerweise ist es so, dass man, wenn man die Mathematik durchgeht, in 1D kann man natürlich keine Rotation machen. In 2D gibt es zwei Arten von Rotation, nämlich welche um einen Punkt, das sind die orkidischen Rotationen. Und im orkidischen Raum, im hyperbolischen Raum, da ist der Punkt praktisch weg, im unendlichen, kann man hyperbolische Rotation machen. Das sind die zwei Rotationen, die in 2D gehen. Und in 3D gibt es witzigerweise nur 2D-Rotationen. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel diesen Torus anguckt, der funktioniert nicht richtig in 3D, weil der Torus wurde da gequetscht auf der Innenseite. Der ist innen schmaler als außen. Das heißt, wenn man sich vorstellt, der Raum hat keine Krümmung, ist flach, das funktioniert nicht. Der Torus passt da nicht richtig rein, dann müsste der Raum sich biegen. Damit der Raum sich biegen kann, muss sich mindestens eine Dimension höher gehen. Das heißt, in 4D kann nicht so ein Torus machen, der sich rotiert, so eine Art Rauchring. Und in 4D würde es dann wieder gehen. Dazu korrespondiert, dass komplexe Zahlen in 2D existieren. Es gibt welche in 4D, aber keine in 3D. Oder wenn man Computergrafik macht, fällt einem das auch auf. Komplexe Zahlen haben eine total witzige Eigenschaft. Die sind so definiert, dass man mit diesem Imaginärteil, mit diesem I, normalerweise komplexe Zahlen, sind einfach Paarzahlen. Das sind Zahlenpaare, praktisch Koordinatenpaare. Dieses A plus BI, A und B sind XY-Koordinaten. Und das I ist dazu da, damit sich der B-Teil nicht wegkürzt. Dieser Imaginärteil, die Y-Koordinate. Und I ist so definiert, normalerweise ist es die Wurzel aus Minus 1. Eine etwas seltsame Zahl, die aber die praktische Eigenschaft hat, dass man sich selbst multipliziert, kommt halt Minus 1 raus. Man kann damit rechnen, kann es eventuell wegkürzen. Und wenn man jetzt diese komplexen Zahlen nimmt, wenn man die zusammen addiert, dann hat man eine Translation in 2D. Und wenn man sie multipliziert mit dem Realteil, dann kriegt man eine Skalierung. Wenn man sie mit dem Imaginärteil multipliziert, kriegt man eine Rotation. Das ist also ziemlich cool, man hat da eine Algebra, mit der Addition und Multiplikation und Rotation möglich sind. Und diese Rotation funktioniert in 3D nicht so richtig. Wir merken das, wenn wir ein Grafikobjekt haben, wenn wir so was koden, wir können das im Raum drehen ein bisschen, mit zum Beispiel drei eukligischen Winkeln, dreht das um jede Achse ein bisschen. Wir wollen das jetzt in eine andere Position drehen, also in ein Smooth, von A nach B, ne? Und wenn wir da einfach zwischen den drei Rotationsachsen interpolieren, dann dreht das Ding sich nicht gleichmäßig. Und noch schlimmer als wenn wir irgendwelche Nulldurchgänge haben, dann dividieren wir durch Null und das funktioniert gar nicht. Da muss man ganz viele Fallunterscheidungen machen. Und deswegen macht man einen ganz einfachen Trick, man macht diese Rotation einfach in 4D mit Quaternions. Das läuft so, man nimmt einfach eine Achse, die definiert man als ein Vektor mit drei Koordinaten, den kann man auch schön interpolieren und dann die vierte Zahl ist die Rotation um diese Achse. Das heißt, jede Rotation in 3D ist eine 2D-Rotation um eine Achse. Und dafür brauchen wir halt vier Zahlen, um das ordentlich aufzuschreiben. Man kann halt in 2D dieses i definieren, man kann aber in 3D kein passendes i und j definieren, damit es geht. Aber in 4D kann man i, j und k definieren, mit dem sich auch solche komplexen Zahlen bauen lassen. Und in 8D geht es noch, das sind die Oktonions, danach ist aber Schluss. Und das heißt, die Menge der Rotationen, die mathematisch möglich sind, ist begrenzt. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, angenommen Teilchen sind sowas wie kontinuierliche Wirbel in der Materie, die deswegen Wirbel sein müssen, damit ihre Information nicht zerfließt, wenn sie über große Strecken sich fortbewegen müssen, dann muss da irgendeine Rotation stattfinden. Und im Augenblick gibt es eine Reihe von Physikern, die darüber nachdenken, dass man ja einfach so vom First Principles die Menge der Rotation sich angucken kann und siehe da, das matcht ziemlich schön zu den Spino Spaces der Quantenmechanik. Das heißt dann tatsächlich, diese Eigenschaften, die Partikel haben, die lassen sich wiederfinden.
Okay, das wäre dann tatsächlich die Vereinigung der beiden Problemfelder.
Ja, wobei diese Theorien kontinuierlich sind. Also die gehen davon aus, dass es kontinuierlich ist.
Was gegen deine Theorie an das Computation-Universität?
Das Ding ist, es geht im Augenblick nicht richtig auf. Die kommen in Probleme mit der Renormalisierung, dass da irgendwelche Sachen laufen und endlich gehen, die nie davon endlich gehen sollten. Und wissen nicht genau, wie es mit der Gravitation zusammenpasst.
Gravitation, das ist wirklich stört die immer.
Und möglicherweise passiert diese Kontinuität nur deswegen, wenn du genügend Teilchen zusammen hast, genauso wie in der Thermodynamik, wenn du halt sehr viele Teilchen hast, dann hast du Temperatur. Bei einzelnen Teilchen gibt es keine Temperatur. Bei einzelnen Teilchen gibt es auch keinen Druck, sondern das gibt es nur als eine Compound-Eigenschaft. Oder wenn du dir Flüssigkeiten anguckst, du hast halt diese Wellen und Wirbel in Flüssigkeiten. Aber wir wissen, in den Flüssigkeiten sind eigentlich nur einzelne Teilchen, die miteinander diese Dynamik haben, die statistisch dann zum Fluss so aussieht wie Wellen. Und möglicherweise ist in der Physik auch so. Das heißt, es gibt zum Fluss diskretere Teile, die drunter liegen, über denen wir emigrieren, die wir nicht beobachten können. Und fieserweise sind wir möglicherweise auch wahrscheinlich nicht die ganze Zeit anwesend. Also angenommen, dass Universen besteht tatsächlich aus solchen Wellen, die miteinander interagieren, dann heißt das ja nicht, dass sie die ganze Zeit miteinander interagieren, sondern es gibt Stellen, wo sie halt nicht miteinander interagieren, wo sie durcheinander durchfließen. Weil man halt nicht in der gleichen Phase ist. Und wenn man sich das so klarmacht, wenn es möglich ist, dass die Schrödingerkatze sozusagen in Superposition geht, with respect to us, oder der Quantencomputer, das Q-Bild in Superposition geht im Verhältnis zu uns, dann heißt das natürlich auch, dass wir im Verhältnis zu diesem Q-Bild in Superposition gehen können. Also aus diesem Q-Bild gesehen sind wir in Superposition. Im Prinzip ist es also so, dass wir alle Schrödingerkatzen sind, die in die Existenz blinken und wieder raus. Aber da wir uns gegenseitig messen, tun wir das in der gleichen Phase. Und das ist sehr spekulativ, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Aber mir kommt das so vor, als sei es denkbar, dass wir also sozusagen nicht die ganze Zeit in der Evolution des Universums existieren, sondern nur in regelmäßigen Timeslices, in denen wir uns halt gegenseitig beobachten, sodass wir jetzt nicht merken, was dazwischen passiert.
Aber wo kommt der Clock her?
Welche Clock?
Für die Timeslaces.
Die Clock ergibt sich praktisch direkt aus dieser elementaren Transitionsfunktion des Universums. Da gibt es irgendwie so ein Bit, was in dem Beut vor sich hingelitscht und nacheinander alle entgegen Automaten erzeugt in Superposition. Und das, was übrig bleibt, was sich nicht gegenseitig auscancelt, ist halt ein Universum, was ab einer bestimmten Stufe in der Lage ist, Partikel-Dynamiken zu erzeugen, die nicht auseinanderfallen. Und nur in diesem Teil existieren wir.
Mich interessiert ja das Auscanceln an der Stelle.
Das würde halt auch bedeuten, dass es ja mehrere unterschiedliche Auscanceln gibt. Also mehrere Parallele gibt es.
Du, da gibt es einige Sci-Fi-Serien, die plötzlich recht haben, wenn das stimmt.
Weil du hast ja, also du hättest ja dann nicht nur ein Universum, sondern du hättest ja mehrere mögliche Universen. Weil es ja nicht nur eine synchrone Phase gäbe.
Ja, aus unserer Perspektive ist das Universum genau das, was mit uns wechselwirkt. Also wo Information zu uns zurückfließt. Das, wo bloß Information wegfließt, gehört nicht dazu.
Aber es könnte halt problemlos in so einem Modell auch mehrere Universen geben. Weil du ja, also es müssen ja nur andere Phasen sein.
Ja.
Also die halt nicht mit uns in Konzentration sind.
Genau, aber wahrscheinlich sind diese anderen Phasen ganz ähnlich wie unsere. Die sind halt nur ein kleines bisschen Phasen verschoben.
Ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall interessant.
Es ist auch vorstellbar, dass das Universum sozusagen ständig aufbrancht.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist in der Sci-Fi gerade in letzter Zeit relativ...
Was ist da schon abgelutscht?
Na ja, in letzter Zeit...
Nein, aber Dimensionen über die Phase abzubilden, finde ich ausgesprochen interessant.
Ja, aber es gibt ja gerade in der Sci-Fi diesen Trend, dass diese parallel Universums entweder Zeitlinien oder halt parallel Universen, die anhand von Ereignissen aufbranchen...
Das kommt gerade wieder?...
ist gerade voll der Fit, letztens. Gutes Zeug dabei, also Charles Stross zum Beispiel, im March in Princess Sirius sehr zu empfehlen, wirklich sehr ordentlich. Oder hier Gibson Peripheral, geht ja in eine ähnliche Richtung, ist gerade ziemlich gut.
In welche Rick und Morty Folge war das mit den Zeitlinien?
Ich kenne das nicht aus, wenn ich insofern weiß, ich nicht.
Sag mal, du lässt dich mit deinen physischen Erkenntnissen, physikalischen Erkenntnissen nicht von Rick und Morty inspirieren, oder?
Nee, ich habe aber den Eindruck, dass Dan Harmon ungefähr die relevanteste Inkarnation des Weltgeistes ist im Moment. Ich muss mal gucken, er hat eine total tolle Biografie in Wikipedia drin, die man sehr liebevoll eingepflegt hat. Geht damit los, dass seine Eltern ihn mit sieben Jahren vor den Fernseher gesetzt haben und ihn da haben sitzen lassen, weil sie arbeiten mussten. Und zwei Jahre später, von unentwegten Starren auf den Bildschirm, hat er einen Klick gemacht und er dachte sich, ich sehe das System. Und dann hat er angefangen, Drehbücher zu schreiben. Er hat sich dann mit der ganzen Welt überworfen, hat eine TV-Show gemacht und hat dann auf dem Set geschlafen und alle Leute angebrüllt und sich politisch ungerecht verhalten, bis sie ihn rausgeschmissen haben nach vier Seasons. Und danach hat es aber nicht mehr geklappt ohne ihn, weil sie haben halt nur eine Kopie gemacht von dem, was er machte. Weil er hat halt wirklich was kapiert. Wenn man sich Rick und Morty anguckt, das hat wirklich einen sehr interessanten Metastruktur, die hinter dem einen drin steckt. Das sind diese ganzen Quatsch-Episoden im Vordergrund. Wenn man rauszoomt, dann hat dieses Ding eine Gestalt. Das ist sehr interessant. Es ist wirklich die Gesamtheit der Theorien von künstlicher Intelligenz und der Natur der Existenz und der Physik, die man so ungefähr runterbrechen kann, dass man die leicht versteht. Und der daraus resultierende Nihilismus. Also was passiert, wenn du das intelligenteste Säugetier im Universum bist? Und die beste Beziehung, die ich jemals hattest, war mit so einem Körperfresser-Hive-Mind. Ich weiß nicht, kennst du die Episode?
Nein, ich hab, wie gesagt, nicht so viel Zeit zum Seriengucken. Insofern kenn ich sie nicht.
Also Rick und Morty kann man schon mal reinschieben.
Ich fürchte, man muss, also es ist ja ein Hurd, es ist inzwischen so Background, dass es ein Anti-Status-Signal ist, in den meisten Kreisen, Rick und Morty gut zu finden, aber...
Nein, nein, nein, erst zu sagen, wenn du es einfach still und leise genießt, hat keiner ein Problem damit. Aber damit missionieren zu gehen, und das gilt ja meines Erachtens immer, sobald die Leute anfangen zu missionieren, ist scheiße.
Also wenn ich mal im Twitter-Timeline glauben kann, dann ist das Problem gar nicht Rick und Morty selbst, sondern die Fans, die Rick und Morty hat, also Leute wie wir.
Genau, Leute, die rumlaufen und erzählen, sie finden Rick und Morty geil.
Also noch mal zurück zum Computational Universe.
Wieso ist denn das überhaupt ein Problem? Oder sagen wir mal eine interessante Frage, ob das Universum diskret ist oder kontinuierlich. Das hast du jetzt so noch nicht wirklich beleuchtet, sondern nur so im Halbsatz anderer Seite.
Ich habe den Verdacht, dass es der Grund, weshalb wir es nicht geschafft haben, oder die Physiker es nicht geschafft haben, die Physik aufzulösen, obwohl die so schlau sind und seit 100 Jahren im Prinzip die wesentlichen Ideen zu haben scheinen und die meisten Ferien enthalten, dass es möglicherweise der falsche Ansatz ist, nämlich dass wir so eine zeitlose Mathematik benutzen. Und nicht eine Mathematik, bei der man tatsächlich alles ausrechnen muss. Es gibt zum Beispiel dann möglicherweise im Universum das Prinzip, was Wolfram korportationale Irreduzibilität nennt, also dass du keinen analytischen Shortcut hast, dass du nicht einfach jetzt ausrechnen kannst, wie das Universum in Zukunft aussehen wird, ohne das Universum bis an diese Stelle laufen zu lassen. Das könnte zum Beispiel heißen, dass ein Photon zum Beispiel, wenn es durch diesen Doppelspalt geht, es hat halt einfach keine Position im Raum, weil den Raum gibt es nicht. Was es in Wirklichkeit gibt, ist ein Graf. Und dieser Graf, den kannst du, wenn du so wie wir bist und weit rauszoomst und ein bisschen blinzelt, als 3D-Schwamm auffassen, als so ein 3D-Lattice, als so ein Gitter aus 3D. Aber es ist nicht genau ein 3D-Gitter. In diesem Gitter gibt es manchmal zu viele Links. Also Links, die nicht nur benachbarte Positionen im Gitter verbinden, sondern die größere Distanzen überwinden. Und das ist dann Non-Locality. Und diese Non-Locality führt aber nicht dazu, dass du Informationen da hinschicken kannst. Weil, damit du weißt, wo die Information herkommt, brauchst du mehr als ein Bit. Du brauchst so viele Bits, dass du rauskriegst, aus welche Richtung das gekommen ist.
Kannst du schon hinschicken, aber halt nicht einzeln.
Du weißt halt nicht, woher das Bit kommt. Du müsstest dazu parallel auf dem klassischen Informationskanal ein Partikel schicken, irgendein Photon, also irgendein Gleiter, der sein Momentum-Information erhält, damit du weißt, wo diese Information hergekommen ist. Ein einzelnes Link reicht nicht aus.
So, aber...
Und wenn du zu wenig Links hast, dann kriegst du Nicht-Ortlichkeit. Also Non-Locality und diese Superposition ergibt sich daraus, dass du etwas nicht mehr in Raum werfen kannst, weil es zu wenig Links hat, um trianguliert zu werden auf einer Raumposition.
Ich finde, das Konzept mit der Irreduzierbarkeit ist eigentlich schon lange in der Mathematik und Physik angekommen, in Form von Differentialgleichung. Ja, also es gibt schon, auch jetzt schon diverse Probleme, wo es nicht gelingt, zumindest, sagen wir mal so, eine absolute Lösung zu finden, sondern du musst dich daran simulieren, oder, sagen wir mal, Wettervorhersage, da gibt es auch keine tolle Funktion für dich.
Genau, das berühmte zum Beispiel ist das Drei-Körper-Problem. Das ist ein System, was dann so chaotisch ist, dass du nicht mehr voraussagen kannst, wie sie drei Körper, die sich im Raum umkreisen.
Genau, es sind halt drei Körper, die sich im Raum umkreisen. Es gibt auch einen ganz hervorragenden chinesischen Seifi mit demselben Namen, der Free-Body-Problem.
Frank hat gerade Sommerferien genutzt.
Hey, die Leute freuen sich über das.
Das wird eine etwas längere Buchliste diesmal.
Die Leute freuen sich über... Ja, hast du gelesen? Einer der besseren Seifi-Serien der letzten Jahre, muss ich sagen. Ich find auch ein bisschen deprimierend am Ende.
Du meinst wegen der Dark-Forest-Hypothesis?
Ihr werdet doch jetzt hier nicht spoilern, oder?
Na ja.
Schäm dich.
Hast du noch nicht gelesen? Jetzt dürfen wir nicht spoilern. Ja, das ist tatsächlich wegen der Dark-Forest-Hypothesis, ja.
Ich dachte, die kennen doch alle inzwischen. Es ist notwendig, dass man sich das klarmacht.
Na ja, es gibt halt, na gut, ich meine, es gibt halt die Gegentheorie jetzt, dass halt, also die Dark-Forest-Hypothesis ist basically, wenn du im Universum bist als eine Zivilisation, die sich innerhalb des Universums bewegen kann, hast du ein großes Incentive, auf alle anderen, von denen du weißt, erst mal auszurotten. Weil du nicht wissen kannst, ob die halt irgendwie daherkommen, um dich auszurotten. So, und heißt das, wenn du Piep sagst und deine Location im Universum irgendwie, ja, von dir gibts, Bekannt gibts. Bekannt gibts, dann ist halt irgendwie relativ klar, dass halt irgendwie, dann ist halt nicht allzu lange dauert. So, es gibt jetzt halt die Gegenthese, die halt sagt, na ja, wir senden jetzt halt schon so lange Fernsehen, dass irgendwie sehr unwahrscheinlich ist da draußen, wenn das noch irgendjemand anderes auf dem selben Entwicklungsniveau ist. Möglicherweise ist dieses Universum gerade halt rein zufällig quasi wie für uns gemacht, und alle anderen sind weit hinterher.
Na ja, also 100 Jahre, oder? Na ja.
Also könnte auch einfach sein, dass überlichtschnelles Reisen nicht möglich ist.
Kannst ja auch ausrechnen, wie weit du in 100 Jahren kommst.
Ja klar, ich mein, kann halt...
Wenn du mir ein Signal auswendest, das Universum ist halt echt groß.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn überlichtschnelles Reisen nicht möglich ist, dann ist das Problem ja sowieso egal. Weil dann hätten wir genug Zeit.
Na ja, nur weil die schnell zu uns kämen, heißt es ja nicht, dass sie nicht trotzdem warten müssen, bis das Signal auf regulärem Wege bei ihnen ankommt.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendwie die... Also, wie gesagt, die beiden Optionen sind entweder, es gibt kein überlichtschnelles Reisen oder wir sind die Ersten.
Die Frage ist einfach, wie häufig Leben ist. Also, wie wahrscheinlich ist A-Biogenesis? Also, dass Leben aus nicht Leben entsteht. Du brauchst halt eine komplette Zelle, damit Leben entsteht. Und eine komplette Zelle ist halt eine Turing-Maschine, diese DNA ist, und du hast eine Maschine mit einem Treibbläsekopf, ziemlich buchstäblich, total verrückt, wenn man sich das überlegt, ne? Und die DNA implementiert, das sind zellulären Automaten, mit denen die Zelle regelmäßige Zustandsübergänge machen kann. Und außerdem braucht sie den NEC-Entropy-Harvester, damit sie Struktur bauen kann, indem sie Energie aus der Umgebung abschöpft und einen Selbstreplikationsmechanismus. Und wenn irgendwas davon fehlt, ist es keine Zelle und lebt nicht. Und damit du die erste Zelle kriegst, musst du wahrscheinlich die kosmischen Würfel verdammt oft rollen.
Na gut, aber das Universum ist doch echt verdammt groß.
Naja, also der interessante Punkt ist halt, dass wir mittlerweile wissen, dass halt diese Biosporen-Geschichte aus dem Universum Panspermi meinst du? immer wahrscheinlicher wird. Also es wird ja, man findet ja auch immer wieder Aminosäuren auf irgendwelchen...
Ja, also es ist ja so gut wie nachgewiesen eigentlich. Es ist noch keine Zelle gefunden worden, aber die Idee...
Naja, Aminosäuren können auch so entstehen.
Genau. Aber das halt...
Ja, Zellen können auch so entstehen.
Aber es hilft halt sehr, wenn du schon mal Aminosäuren hast, wenn du eine Zelle willst. Insofern...
Naja, wobei, man weiß ja nicht, vielleicht gibt es noch andere Arten, auf die man eine Zelle ausbauen kann.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich mehr Planeten, auf denen spontan mechanische Uhren entstanden sind, als welche auf den Zellen entstanden sind. Die Uhren replizieren sich natürlich nicht, aber...
Um noch mal kurz auf dieses Universumsproblem zurückzukommen.
Ich bin ja noch beim Physikproblem, aber macht das mal.
Das hängt ja eng damit zusammen. Also wenn wir sozusagen sagen, ein kontinuierliches Universum könnte kein Computational Universe sein, weil es energetisch nicht hinhaut. Also es ist nicht genug Masse da, um es irgendwie zu erledigen. Dann wäre die Frage, wie funktioniert so ein Computation-Mechanismus? So und er könnte ja auch auf der Basis von seiner Dualität funktionieren. Also wenn halt ein Teilchen nur ein Ausdruck eines lokalen kontinuierlichen Wirbels ist, wäre er trotzdem eine Abstraktion, die Computation ermöglicht, dass sozusagen nur die Teilchen an sich und deren Interaktion halt den Automaten darstellen, auch wenn sie auf Wellen reiten.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Leute, die versucht haben, das umzusetzen. Zum Beispiel Ed Redken, ein Außenseiter in der Physik, der ist vor allem durch die Redken Gates bekannt geworden. Das sind Gates, die keine Bits löschen und deswegen keinen Energieverbrauch. Wenn man ein Bit löschen will, muss man es trotzdem irgendwo speichern und so weiter. Aber man kann damit theoretisch Computer bauen, die um einiges effizienter sind als die heutigen. Aber ansonsten ist er ein Vertreter der digitalen Physik und hat sich damit beschäftigt, zu einer Art Pilot-Wave-Theorie zu entwickeln, die digital ist, komplett. Das ist nicht sehr vollständig und fragmentarisch. Ich bin nicht mal sicher, ob er weiß, dass es eine Pilot-Wave-Theorie ist. Aber es ist ziemlich cool.
Wie nennt ihr es denn?
Er hat das NACL-Modell, also Natur- und Chlorid-Modell, weil es aus so einem Raster besteht, so einem phobischen Gitter, wo immer benachbarte Zellen unterschiedliche Typen haben, so wie bei Salzkristallen halt. Und ein Photon in seinem Modell ist so eine Art Zylinder, der eine Scheibe ist, mehrere Meter Durchmesser und ein paar Nanometer, also die Wellenlänge des Lichtes lang. Du kannst diese Zylinder hinten abschneiden sozusagen, die Wellenlänge verkürzen, wenn du von dem Photon den Schwanz abschneidest. Geht ja, dann verändert sich halt die Wellenlänge des Lichtes. Und wenn du was anders aus der Scheibe rausschneidest, dann vervollständigt sich wieder, aber es geht halt Information über die Richtung des Photons verloren. Das heißt, das Licht wird gebeugt. Die Lichtbeugung bedeutet einfach, dass Information über den Momentumvektor des Lichtes verloren geht. Und dieses Licht ist halt wirklich eine metagroße Scheibe. Und diese Lücken, die wir im Doppelspalt-Experiment sehen, die sehen für uns sehr schmal aus. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es halt so, dass alle Teilchen verschwommen sind. Deswegen passt das Licht da durch. Aber wenn du das gesamte Licht einfangen willst, um rauszukriegen, wo es herkommt, dann brauchst du ein sehr großes Spiegelteleskop. Wenn du ein kleineres Spiegelteleskop hast, hast du halt schlechtere Auflösungen, weil du nicht genau rauskriegst, wo das Licht hergekommen ist. Das ist ein Teil seines Modells. Puh, hat er mir alles erzählt. Die Physiker mögen den Fredke nicht so sehr, weil er keine Lust hat, das umzurechnen in ihre Mathematik. Und er redet nicht so gerne mit den Physikern. Und dann reden die Physiker auch nicht so gerne mit ihm, sondern er macht nur seine Computersimulation.
Das klingt nur von dem Gedanken aus, dass irgendwie ein Abbild schärfer wird, wenn du ein großes Teleskop hast und hat von da aus zurückgerechnet.
Das war eher nur eine seiner Einsichten, die gut zu seinem Modell passen.
Ach so, okay, verstehe.
Aber seine Einsicht war eher, wenn du so eine Art Gleiter bauen willst, ähnlich wie in Game of Life, der eine Richtung beibehält. Und die Richtung soll sehr fein aufgelöst sein und du hast so ein kurbisches Gitter, auf dem das alles läuft.
Also kurz zur Erklärung, ein Gleiter ist ein Automat in Game of Life, der sich halt einfach in eine Richtung fortbewegt, indem er den Regeln von Game of Life folgt.
Wir haben noch nicht mehr erklärt, was Game of Life ist.
Das tun wir einfach in die Links, weil das muss man sich einfach mal angucken. Oder willst du es kurz erklären?
Nein.
Ich kann es kurz machen. Game of Life wurde von John Convy in 1950 entdeckt oder erfunden. Man braucht dazu einfach ein Kästchengitter 2D. Und die Kästchen sind Zellen. Und die Zellen können entweder Leben oder Tod sein. Jede Zelle hat acht Nachbarn, so ein Kästchengitter. Klar, seht ihr vor euch. Und wenn eine Zelle genau zwei oder drei Nachbarn hat, dann bleibt sie am Leben. Wenn sie weniger als zwei hat, dann stirbt sie, weil sie zu einsam wird. Und wenn sie mehr als drei hat, dann stirbt sie, weil sie ihr zu eng wird. Und wenn ein leeres Feld genau drei Nachbarn hat, dann entsteht an der Stelle eine neue Zelle. Und das Tolle ist, wenn man jetzt irgendeine zufällige Anfangskombination nimmt und das Ding einschaltet, also schrittweise weiterrechnet, dann fängt das an zu blubbern. Und zum Schluss kommt es im allgemeinen periodischen Zustand.
Oder es stirbt aus.
Genau, das ist Period 1, der langweilige periodische Zustand. Da gibt es Muster, die sich selbst weiterkoppieren, das sind die Gleiter.
Das ist im Grunde ein zellulärer Automat mit ganz einfachem vordefinierten Rätum.
Das war die erste Erkenntnis zum zellulären Automaten.
Das ist der berühmteste zelluläre Automat.
Da gibt es Leute wie Wolfram, der versucht hat, eine ganze Mathematik auf zelluläre Automaten aufzubauen. Ich hab's nicht ganz durch das Bruch geschafft, muss ich gestehen, das war auch ein bisschen zu lang.
Aber es gibt einen super einfachen zellulären Automaten, der Turing-vollständig ist. Wolfram und Minsky haben sich gestritten, wer von ihnen den einfacheren Automaten gefunden hat.
Und welche hast du?
Ich hab's vergessen, genau, welche Regel es war. Es war eine verdammt kurze Regel, die hat ein 2D-Automat weiter rechnen und man kann damit Turing-Vollständigkeit, jedes beliebige Ding machen. Aber Game of Life ist auch Turing-Vollständig. Das ist deutlich komplizierter als dieses Ding. Das heißt, du kannst in Game of Life einen Computer bauen.
Okay, wir sind aber gerade abgestellt von deinem Satz, wo du nur den Begriff Gleiter verwendet hast und ich den eigentlich nur kurz erklären wollte.
Genau, also ein Gleiter ist ein sich selbst vorwärts pehlendes Muster. Und das Ding ist, dass die Game of Life Gleiter sehr brittle sind. Also wenn man dann ein Loch in das Rasterstand, so eine kleine Raumkrümmung hat, sodass da mal ein Pixel mehr oder weniger als acht Nachbarn hat, dann gehen die Gleiter halt kaputt. Und unser Universum hat wahrscheinlich kein komplett glattes Lattes, sondern da der Raum gekrümmt ist, ist das Lattes halt ungleichmäßig. Da, wo das gekrümmt ist, ist das Lattes halt dichter, ne?
Aber Licht kommt trotzdem noch durch.
Ja, das heißt bis Licht, die Photonen, sind halt die Gleiter, die sich auf 3D-Mapen lassen, auf beliebige Entfernungen, dabei nicht kaputt gehen. Das heißt, die müssen verdammt robust sein gegen Störungen um Lattes. Und vielleicht gibt es einfach nicht so viele, die diese Eigenschaft haben. Und damit so ein Gleiter robust ist gegen Störungen, müsste es wahrscheinlich so sein, dass es so kodiert ist, dass die Nachbarfelder in dem Lattes ähnliche Werte haben. So dass es eine kleine Störung da ist, fällt das nicht ins Gewicht und gleicht sich wieder aus. Und wenn das ähnliche Wert heißt, dann ist der Gleiter sozusagen kontinuierlich. Der muss nahezu kontinuierlich sein, damit das funktioniert.
Damit die Lichtausbreitung funktioniert.
Damit der Gleiter nicht kaputt geht. Das heißt, der Gleiter ist so eine Art stehende Welle, die sich weiter gruppiert, wie so ein Wirbel.
Okay, aber ist er kontinuierlich oder ist er eine Interaktion zwischen benachbarten Zuständen?
Er muss nicht total kontinuierlich sein, er muss nur kontinuierlich genug sein, wenn du... Also es reicht aus, du kannst ja eine Strömungssynamik auch auf ein diskretes Modell machen, sieht trotzdem aus wie Strömungssynamik, wenn du genügend Elemente hast.
Ja, wenn du genügend Elemente hast, ja, genau.
Was folgt denn aus dem Stand, was folgt dann für das Standardmodell aus dem Universum, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass die Teilchen alle irgendwie Programme sind?
Na, es gibt einen ernsthaften Physiker, sozusagen der von den Physikern ernst genommen wird, weil er Nobelpreis hat für seine Beiträge zum Standardmodell und der heißt TOFT. Und der hat angefangen, die Quantenmechanik zu diskretisieren. Das heißt, der versucht, Modelle zu machen, die komplett diskret sind und Elemente des Standardmodells von Grund auf nachbilden. Und der hat bis jetzt keine Stelle gefunden, wo er ist noch nicht fertig damit. Wo er festgestellt ist, würde er jetzt nicht mehr gehen.
Und der hat sich ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mit der Gravitation und der starken und der schwachen Wechselwirkung beschäftigt.
Es gibt doch starke und schwache Wechselwirkungen schon. Vermutlich läuft es darauf hinaus, dass die schwache und schwache Wechselwirkungen halt Leiter sind, die in höherdimensionalen Spinoff Spaces definiert sind. Das heißt, die sind halt nicht in 3D, sondern von uns aus gesehen werden die in einem Raum verwischt. Und die funktionieren auch nur wenige hundert Plancklängen lang. Danach brechen die zusammen.
Ja, okay, das ist ein Argument dafür, dass die ich einen, ja. Also die Frage ist halt, wieso haben irgendwie Elektromagnetismus und Gravitation sozusagen nicht allzu große Ausbreitungs...
In diesem Gedankenexperiment. Ich wollte eigentlich noch auf eine andere Sache hinaus. Wir haben da neulich schon über geredet und da hattest du so eine These, ob aus der Diskretheit des Universums folgt, dass es sozusagen einen Quantencomputer geben kann oder nicht. Wenn das Universum diskret ist, meint es zu, geht kein Quantencomputer.
Ja, man kann natürlich Quantencomputer bauen. Sie werden nur nicht schneller sein als klassischer. Das heißt, wir werden feststellen, natürlich weil es diese Nicht-Ortlichkeit gibt, dass wir diese Nicht-Ortlichkeit benutzen können, um Computer damit zu bauen. Also es gibt diese Überlagerung in den Qbits, die Nicht-Ortlichkeit und die Superposition sind die wesentlichen Phänomene, die man exploiten kann. Und im Prinzip läuft das darauf hinaus auf die Frage, ob diese Dualität oder diese Überlagerung von den Bits im Qbit, dass sie beide Zustände gleichzeitig haben, bedeutet, dass das Universum mehr Information hat oder dass es weniger Information hat. Es könnte ja auch sein, dass diese Überlagerung sich einfach dadurch ergibt, dass diese Stelle im Universum noch nicht ausgerechnet ist. Das heißt, es ist ein Informationsdefizit. Das Universum hat an dieser Stelle noch nicht fertig gerechnet. Und aus mathematischer Sicht ist das sozusagen nahezu äquivalent. Du projizierst einfach etwas, was noch nicht fertig gerechnet ist, auf die beiden Möglichkeiten. Und diese Projektion kostet den Mathematiker nichts. Aber komputational kostet das was.
Weil du musst es am Ende ausrechnen.
Genau. Also stell dir zum Beispiel mal vor, du hättest eine Spielwelt, jetzt ein Gedankenexperiment, die besteht aus so einem kubischen Lettes wie bei Threadkin. Und du hast ein Elektron, das sich im Atomkern darum auffällt. Und das ist aber nur mit dem Atomkern verbandelt und mit nichts sonst im Universum. Wenn wir dieses Ding von außen betrachten, dann hätten wir den Eindruck, das was ist die Position von diesem Elektron? Das ist nicht einfach ein Punkt natürlich. Weil diese Verbindung ist einfach nur ein Link in dem Grafen. Wenn ihr das Ding in Raum projizieren, ist das so eine Art Kugel. Und wenn das mehr als ein Link ist, dann ist es so ein Spheroid. Und das ist aber nicht in allen diesen Punkten gleichzeitig, sondern es ist da als Möglichkeit. Erst wenn das Elektron mit irgendwas interagiert und nicht mehr nur mit dem Atomkern verbundelt ist, sondern auch mit was anderem außerhalb von dem Atomkern, wird seine Position weiter constrained und ist dann eventuell triangulierbar in unserem dreidimensionalen Raum. Aber dieser dreidimensionale Raum existiert nicht wirklich, sondern existiert nur als ein Frame, den wir benutzen, um das Universum zu sehen. Weil in dem großen Raum, wo wir existieren, können wir alles immer irgendwie für dreidimensional triangulieren. Das gilt halt nur nicht für so Sachen wie das Elektron. Das heißt, das Elektron ist außerhalb von dem Raum. Und wenn du das als Mathematiker betrachtest, dann kannst du einfach sagen, okay, machen wir einfach eine Projektion. Dieses Elektron ist jetzt eine Surface. Und diese Surface hat halt unendlich viele Punkte. Den Mathematiker kümmert das nicht, aber für den Informatiker ist das schlimm, weil natürlich unendlich viele Punkte zu berechnen, ein paar interagierende Elektronen wird mit einem Mal sehr teuer. Und deswegen ist es sehr teuer, Quantenprozesse zu simulieren. Das ist ganz klassisch, wir müssen eine Molekalo-Sample machen von diesen ganzen Aufenthaltsmöglichkeiten des Elektrons und von dem anderen Elektron, mit dem es interagieren soll. Und hoffen, dass wir dann mit Wahrscheinlichkeit berechnen können, was das Elektron tut.
Aber das heißt, wenn man das jetzt mal umdreht, würde es ja heißen, dass der Versuch, einen Quantencomputer zu bauen, ist ja dann nur der Versuch, das Universum dazu zu zwingen, etwas für mich auszurechnen.
Ja, aber die Frage ist, was kann das Universum überhaupt große Zahlen effizient faktorisieren? Das wissen wir nicht. Ich meine, wir wissen auch nicht genau, ob das Problem, große Zahlen effizient zu faktorisieren, ein NP ist. Vielleicht weiß die NSA das besser als wir. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es nicht ein NP. Ist es nicht problemiell berechenbar. Und der Verdacht ist halt, dass Quantencomputer das können. Das heißt, unser Universum kann das, aber unsere klassischen Computer können das nicht. Es gibt also ein paar Probleme, die knapp so an der Grenze liegen, von dem, was wir nicht mehr effizient machen können, aber was ein Quantencomputer effizient machen könnte.
Wie siehst du denn dieses, was die jetzt gerade so D-Wave und Co. machen, also diese, ich sag mal, nonconventional Computing, was ja noch kein Quantencomputing ist, sondern halt mehr so ein...
Die benutzen halt andere Phänomene, die Nicht-Deutlichkeit. Und das läuft darauf hinaus, dass du einen stochastischen Parallelcomputer hast. Und ich vermute, dass es viele Applikationen geben könnte, auch zum Beispiel Learning und so, wo das super nützlich ist. Aber das ist nicht so, dass die was können, was klassische Computer im Prinzip nicht können. Das ist eine andere Art und Weise, Chips zu bauen, die für bestimmte Anwendungen besser ist. Aber es ist nicht so, dass es den Computer an eine andere komputationale Klasse katapultiert.
Wobei das ja auch eine alte Idee ist. Das gab es auch früher schon irgendwie so Thinking Machines und so. Also es gab mehrere Transputer, gab mehrere Ansätze so, einfach das Problem dann halt zu verteilen auf Elemente. Aber ich wollte noch auf eine andere Sache hinaus. Die Quantencomputer finde ich hochspannend. Die andere Sache ist, wir reden hier die ganze Zeit von Berechenbarkeit und Universum. Eine der Fragen, die gelegentlich am Stammtisch von Nerds diskutiert wird, ist ja die Frage, ob wir in einer Simulation leben oder nicht. Und das ist ja eigentlich dann plötzlich auch ein sehr direkt vergleichbares oder ähnliches Problem. Also, ich sag mal Simulation oder Hologramm?
Wir müssten als erstes mal überlegen, was wir genau mit der Simulation meinen. Ich glaube, es gibt so zwei wichtige Simulationsbegriffe. Das eine ist, wenn wir eine Simulation machen von irgendwas, dann ist es so, dass wir das System durch ein Regelwerk abbilden, was isomorph ist. Das heißt, wir nehmen andere Elemente als das Ding, was wir simulieren. Wir vereinfachen das und bilden die sozusagen die Emergenz-Ebene ab.
Also das, was zählt, das, was wahrnehmbar ist.
Genau, also wir gucken irgendwie, zum Beispiel werden wir den Finanzmarkt simulieren. Der Finanzmarkt besteht real aus ganz vielen Leuten, die ganz viele Firmen und Assetklassen traden. Das machen wir nicht, sondern wir abstrahieren die auf bestimmte Nummern und lassen die miteinander interagieren. Wir können wesentliche Eigenschaften von dem Ding, das wir simulieren wollen, abbilden. Dann gibt es noch das Simulacrum. Ein Simulacrum ist so eine Art Handpuppe, die diese Eigenschaften, diese innere Integrität überhaupt nicht hat. Also zum Beispiel unser Selbstmodell ist so eine Art Simulacrum. Das hat Eigenschaften, die wir selber in Wirklichkeit gar nicht haben. Aber das benutzen wir, um uns selbst unsere Geschichte zu erzählen.
Da können wir aber noch mal drüber streben.
Naja, aber warte mal, die Idee, dass das Universum an irgendeinem Punkt irgendwas noch nicht fertig gerechnet hat, da ist meine erste Assoziation. Das ist einfach eine Simulation und es wäre zu teuer, alles immer berechnet zu haben.
Ja, das Ding ist sozusagen, was simuliert denn das? Irgendein fieses Alien simuliert in der Welt. Ist die Simulation die Abbildung von etwas anderem? Also ist es da so, dass die Nerds im Parent-Universum, die sich den Computer hingestellt haben, um die Simulation zu machen, simulieren, die sozusagen ein Universum irgendwie echter ist als unseres? Oder ist es anders? Meinen wir was anderes? Meinen wir mit Simulation, es ist halt ein komputationales Universum und zwar eins, was intentional erzeugt wurde?
Das wäre nur der eigentliche Unterschied zwischen einem komputationalen Universum, was halt entstanden ist und einem, was erzeugt wurde. Das wäre ja die Frage nach der Simulation. Na gut, eine Simulation impliziert natürlich auch immer, dass sie unter jemandes Kontrolle ist, also dass sie halt irgendwie entweder einen Zweck hat oder ein Ende hat.
Naja, wieso?
Naja, weil ich mein, sonst wär's ja keine Simulation, sonst wär's ja echt.
Nö, wieso? Das kann doch sein, dass irgendwie ein Experiment, um zu gucken, was passiert ist.
Das ist aber unter jemandes Kontrolle, also sie ist sozusagen...
Na, der kann ja gestorben sein, Simulation läuft weiter. Also, ja, gut.
Na gut, aber jemand hat's gebootet. Also jemand hat es gebootet.
Ja, jemand hat es gebootet. Aber ich denk mir so, warum sollte es ein Universum geben, was nicht alles ausgerechnet hat, außer es gibt irgendeinen, das kostet was, alles auszurechnen? Ja, wenn es ein physikalischer Prozess ist, stelle ich mir das nicht so froh, als dass es was kosten würde.
Ja, es kostet halt immer Energie. Ohne ist es halt nicht.
Ja, aber nur, wenn du es simulieren willst, oder?
Nö, na auch wenn es so ist.
Ansonsten gilt die Energiehaltungssatz.
Du kannst jetzt sagen, wenn man jetzt sagt, ok, du hast ein kompetitionales Universum, was halt irgendwie nach einem Set von Regeln folgt, die halt, nehmen wir mal an, so Leer-Automaten auf irgendwie die Subatomata-Teilchen-Ebene sind, dann hättest du ja quasi so eine Art stochastisches Uhrwerk. Na so etwas, was halt irgendwie so in seiner Komplexität vor sich hin funktioniert, keinen Sinn hat, kein Ziel hat, kein Zweck hat. Also einfach nur da ist.
So jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was heißt denn, ist echt oder ist nicht echt? Ja, wenn da jetzt irgendwie ein Layer dazwischen ist, ist es ja immer noch echt. Also könnte man argumentieren.
Für alle praktischen Zwecke ist es echt egal.
Also es ist total echt, das Ding ist simuliert, das Wasser macht alle Leute der Simulation nass. Insofern ist es echt.
Genau, aber ich finde die Frage, finde ich einfach deswegen interessant, ob das Universum sozusagen berechenbar ist oder ob es mehr kann als eine Touring-Maschine, finde ich deswegen interessant unter anderem, weil das eine der Fragestellungen ist, die zu klären ist auf dem Weg dahin, ob wir gesimuliert werden oder nicht.
Das Ding ist, dass alle Beobachtungen, die ich mache, sind endliche Bitvektoren. Und für jede Menge von endlichen Bitvektoren kann ich ein Programm finden, was sie erzeugt. Das bedeutet, dass ich also immer für jede Menge von endlichen Observationen, die ich mache, werde ich ein berechenbares Modell finden, das mir das Ding liefert. Frage, ob das elegant ist, das Modell, aber eins werde ich auf jeden Fall finden. Im schlimmsten Falle ist es so eine Art Recording.
Aber nur in einem diskreten Universum.
Ja, das Ding ist aber, es reicht aus.
Wir drehen uns hier gerade so ein bisschen.
Nein, das ist nur, um die Wichtigkeit noch mal zu unterstreichen.
Naja, aber es reicht aus, ein diskretes Universum zu machen. Das heißt, ich kann niemals eine Beobachtung machen mit endlich vielen Bits, die mich dazu zwingt, das diskrete Universum zu verlassen. Also anzunehmen, dass ich in einem nicht diskreten Universum bin.
Vorausgesetzt, du hast genügend Bits.
Ja, und jetzt ist die Frage, warum fängt man an, dieses diskrete Universum zu untersuchen oder warum ist man überzeugt davon, dass es kontinuierlich ist? Und ich vermute, dass es historisch halt so ist, dass wir in der Welt leben subjektiv, die sehr kontinuierlich aussieht. Auf unseren Größenordnung, so 30 Magnetüzen über der Planck-Länge, sieht das Universum halt kontinuierlich aus. Genauso wie man Wasser halt wellensieht und keine Wassermoleküle.
Na und? Unsere Mathematik sieht kontinuierlich aus und legt es nahe.
Wir haben uns eine Mathematik gemacht, die das tut.
Ja, aber das ist ja, das haben wir ja gemacht, bevor wir überhaupt auch nur Thesen für alle physischen Prozesse hatten, physikalischen Prozesse hatten.
Na die Mathematik ist im Grunde genommen zum großen Teil eine Formalisierung von dem, was unser Gehirn sowieso tut, wenn es die Welt modelliert. Wenn du so ein Kleinkind auf dem Boden sitzen siehst, das ein Blatt Papier faltet und ein Stift durchsticht, was das Kind da eigentlich macht, ist, das beweist halt Eigenschaften von eingebetteten Surfaces in dreidimensionalen ökolitischen Räumen. Das Kind hat einen Verdacht, wie das aussieht und macht halt dieses Experiment, um raus zu gucken, wenn ich das so krümme, kommt das dahin, an der Stelle raus, wo ich denke. Das Kind weiß das vorher nicht und deswegen probiert es das aus. Das Kind weiß das nicht, dass es das macht. Also die Mathematik ist die Operationalisierung davon, dass wir diese impliziten Modelle, die diese Machine Learning Maschine in meinem Kopf macht, über die reden können, uns über die austauschen können. Und diese Modelle zu finden, ist relativ schwierig, diese expliziten Sprachen über diese Berechnungen, die wir da machen. Die Mathematik ist eigentlich die Kunst, dein Gehirn mit interessanten Operatoren zu trainieren und die Notation dient nur dazu, dass du dich dabei ehrlich hältst und dass du mit anderen darüber reden kannst.
Also die Frage am Ende mit der Simulation ist ja aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen irrelevant, weil sie am Ende ja nur irgendwie eine kursierte Frage nach Gott ist. Und das finde ich irgendwie einigermaßen interessant.
Es gibt ja zwei verschiedene Arten von Gott. Das Ding ist, der eine Gott ist, der sozusagen Sinn für unser Leben gibt. Das ist dieses große Ding, was ist die Frage, auf die ich die Antwort bin? Und alle Menschen, die keine Soziopathen sind, scheinen das eingebaut zu haben. Wahrscheinlich ist es von uns reingezüchtet worden, von unseren soziopathischen Vorfahren, die halt große Massen brauchen, die nach ihrer Pfeife springen. Und das tun sie, indem sie darin eine Bedeutung sehen. Dass sie bei etwas ihrem Leben Bedeutung gibt über den reinen organismischen Erhalt hinaus. Und diese Bedeutungsbedürfnis ist so so ein Huck, um Leute in Superorganismen zu organisieren, die praktisch als Staaten funktionieren, und als Stämme und so fort.
Es ist nicht nur ein Bedürfnis, sondern es löst auch Belohnungssysteme aus.
Naja, funktionieren diese Bedürfnisse. Die sind alle so vertratet, dass sie den Rewards geben oder Schmerzsignale, wenn sie ausbleiben. Und damit den Verhalten steuern. Aber der Schöpfergott ist etwas völlig anderes. Der Schöpfergott ist halt einfach so ein fetter Nerd, der da oben sitzt und seinen Computer anlaufen lässt, um da drin eine Physik- oder Gesellschaftssimulation zu machen. Und der besitzt nicht die magische Fähigkeit, den Inhabitants dieser Simulation irgendwelche Bedeutung zu verleihen. Das ist ein totaler Taschenspielertrick, von den Missionaren zu behaupten. Erstens, Gott ist der Nerd, der diesen Computer aufgestellt hat. Und zweitens, er besitzt die Superkraft, da im Leben Bedeutung zu verleihen. Das hat nichts miteinander zu tun. Total ist nur ein Seqitur.
Na gut, nehmen wir mal das Nummerbringer wieder.
Vor allem ist es auch subjektiv, Bedeutung zu haben oder nicht. Zumal in den Augen von jemandem, den du nicht danach fragen kannst. Also, na gut.
Also die Frage nach der Simulation wäre ja sozusagen die Frage nach dem Besitzer des kosmischen Supercomputers, also nach dem göttlichen Nerd. Also letztendlich ist ja sozusagen nichts weiter als irgendwie die Silicon Valley-Version der Frage von gibt es da einen Gott und können wir irgendwie nachweisen, ob es ihn gibt oder nicht.
Ja, aber die Situation ist, die Konfidenz muss genauso groß sein wie die Stärke der Evidenz. Welche Evidenz könnten wir dann haben über Götter da draußen?
Ich halte das ja für futile, aber es gab ja so diverse Experimente, die halt versucht haben, irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was ich da hatte, irgendeiner von den Microsoft-Leuten hat das da auch finanziert, so dieses eine Experiment, um rauszukriegen, ob wir in einer Simulation leben oder nicht. Das war irgendwie aber auch, das schien mir schon damals so, ich kriege die Details nicht mehr zusammen. In jeden Fall, die Frage letztendlich ist ja, hat es eine Intention, dieses Universum?
Höchstwahrscheinlich ist es nicht für unser Benefit.
Betrieb oder?
Weil das Universum ist da viel zu groß.
Genau, wir nehmen uns da glaube ich viel zu wichtig in die Universum.
Wenn das Universum tatsächlich eine internationale Simulation ist, dann dient es wahrscheinlich nur dazu, irgendwelche Physik-Sachen zu machen. Und wir sind einfach so ein bisschen Hefe, die da zufällig drin entstanden ist.
Naja, es ist uns ja nicht darin hin, zu versuchen zu verstehen.
Ja klar, das ist ja eine Sache, das muss man glaube ich trennen. Die Frage, ob man das verstehen kann und die Frage, ob es einen Sinn ergibt oder ob es eine Intention hat.
Was soll denn Sinn sein?
Ja eben.
Es ist relativ einfach glaube ich inzwischen zu sehen, wie Sinn implementiert werden müsste in einem Computer. Also dieses Bedürfnis nach Sinn. Das sieht auch jetzt für mich nicht so problematisch aus und es gibt auch einen evolutionären Grund, warum wir sowas haben sollten.
Ja, das ist so eine NPC AI, die du da rein gibst, damit es nicht so künstlich aussieht.
Nein. Es ist einfach die Adaption für multilevel selection, dass wir so ein startbildender Organismus werden. Übrigens, witzigerweise, wenn man die Bibel richtig liest, habe ich den Verdacht, dass da nichts drinsteht von Schöpfung. Also das Alte Testament Genesis, das ist eher die Kindheitserinnerung von Gott. Das erste Buch, das ist nicht so ein übernatürliches Wesen, das ein physisches Universum erzeugt, sondern es ist als erstes, wird halt Licht und Dunkelheit entdeckt und dann die Nomativität und Gott sagt, dass es gut war. Und dann entdeckt Gott Erde und Himmel und dann entdeckt er Tiere und die Pflanzen und gibt ihnen allen ihren Namen. Ich glaube, das ist cognitive development. Und wenn du die Adam und Eva anguckst, die sind ganz klar nicht der erste Homo sapiens, sondern der Adam, der trifft ja irgendwann die Lilith und so weiter. Und dann später, als die aus dem Paradies rauskommen, Adam und Eva, da sind dann auch gleich Frauen da, an die sie ihre Söhne verheiraten können. Es gibt da deutliche Hinweise darauf, dass sie nicht die ersten Menschen waren, sondern Adam ist einfach der erste Mensch, der von diesem hebräischen Mindvirus infiziert wurde, sozusagen der Patient Zero, der Infektion mit der Abrahamitischen Religion. Und solche Infektionen passieren wahrscheinlich alle nasslang. Und dass dieser eine Mindvirus so speziell ist, liegt halt daran, dass sie eine ungebrochene Linie zu uns hat. Genauso wie die erste Zelle so speziell ist, weil sie eine ungebrochene Linie zu uns hat. Der zweite Person, die diesem Mindvirus zu Opfer fällt, ist anscheinend Eva. Adam verliert eine Rippe in den Prozess, er weiß, was genau vorgefallen ist. Und jetzt sind die beiden in ziemlich tollen Zustand im Paradies. So alles bliss, alles toll. Und dann kommt irgendwann dieser Vorfall mit der Schlange. Und er begegnet Eva. Und danach wird alles viel komplizierter. Und die Möglichkeit des Bösen wird geschaffen. Und Adam und Eva und vermutlich auch Gott werden aus dem Paradies vertrieben in die normale Welt. Das ist, glaube ich, was viele Paare durchmachen.
Ich hab das immer so als Thulup-Parallel gesehen. Ja, so die Idee, dass manche Sachen... Na wieso? Das ist doch eine zentrale Tenet bei Lovecraft. Dass das Universum einfach Dinge enthält, die nicht so dafür gedacht sind...
Gesehen zu werden oder geweckt zu werden.
Genau, dass Menschen sie wahrnehmen. Und das ist doch eine alte Angst in Menschen, dass du einfach sagst, okay, das wollen wir jetzt mal nicht gucken, weil wer weiß, was wir da an Wahrheiten lernen.
Ja, natürlich, es ist total gefährlich, wenn eine Frau irgendwelche anderen Schlangen anguckt.
Also ich glaube ja, dass diese Frage mit dem Sinn, also sozusagen, hat die Simulation einen Sinn?
Na die Frage nach gefährlichem Wissen spielt da auch eine Rolle, oder? Das könnte der Grund sein, warum du die Simulation machst.
Na ja gut, also entweder du hast eine Simulation, weil sie dir entstanden ist. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel daran denke, an diese Bottle Gardens. Kennt ihr die? So Leute, die nehmen sich so eine Weinflasche und tun dann da so ein Mikroökosystem rein. Also die tun da halt so ein paar Pflanzen und so ein paar Algen und so ein bisschen Zeugs rein und so und dann versuchen sie, die vollständig als geschlossenes Ökosystem zu betreiben. Da gibt es einige Leute, die sind da richtig gut drin. Also die kriegen es hin, dass sie so einen halben Kubikmeter großes Mikroökosystem betreiben, was also außer Licht von außen keinen Import hat. Was ja also eigentlich eine Ökosystemsimulation ist, auf der Basis eigentlich von echten Zellen, also auf der Basis von echten Organismen, die von außen eingetragen sind, aber dann in sich isoliert sind. So manche starben, manche funktionieren und so weiter. Und wenn wir jetzt halt so eine Art Simulation betrachten, also sozusagen ein Computational Experiment, also der Versuch, etwas herauszubekommen, dann wäre das schon eine ziemlich, also der Aufwand wäre schon relativ groß. Also wenn man jetzt so das Universum als Computational Experiment betrachtet, ist wahrscheinlich so angesichts der gesamten Energiebilanz so relativ unwahrscheinlich. Denn es gibt noch mal einen signifikanten anderen Leer.
Wollen wir kurz darüber reden, was Energie ist? Na es gibt halt sozusagen zwei Arten von Energie. Das eine ist das Moment, also die Fortbewegung von Partikel. Und das andere ist, wenn du das Partikel anhälst, was dann noch da ist an Energie, das ist die Ruhemasse. Und man kann sich die Ruhemasse vorstellen, das ist sozusagen die Fluktuation an einem Ort, die Menge von Bits, die an der einen Stelle ist. Und das andere ist, wie viel diese Bits katapultiert werden können im nächsten Schritt. Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen die Menge der Bits, die bewegt werden und die Bewegung der Bits. Und für beide gibt es Konservierungsgesetze. Das heißt, die Menge der Partikel oder die Menge der Masse im Universum sozusagen ist konstant. Und das Momentum ist konstant. Und wenn man das jetzt auf ein komputationales System überträgt, dann sehen wir halt, dass Energie nicht irgendwie eine magische Fähigkeit ist oder irgendeine Kraft oder so was, sondern es ist halt was zu tun mit den Berechnungen, die im Universum stattfinden. Und diese Berechnungen haben ein Problem in unserem Universum, weil unser Universum ist reversibel empirisch. Wir haben Schwierigkeiten, Bits zu löschen. Wenn wir irgendwas sauber machen, wird was anderes dreckig. Das ist z.B. in Minecraft nicht so. In Minecraft kannst du Bits löschen. Das Minecraft kann vergessen, welchen Zustand es vorher hatte. Wenn du da so einen Klotz weggebaggert hast, dann weißt du nicht, wo der war. Also niemand weiß das, außer du als Beobachter draußen. Aber Minecraft hat das vergessen. Und aus diesem Grund, dass Minecraft Sachen vergessen kann, kannst du in Minecraft per PtU Mobile bauen. Und in unserem Universum halt nicht. Wenn du in unserem Universum eine Dynamik errichten willst, die von der Dynamik des unterliegenden Universums abweicht, dann musst du da Bits löschen. Wenn du z.B. die Schwankungen in deiner gestrigen Körpertemperatur vergessen willst, was du möchtest wahrscheinlich als Organismus, sondern willst die stabilisieren, dann musst du diese Bits irgendwie aus deinem System kriegen. Und das heißt, du nimmst diese überflüssige Information und codierst die in die Momentumvektoren von Partikeln rein in deinem Körper und tust diese Partikel dann raus aus dem Körper. Und diese zusätzliche Information, die rein codiert ist, das ist halt Wärme von den Partikeln. Das sind die durchschnittlichen Geschwindigkeitsunterschiede von den benachbarten Partikeln. Und eine Energiequelle ist halt etwas, was diese Information wieder aus den Partikeln rauskühlt und dann die Partikel wieder zurückführt, solange bis die Energiequelle voll ist und auf eine Mülldeponie geschmissen werden muss. Und in unserem Fall ist die Hauptenergiequelle halt die Sonne. Die gibt uns Partikel, die Fortunen, die sind relativ gut organisiert und zum Schluss streilen wir das Zeug als Hitze wieder in den Weltraum ab und in diesem Gradienten leben wir. Das ist das Ding, was uns antreibt. Und wenn die Sonne ausgebrannt ist, unsere kleine Pfütze von der Entropie leergeschöpft ist, dann hört das Leben halt auf und die Entropie kriegt uns. Ich bin nicht mehr vergessen, was die Körpertemperatur von gestern war.
Wobei die Frage dann natürlich ist, wenn die, also die Computation ist ja eine Funktion der Struktur des Universums an sich in deiner Theorie. Also ist ja sozusagen keine exogene Funktion, sondern eine Eigenschaft.
Das kann es ja nicht unterscheiden, oder?
Kommt darauf an, wie man es definiert. Also man könnte auch sagen, das Universum ist halt die Menge der States. Und natürlich wird das Universum erst seine Form halten durch die Transitionsfunktion.
Was aber ja genau dasselbe wäre am Ende.
Ja, das ist doch eine Abstraktion eigentlich.
Das ist die Frage, wie du es halt formalisierst.
Ja, okay. Aber heißt ja, dass sozusagen die, es ja eigentlich nur die Regeln sind, nach denen Zustandsübergänge stattfinden. Also quasi nur ein zugrundeliegendes System von Regeln, die auf einer sehr, sehr, sehr niedrigen Ebene Zustandsübergänge definieren. Trotzdem brauchen diese Zustandsübergänge ja an sich Energie.
Wenn dein System, in dem das Ding läuft, kein reversibler Computer ist, dann nicht. Und weil das ein reversibler Computer ist, dann brauchst du deine Energie, wenn du andere Operationen als Permutationen ausfindest. Wenn du nur Permutationen machst, das hat Fredri gezeigt, dann hast du kein Problem. Und unser Universum hat die Eigenschaft, dass du Informationen nicht loswirst. Wenn du keine Bits löschen kannst, dann heißt das, dass das Universum bloß permutiert. Das heißt, es braucht keine Energie zum Laufen.
Okay, das heißt also, die Menge der verwendbaren Energie wäre ausschließlich bestimmt durch die Menge an Teilchen des Universums?
Nö. Die Teilchen müssen nicht speichert werden.
Also zu einem Zeitpunkt, man hier sozusagen für einen Snapshot.
Das Ding ist aber, dass dieser Snapshot nur existiert von Ihnen im Universum gesehen. Das kann ja passieren, dass die Funktion, die das Universum von außen berechnet, sozusagen nur sehr wenige Steinchen bewegt. Und das Ding ist so eine Art emergentes Fraktal, das nur aus der Innenansicht sichtbar wird.
Hm, das wäre ganz schön funky. Okay, aber dann hätten wir keine Chance, es festzustellen, was es ist.
Na, möglicherweise doch. Wir können einfach mal gucken, welche Fraktale es so gibt.
Na, und wir könnten sehen, wie tief wir reinzoomen können.
Na ja, es ist beim Fraktal definitionsgemäß endlos.
Ja, eben. Aber unser Universum sieht ja aus, als wenn es diskret ist an der Stelle.
Vielleicht, ja.
Ja, es gibt halt so was wie...
Also, das reinzoomen kostet immer mehr Energie. Also in unserem Universum Energie.
Also, es sieht so aus, dass...
Vielleicht ist das ansichtlich so eingebaut, damit wir dem nicht auf den Klo gehen.
Genau.
Ein endliches Raumvolumen scheint endlich viel Informationen zu enthalten bei uns. Also, es gibt sozusagen, wenn man das so betrachtet, gibt es also auch nur endlich viele Zustände, die pro Raumvolumen möglich sind. Und in diesem Sinne hätten wir ein Universum, was sozusagen diskritisierbar ist.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass es sozusagen ein deterministisches Universum wäre.
Es könnte sein, dass es stochastisch ist, aber es sieht halt so aus, als wäre es nicht stochastisch. Es sieht verdammt regelhaft aus. Die stochastische Anbetung lässt sich einfacher erklären.
Naja, okay, mach mal.
Also das Ding ist, wenn unser Universum komplett zufällig wäre, so eine Art Bolzmann-Maschine, dann könnten wir keine Vorhersagen über die Zukunft treffen.
Nee klar, komplett zufällig.
Das machen wir auch. Das Universum lässt sich relativ gut komprimieren. Wenn du dir zum Beispiel so eine Mandelbrotfigur anguckst, du zoomst da ein bisschen rein, du kannst bei der Mandelbrotfigur sehen, wie die weitergeht sozusagen als nächstes für ein Paar. Wenn du so ein bisschen zur Seite scrollst, das kannst du dir vorstellen, wie es jetzt als nächstes weitergeht in der Regel. Du kannst aber nicht das Ganze machen, ohne dass du die gesamte Mandelbrotfigur ausrechnest und die Regel kennst, nach der sie berechnet wird. Das ist ja super einfach, das ist praktisch nur eine Zeile Code, die du brauchst, um dieses Fraktal zu erzeugen. Und wenn unser Universum so eine Art Fraktal wäre, dann könntest du praktisch eine relativ einfache Funktion haben, die die Gesamtheit dieser Muster erzeugt. Aber wenn du dich in einem Fraktal befindest und nicht weißt, an welcher Stelle du bist und was die Erzeugungsfunktion ist, dann kannst du nicht vorher sagen, was als nächstes passiert. Aber das Fraktal ist nicht so chaotisch, dass du gar nichts vorhersagen kannst, sondern du siehst halt bestimmte Regelmäßigkeiten.
Aber wir haben ja auch das Problem verschärft durch die Nichtlokalität, dass wir gar nicht die, also wir können überhaupt nicht einen diskreten Raumteil benennen, den wir weiter simulieren wollten, um die Zukunft vorher zu sagen.
Das ist sicherlich ein Problem.
Aber das spricht so ein bisschen gegen das Fraktal, oder nicht?
Naja, das wäre halt mehrdimensionales Fraktal. Das hätte halt dummerweise wahrscheinlich denn sowas wie acht Dimensionen oder so.
Wahrscheinlich acht oder sowas. Es lässt sich halt auf jeden Fall nicht als, es ist nicht das Mal eine Brutfraktal. Das sieht vermutlich ganz anders aus in seiner mathematischen Struktur. Das ist aber nur ein Problem für unsere Vorhersagen. Das ist nicht ein Problem für unsere Erkenntnisse. Also wenn wir feststellen, wir muss dann so mal die einfachen zellulären Automaten durch, bis wir zu einem kommen, der die Eigenschaft hat, ein Universum mit Urknallen drin und Planeten drin zu produzieren. Und wir stellen fest, es gibt keinen Einführern als das. Und vielleicht ist er sogar so einfach, dass es einfach die Überlagerung aller diskreten Automaten ist. Weil Existenz das die Wort ist und nicht nicht Existenz.
Naja, das heißt dann aber, dass die Frage des Determinismus des Universums eher dahin geht, dass man sagt, okay, es ist nicht deterministisch im Sinne des laplastischen Demons, weil die Anzahl der Möglichkeiten davon abhängt, wie weit ich rein summe.
Naja, im Prinzip ist die Idee, wir leben in dem laplastischen Dämon. Der laplastische Dämon denkt halt über ein Universum nach und hier sind wir.
Erklär mal.
Na, es ist die ursprüngliche Idee von dem laplastischen Dämon, es gibt das physische Universum, das besteht aus Zeug. Und dann ist der laplastische Dämon, der denkt darüber nach.
Genau.
Es ist aber gar nicht erforderlich, dass es Zeug gibt. Es reicht aus, dass der laplastische Dämon darüber nachdenkt.
Weil wenn er da zu einer Lage ist, dann kann er das Universum simulieren.
Ja, und dann würden wir da drin existieren.
Na gut, aber ich meine, eine Implikation des laplaschen Dämons war ja unter anderem, dass es halt quasi eigentlich sowas wie freien Willen nicht gibt.
Da wollte ich auch gerade hingehen. Wir kommen die ganze Zeit von Berechenbarkeit und Determinismus. Und die Kernfrage haben wir noch gar nicht, haben wir einfach impliziert.
Na ja, das ist eine gute Einleitung in die Richtung gewesen.
Genau, da wollte ich eigentlich bitte öffnen heute, aber okay.
Egal. Freier Wille.
Genau, haben wir freien Willen.
Ja, aber es ist was anderes, als die Leute denken. Freier Wille ist die Fähigkeit, das zu tun, was man als richtig erkannt hat. Freier Wille, das Gegenteil davon, ist nicht Determinismus oder Zwang, sondern Kompulsion. Ich hatte einen danach ein Beispiel gefragt, das war auf Twitter, ich hab gesagt, der Umstand, dass ich jetzt gerade auf Twitter bin, ist nicht freier Wille. Ich weiß, dass ich das nicht tun soll. Ja, es ist genau dieses Ding, dass du in der Lage bist, zu wissen, was du tust, und dich danach zu verhalten. Und je besser du weißt, warum du das tust, was du da tust, desto weniger Freiheitsgrade hast. Du bist total paradox, im Grunde genommen.
Je weniger du bei Nacht denkst, desto mehr Freiheit hast du.
Ja, also diese Freiheit ist aber einfach Wuschigkeit. Wenn du ein kleines Kind bist, darfst du sehr wuschig sein und darfst so viel Schokolade essen, wie du kriegst und erbeuten kannst. Und je erwachsener du wirst, desto weniger Schokolade kriegst du, obwohl du sie alle haben darfst.
Du könntest sie alle haben.
Ja, du könntest sie alle haben. Du bist aber einfach zu vernünftig, um das zu tun.
Das ist aber eine Definitionsfrage oder nicht? Du könntest auch sagen, ich muss hier mal meine Schokolade.
Ja, wir sind alle nicht sehr erwachsen hier mit der Schokolade. Aber das wussten wir schon.
Das schränkt ja nicht deine Freiheit ein, wenn du dich dagegen entscheidest, etwas zu tun. Solange es eine Option war, es doch zu tun, finde ich, ist die Freiheit nicht eingeschränkt. Aber das hängt wahrscheinlich von der Definition.
Die Frage ist, wie viel Agency du hast.
Genau, das ist eigentlich die Kernfrage. Kann man Leuten das übel nehmen, wenn sie was getan haben? Oder war das eigentlich berechenbar aus dem Zustand von heute Morgen?
Natürlich kannst du ihnen das übel nehmen. Die Frage ist, ob du es solltest, wenn du vernünftig bist.
Du Sophist.
Das ist eine total wichtige Frage. Ich merke, je Erwachsener ich werde, desto weniger schaffe ich es, mich über Twitter aufzuregen. Und das passiert aus dem gleichen Grunde.
Das ist eine große Abstumpfung.
Nee, ich sehe einfach, was passiert.
Bringt nix.
Es ist einfach so eine Form von Erwachsenwerden. Ich bin sicherlich nur selektiv erwachsen geworden. Aber stell dir vor, du leitest in den Kindergarten. Und die Kinder kommen zu dir und sagen Sachen, die total outrageous sind. So ganz schlimme Dinge. Willst du dich als Kindergärtner darüber aufregen? Oder ist es einfach so, dass du beobachtest, was Kinder halt so sagen? Irgendwann hast du die Muster alle erkannt und du verstehst, wie die Kinder gerade die Welt modelieren und warum. Und warum die sich über diese Sachen aufregen und über jene und warum die diese Koalition bilden und jene. Nur, sie finden, dass die Emma dahinten super ungerecht gewesen ist, heute und ihr Spielzeug heute teilen sollen. Und warum der Kindergartenlehrer total ungerecht ist, weil er da halt nicht eingegriffen hat und so. Aber es betrifft dich als Kindergartenlehrer nicht, ne? Und das liegt einfach daran, dass du verstehst, warum die Kinder tun, was sie tun. Das heißt nicht, dass du das Gefühl hast, die tun das Falsche. Du hast das Gefühl, dass sie das Falsche tun nur deswegen, weil du auf ihrer gleichen Stufe bist und die Muster nicht verstehst.
Ne, also es betrifft dich ja trotzdem. Du bist ja betroffen, wenn die zu dir kommen und dich voll nüllen.
Aber auf eine andere Rolle.
Ja, aber das ist aber ein Unterschied. Also und das ist auch, ich meine, es ist immer einfach zu sagen, okay, ich habe verstanden, warum der das jetzt macht, aber ich kann mich da trotzdem darüber aufregen. Also das den Schrift...
Das ist ein bisschen, als ob du dich über deinen eigenen Code aufregst oder über den Code anderer Leute.
Machst du das nicht?
Naja.
Ach, den ganzen Tag?
Aber du weißt, dass dich anschreien nicht besser wird.
Das macht...
Na doch, an dir Code nicht, aber auf ich fährt besser, wenn ich mich das rauslassen kann.
Ich werde davon nur depressiv, wenn ich mich anschreie.
Also, meine, es gibt ja diesen schönen Spruch von Chris Lomoti, dass wahre Weisheit ist, zu beobachten und zu erkennen, ohne einen Urteil zu fällen. Was ungefähr die Position des Kindergärtners ist an dieser Stelle.
Nee, da fällt schon ein Urteil, oder?
Ich erinnere mich, du bist ein Psychiater und ein Psychologe und du hast deine ganzen Patienten. Es ist natürlich so, dass du Urteile fällst, aber diese Urteile sind keine moralischen Werturteile.
Genau, keine Verurteilung.
Also du hast keine moralische Regung dabei. Das ist entscheidender dabei, sondern du hast eine Regung, die was zu tun hat. Du siehst ein technisches Problem und mit diesem technischen Problem muss gearbeitet werden. Das ist ein Teil der Physik in einer gewissen Weise.
Warte mal, das hast du auf Twitter geschafft, dass du da keine moralischen Verurteilungen mehr machst? Da muss ich aber sagen, das muss man kurz anbieten. Kannst du reich und berühmt mit werden.
Der Robert Keegan, so ein Psychologe, der hat eine Theorie über die Selbstbewusstwertung gemacht. Das ist eine Art Vental Theory, also eine Entwicklungspsychologie. Aber ich glaube, dass es noch spannender ist als eine Philosophie zu sehen. Weil ich glaube, dass meine Kinder sich nicht genau in der Reihenfolge entwickelt haben. In dem Fall, diese Stufen funktionieren ungefähr so. Wenn du so ein kleines Baby bist, das die Welt wahrnimmt, dann nimmst du wahr, dass die Welt halt komplett Lust ist oder komplett Schmerz. Und das Baby denkt nicht an zukünftig Lust und Schmerz, sondern ist komplett in diesem einen Ding drin. Das ist dieses alles oder nichts. Und dann irgendwann kriegt das Kind mit, dass die sich abwechseln und das Erlager über die Zustellung zu integrieren und Erwartungen zu formen und kriegt auch mit, dass Lust und Schmerz Dinge sind, die an den Dingen dranhängen. Und noch später kriegt es mit, dass es nicht an den Dingen dran hängt, sondern ein Teil der eigenen Reaktion auf die Dinge ist. Und irgendwann kriegt man halt mit so als Mensch, dass man selber Ziele hat und mit denen man Lust und Schmerz verbinden kann. Und dass man selber nicht dieses Ziel ist, sondern die hat. Dieser Übergang ergibt sich dann, wenn die Kinder aufhören, diese furchtbaren Schreikrämpfe zu haben, wenn sie ihre Ziele nicht erreichen. Ich glaube, die haben diese Schreikrämpfe mit zwei und drei Jahren nicht deswegen, weil sie ihre Eltern nerven wollen und die Grenzen austesten wollen, sondern die glauben halt, die sind ihr Ziel. Die identifizieren sich mit diesem aktuellen Verhaltensprogramm. Ich ist immer der Index auf das aktuelle Verhaltensprogramm. Und die haben einfach noch nicht gelernt, dass wenn sie dieses Ziel erreichen, dass sie dann nicht sterben. Es ist wirklich dieses Gefühl, dieses Verhaltensprogramm denkt, wenn ich das nicht schaffe, das jetzt zu kriegen, was ich mir unbedingt vorgenommen habe, egal ob das physisch möglich ist oder nicht, dann passiert was Schlimmes. Ich sterbe sozusagen, ich höre auf zu existieren. Ich werde mein Ziel nicht erreichen. Und das führt dann zum kompletten Schreikrampf, bis das Kind zusammenbricht. Und irgendwann lernt das Kind, ich bin immer noch da, und lernt es über diese Dinge zu integrieren. Und dann kommt es halt dahin, dass es selber Zielsetzen ist. Also ich bin nicht mehr mein Ziel, sondern das Ziel ist etwas, was ich habe. Und wenn die dann bemerken, dass andere Leute auch Ziele haben, dass sie die verändern können, dann kommt das Kind in das, was der Kegern die imperiale Fasel nennt. Ich muss dann allen sagen, was sie tun sollen. Und dann kriegt das Kind mit, okay, was ist jetzt da? Jetzt ist Wissen da. Das Wissen sagt mir, wie die Welt funktioniert. Und wie kriege ich das Wissen raus? Von meiner Umwelt. Ich muss also rauskriegen, was wichtige Leute über die Welt denken. Wenn ich das geschafft habe, nachzuvollziehen, was die denken, dann bin ich fertig mit der Kognition. Und das ist bei Kegern das Level 3 des Bewusstseins. Und da sind die meisten Leute irgendwie drin. Das heißt, die meisten Leute versuchen, ihr Weltbild zu formen, indem sie rauskriegen, was die Experten denken über die Welt. Also am Anfang halt die Lehrer und die total coolen Kinder in der Klasse. Und später halt die wichtigen Experten auf der Welt. Und besser wird es nicht als das. Und irgendwann ist es aber so, dass Leute mitkriegen, ein Teil der Leute, diese Grundregel der Epistemologie. Die Konfidenz muss genauso groß sein wie die Evidenz. Es gibt gar kein geheimes gnostisches Vektor zum Universum, dass nur Leute mit besonders langen Bärten öffnen können und du halt nicht, weil du jetzt noch zu dumm und unweise bist. Sondern die müssten auch Evidenz gehabt haben. Das heißt, der Typ, der da von den Berg zurückkam und mit dem brennenden Busch geredet hat und daraus geheimes Wissen über den Ursprung des Universums bekommen hat, der will dich wahrscheinlich nur zu irgendwas kriegen. Oder er spinnt. Eins von beiden.
Oder beides.
Ja, nicht den Moment. Die dritte These ist, dass er nur die Sachen mitgebracht hat, die du eh schon wusstest. Das ist ja...
Na ja, also die, sag mal so, sowohl die Evidenz als auch die Konfidenz, dass irgendwie da mehr als irgendwie ein bisschen zu viel magische Pülsen im Spiel waren, als der Busch brannte und mit ihm redete, sind halt gering.
Na abstrahier doch mal von dem Busch.
Keiner von mir hat ihn gesehen. Der steht da noch auf diesem Berg und daneben ist ein Feuerlöscher. Vielleicht haben wir jetzt nicht noch mal passen.
Ich war da...
Ein Feuerlöscher?
Ich war da... Nein! Ich war da. Ich hab's mir anguckt. Du kannst da hinfahren. Es gibt diesen Busch. Und es ist schon der zweite Busch. Weil der erste Busch...
Der erste ist abgebrannt.
Den ersten Busch hat irgendein Irrer versucht anzuzünden. Dann haben sie aber noch einen Ableger in der Asche gefunden und haben den wieder hochgezüchtet. Jetzt steht um diesen brennenden Busch steht da so fünf Feuerlöscher drumherum, so die ganz großen. Und es steht ein Wächter daneben, der aufpasst, dass nicht wieder ein Irrer versucht hat, den Busch anzuzünden, um mit Gott zu reden.
Es wäre total gefährlich. Du kriegst Updates rein, kannst keine kontrollieren, dass die wieder gepatcht wird in unser Universum.
Ja, also du, das ist ja...
Also, als er letztes Mal brannte, gab es kein Update, sondern, okay, der war wohl offensichtlich... Also, ich weiß nicht, wo der abgeblieben ist, aber wahrscheinlich steckt der in irgendeiner Irrenanstalt. Und niemand weiß, was das Universum ein Update bekommen hat.
Jedenfalls dieser Punkt, wo du rauskriegst, wo die Beliefs eigentlich herkommen und wie du sie selber bauen kannst, das ist die Stelle, wo du Self-Authoring wirst, wo du also selber zum Autor deiner Werturteile wirst, über wie die Dinge sind. Und du kannst dann halt dein eigenes Weltbild bootstrappen. Und die Stufe 5, das ist, wenn du mitbekommst, dass du nicht identisch mit deinen Werten bist, sondern dass die Werte eine Art kultureller Programmierung sind und dass du die Werte hast. Du bist die Werte nicht, sondern du hast sie. Und es gibt verschiedene Wertesysteme und das Verhalten von anderen Menschen vom vergleichbaren Fähigkeitsgrad ist halt nicht deswegen anders, weil die böse oder verwirrt sind, sondern es liegt daran, dass die andere Werte haben. Und aus diesen anderen Werten fließt logisch ein anderes Verhalten. Und du kriegst mit, du kannst diese Werte ändern. Und es gibt halt Wertesysteme, die mehr oder weniger sustainable sind, aber das war's.
Na oder andere Fakten, anderes Wissen.
Naja, aber zum Schluss gibt's nicht so viele Fakten, die aufgehen.
Na, es gibt aber mehr Fakten, als es Wertesysteme gibt oder nicht.
Nee, na, der Punkt ist, dass nicht alle Fakten sind für Wertesysteme relevant. Also ob man an Universum und kontinuierlich oder diskret ist oder computational oder der dem Standardmodell oder der Stringtheorie entspricht, ist für den allergrößten Teil meiner Werturteile verständlich irrelevant.
Ja, aber die meisten Leute haben eigentlich vergleichsweise ähnliche Werte, aber sie haben unterschiedlichen Kenntnisstand. Also so Werte im Sinne von moralischen Beurteilung ist ja gut oder böse. Es gibt so die warte Sachen, auf die du dich einfach geeinigt hast.
Es gibt innerhalb einer Gesellschaft ist es so, dass die Leute stark incentiviert sind, nicht laut zu sagen, wenn sie andere Werte haben, weil dann gibt es Ärger. Früher war es so, dass man Leute einen Baum genagelt hat, wenn sie öffentlich angekündigt haben, ich habe eine andere kulturelle Programmierung laufen als du. Und heute lag man sie nicht mehr einen Baum, aber es kann dazu führen, dass sie ihren Job als CEO von Mozilla verlieren. Das ist also blöd. Die Leute, die nicht völlig bescheuert sind, wissen, welche Werte sie in welchen Kontexten vertreten müssen.
Pothetisch gesprochen.
Wenn man sich aber zwischen verschiedenen Milieus hin und her bewegt, stellt man fest, dass Leute total diverse Werte haben.
Also richtig so auf grober Struktur verschiedene Werte oder in kleinen Details nach 15 Stufen?
Nö, die unterscheiden sich ziemlich massiv.
Also sie können interessanterweise zu denselben Conclusio kommen. Also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Ansätze, wie man zu du sollst nicht töten kommt. Also da gibt es ja mindestens fünf verschiedene Herleitungen. Wohin weiß ich mir am Ende, egal, mit welcher Herleitung jemand zu dem Ding gekommen ist, solange ich mir ungefähr das Vertrauen habe, dass er halt irgendwie diesen Regeln so grob folgt.
Hm, nicht ganz egal.
Nein, nicht ganz, aber es ist zumindest so für das irgendwie allgemeine zivilisatorische Zusammenleben. Es reicht eigentlich aus, egal, ob es jetzt aus einer religiösen, irgendwie Moralperspektive, einer biologistischen Perspektive oder einem reinen Utolitarismus dahingekommen sind, ist mir am Ende egal. Also solange ich halt irgendwie mir einigermaßen sicher bin, dass der, den ich da auf der Straße treffe, kein großes Interesse daran hat, mich umzubringen, kann ich damit leben, egal wie er dahingekommen ist. Deswegen will ich auch kein Urteil darüber fällen, wie er halt irgendwie zu diesem Ziel gekommen ist. Ich verliessens dann ein Urteil, wenn er halt irgendwie von diesem Basisparadigma abweicht, was zivilisatorisches Zusammenleben ermöglicht. Aber die interessante Frage dabei ist ja eigentlich, wenn das Universum computational ist, wie funktioniert dann das menschliche Gehirn? Ja, also weil wir haben ja dann, also der der freie Wille an sich, also gab es diese Diskussionen um den freien Willen, dann gab es diese blöden Schlagzeilen von wegen, es gibt keinen freien Willen, weil sie festgestellt haben, dass ein Teil des Gehirns halt irgendwie eine Geschichte daraus macht, was irgendwie ein anderer Teil des Gehirns halt irgendwie schon vor einer ganzen Weile beschlossen hat, was jetzt mal Phase ist. Und sie dann irgendwie auf diese irrige Annahme kommen, dass dieser Verbalisierer, der die Geschichte erzählt, nun das Bewusstsein sei oder der Freie, der der Sitz des ehemaligen freien Willens sei. Und deswegen meinten, es gäbe gar keinen freien Willen. Oder was konnte mich da entlastbar aufregen über diesen Quatsch? Aber die, also, naja, das war so ein typischer Fall von, ich musste leider aus dem Vortrag nach Humboldt-Uni rausgehen, weil sonst wäre ich ein bisschen ausfällig geworden. Aber die Frage, was ist das Ich? Also wie definiere ich mein Selbst? Also welches, was ist denn der?
Na oder Bewusstsein schon. Das finde ich nämlich die, das ist nämlich, wir haben uns vorhin schon in der Vorbereitung ein bisschen angewärmt bei der Frage, heißt Bewusstsein, dass ich mir meiner selbst bewusst bin? Oder ist es nur die Ausprägung, die wir kennen? Kann es auch ein Bewusstsein geben? Sag mal bei irgendeiner Schwarmintelligenz?
Das ist leicht dahingehen, aber ganz kurz noch zum freien Willen. Dieses Ding ist, dass Leute, die Werte haben, diese Werte sind eine Programmierung, mit der die Leute Teil von so einem Hive meint werden, von einer gesellschaftlichen Gruppe. Und Hive meint, da kennt man zum Beispiel daran, wenn die Leute argumentieren, auf YouTube sieht man das manchmal, dann reden die gerne im Chor. Die chatten dann. Das heißt, dass das nicht das Individuum denkt, sondern das Individuum spürt, das ist sozusagen der richtige Gedanke meiner Gruppe. Und ich darf den auch nicht in Frage stellen. Erstaunlich, weil sind diese Gruppengeister oft dümmer als individuelle Geister. Weil sie können halt nicht weitere...
Finde ich auch nicht erstaunlich.
Das ist nicht erstaunlich, weil deren Synchronisationsfunktion kostet halt einfach irgendwie Zeit.
Ja, aber das Faszinierende ist, dass Menschen funktionieren da drin. Also die sagen Dinge, die dümmer sind als das, wo sie normalerweise selber draufkommen können. Und sie haben aber das Gefühl, dass es richtiger ist als das, wo sie selber draufkommen könnten.
Ja, weil es die... Das Belohnungssystem ihnen sagt, du bist Teil einer Gruppe und wenn du Teil einer Gruppe bist, bist du starker.
Ja, und du fühlst dich richtig.
Das gibt es auch bei Computern. Du bist auch sonst so ein Freund von verteilten Computersystemen. Da ist das genauso. Du hast irgendwie acht Chores, ja, und dann hast du einen gewissen Verlust einfach durch die Cache-Synchronisation. Und es kann durchaus sein, dass ein Chor ein Problem berechnet und dabei schlechter ist als vorher, weil er einen Teil seiner Ressourcen ausgeben muss, um den anderen zuzuhören. Und es kann sogar sein, dass jemand was vertritt, was er eigentlich selbst nicht geglaubt hätte, weil sich das auf Input von woanders bezieht, den er nicht unter Kontrolle hat. Also das ist alles, es gibt wunderbare Parallelen zur Programmierung. Wo kommt denn aber die, du sagst, die sind programmiert, die Wertesysteme, wer programmiert die denn?
Ich vermute, dass die wichtigste Entdeckung der letzten 10.000 Jahre war, dass es nichts Wertvolleres gibt, als andere Menschen zu manipulieren. Weil praktisch alles, so gut Zeug, was du kriegst in der Welt, kriegst du von anderen Leuten, inklusive Zivilisation. Und wenn du es schaffst, die Leute dazu zu kriegen, was du willst, dann hast du es geschafft. Und es gab so ein paar relativ schlaue Charismatiker, die die Technologien der Manipulation von Leuten in den letzten 10.000 Jahren vervollkommnet haben. Und als Ergebnis kriegten wir Religionen und Ideologien. Und das ist im Prinzip eine Art Programmierung. Diese Programmierung, dass wir eine programmierbare Spezies sind, das ist wahrscheinlich der wesentliche Fortschritt gewesen. Spannende in den abahamitischen Religionen passiert mit Abraham. Gott sagt zu Abraham, tötet doch mal deinen Sohn. Also opfere den. Und Abraham sagt, okay, mach ich. Und Gott sagt, okay, das ist wichtig. Das hängt jetzt nicht darum, dass du das jetzt machst. Das wäre in der jetzigen Situation gerade nicht hilfreich. Der wichtige Punkt ist, du musst bereit sein, das zu tun. Ich glaube, das ist der genaue Punkt, wo wir von der Stammesbildung in Spezies, wo der Stamm die Summe der Members ist, werden wir von der Staatenbildung in Spezies. Der Staat ist dieses Organisationsprinzip, das sagen kann, okay, dieses Individuum opfern wir jetzt mal im Staatsinteresse. Das ist was Neues. Mit einem Mal hast du so eine Art Superorganismus, wo das Individuum zu einer Zelle wird und der Organismus halt sagen kann, okay, diese Zellen opfer ich, weil es jetzt notwendig ist im Interesse des Organismus oder diese Zellen sind halt Krebs oder ein Leberfleck und sollen weg.
Da wollte ich aber eigentlich gar nicht drauf hinaus, denn ich sehe einen Unterschied zwischen programmieren und trainieren. Ja, ein neuronales Netz trainierst du, ein deterministisches Algorithmus programmierst du. Da ist Intention dahinter, hinter dem Programmieren. Und da ist ein Autor. Beim Trainieren ist ein Typ, der das anstößt und beobachtet.
Aber der kippt nicht die einzelnen Bits, um was zu bewirken. Nein, aber du trainierst halt, du trainierst damit ein Ziel.
Ja, aber das finde ich genau eine wichtige Unterscheidung an der Stelle, dass es eben nicht den Typen gibt, der sich hinstellt und bei dir irgendwie Assembler reinkippt.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht zufällig, das ist bewusst gedacht. Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel das Alte Testament anguckst, das ist nicht irgendwie magische Geschichten.
Es hat eine Intention, ja, aber es ist nicht bewusst im Sinne von, wenn das passiert, wird er das tun, sondern es ist immer noch ein Training, kann immer noch Fehler haben, ja, und es ist immer noch wahrscheinlichheitsbasiert. Soweit sind wir nämlich noch nicht, dass wir jemanden wirklich programmieren können.
Nee, aber also...
Na, die Kirche ist eine Institution, die über 2000 Jahre hinweg versucht hat, Leute zu programmieren.
Das ist die Intention, ja.
Das funktioniert auch so.
Ja, man darf das nicht als entweder oder betrachten, aber wir haben beides dabei. Du hast ja in so einer Religion als gesellschaftlicher Mechanismus der Koheranzerzeugung, also als nur neutral positiv formuliert, ein Mechanismus, der über soziale Werte, zum einen das Überleben der Gemeinschaft sich erstellen will und zum anderen sich erstellen will, dass sie sich organisiert in eine Richtung bewegen kann, bevor sie gehijackt wird von Leuten, die sie irgendwie für ihre persönlichen Zwecke missbrauchen, irgendwie ihre Machtstrukturen aufbauen und so weiter und so fort. Hast du ja, diese Stämme mit Religion hatten überlebensvorteilweise in der Lage waren, sich auch, wenn es erstmal eigentlich fürs Individuum unlogisch war, in eine Richtung zu bewegen und ein Ziel zu verfolgen. So und das besteht aus expliziten Regeln, also richtig expliziten Regeln, also gerade die abramitischen Religionen haben alle ein ausführliches Werk von sehr expliziten Regeln, das ist quasi die direkte Programmierung, also das ist tatsächlich das Bitskippen. Und dann ist dazu aber parallel, das zweite Werk, was nämlich tatsächlich das Training ist, das sind halt die sozialen Implikationen der religiösen Texte, das sind halt irgendwie die Wertesysteme, die sich herausbilden, die halt aus Tradition kommen, die aus gelebten Vorbildhandeln kommen und die halt dazu führen, dass du halt irgendwie in der Lage bist, dich einer Bewegung sozusagen anzuschließen. Und das Problem ist halt, dass diese, also das sind religiöse Systeme, haben halt einen relativ hohen Kostenfaktor, weil sie zum einen bestimmte Klassen von Individuen, Außener, die halt nämlich keinen Bock haben oder nicht in autoritären Systemen können, zum anderen hast du halt das Problem, dass sie halt inflexibel sind, also dass sie halt irgendwie immer davon abhängig sind, dass du halt irgendwie ein Update deines Regelwerks hinbekommst, schnell genug. Und das ist halt tatsächlich so ein bisschen wie bei Parallelcomputern, wenn wir nochmal zurück zu der Analogie wollen. Die effizientesten Systeme sind Loose Coupling-Systeme. Systeme, wo du halt tatsächlich individuelle Notes hast mit relativ großen Ressourcen, also die die lokalen Speicher, den lokalen IO haben, die aber loosely coupled sind mit den anderen, sodass sie halt eine Kohorenz hast, dass sie derselben Aufgabe folgen können, aber die nicht abhängig davon sind. Und ich glaube, weil tatsächlich bei menschlichen Gesellschaften ist es so ähnlich, dass du halt ein Wertesystem brauchst als loose coupling, was ungefähr dafür sorgt, dass du in dieselbe Richtung gehen kannst und nicht halt wie gerade momentan halt so eine komplette Defragmentierung und Zerlegung. Aber du willst halt kein close coupling haben, wie du halt irgendwie es in irgendwie realsozialistischen Systemen hattest, wo die Leute, wenn sie nicht in Lockstep waren, mit den ideologischen Anforderungen halt einfach ausgesendert wurden oder wie halt irgendwie in katholischen Gegenden irgendwie oder auch evangelikalen Gegenden, wenn die Religionen da gerade in ihrer absoluten Blüte waren. Das führte halt in der Regel immer schnell dazu, dass sie dann halt nicht mehr in der Lage waren, halt irgendwie mitzuhalten, dass sie nicht mehr in der Lage waren, halt irgendwie sich auf die Anforderungen von außen einzustellen.
Naja, also ich finde es aber das eine der Gründe, warum ich diese Unterscheidung, Training und Programmieren wollte. Wenn ich dir zehn Gebote gebe, dann ist es nicht programmiert, sondern eine Vorgabe. Du hast immer noch den freien Willen zu sagen, fuck you, nee, das ist eine Vorgabe. Mit Programmierung kannst du nicht dich entscheiden, das anders zu machen. Wenn du programmiert bist, dann folgst du dem Punkt.
Ja, das ist aber eher Training.
Eben, deswegen meine ich, Region ist eher Training.
Die Trainingsfunktion im Alten Testament ist zum großen Teil Selektion. Das heißt, wenn jemand sich nicht an die Regeln hält, hat er keine Nachkommen. Wird dann gesteinigt und die Kinder und Kindeskinder oftmals auch.
Und Exkommunikation?
Ne, das Ding ist, dass damals gab es nicht viel Exkommunikation im Alten Testament, sondern das Ding ist einfach, wenn jemand vom Glauben abfällt, der ist praktisch wie eine Krebszelle. Die Seele ist die Beziehung des Individuums zu Gott, also die Beziehung, die das Individuum zu diesem Heif meint hat, zu dem Superorganismus.
Also es hieß noch nicht Exkommunikation, aber das Prinzip gab es schon. Du wurdest aus dem Tribe rausgeschmissen und hast als alleine in der Wüste keine Überlebenschancen. Es geht nicht nur um die Fortpflanzungen.
Ich denke, was in der Regel passiert ist, dass sie dich getötet haben, weil wenn du jemanden in die Wüste steckst, der einen supergroßen Hunger hat, der ist gefährlich.
Ja, aber das ist doch sozusagen Todesurteil.
Naja, wenn du es dir sicherstellen kannst, dass er nicht aus der Wüste zurückkommt, ja. Und Kanibale wird man zu? Oder Räuber oder was auch immer. Normalerweise, wenn du dafür sorgst, dass der nicht irgendwie morgen mit den Feinden zusammen aufmarschiert von der Tür.
Siehst du denn irgendeinen Vorteil an Religion? Ich versuche jetzt mal so ein bisschen anzudeuten auf, was weiß ich, Peterson zum Beispiel. Dass du sagst, okay, das ist, hat einen evolutionären Vorteil, Religion zu haben in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ich habe den Verdacht, dass die Religion die Voraussetzung war, dass wir den Ernatal ausrotten und aufessen konnten. Also wir haben die Fähigkeit, wie Frank sagt, im Gleichschritt zu laufen.
Ist das ein Vorteil?
Das ist ein programmierbarer Hominin, natürlich. Die anderen hatten nur Reputationssysteme, um sich gegenseitig zu ihrer Sorgen zu bringen. Wir können spieltheoretisch zeigen, dass so ein Reputationssystem nach so ungefähr 160 bis 200 Individuen zusammenbricht, weil du nicht mehr die Übersicht behältst, wer was gemacht hat. Das führt dazu, dass ein Stamm in seiner effektiven Größe begrenzt ist, in seiner Kooperation. In dem Augenblick, wo du Leute hast, die ohne nachzufragen alle dasselbe tun, und das skaliert beliebig auch für 100.000 oder sogar Millionen von Mitgliedern, weil die halt alle das gemeinsame Betriebssystem haben, wo Leute ohne, dass es logisch zwingend ist, zu den gleichen Schlüssen kommen, wie man sich verhalten soll. Das ist was sehr Mächtiges, selbst wenn die Schlüsse im Einzelfall nicht so gut sind. Und das heißt, die Religion beschränkt sozusagen die Individual Agency und blöderweise beschränkt sie auch die Epistemologie, insbesondere die katholische Religion. Also wenn du angekommen bist als Katholik und hast der Kirche gesagt, hallo, mir ist gerade aufgefallen, dass die Confidence in Belief genauso groß sein sollte, wie die Evidenz, dann haben die dich halt Herzlobstaben an den Baum genagelt, damit die anderen wussten, was Sache ist. Und das führte dazu, dass die Leute nicht klar denken konnten für ungefähr 1000 Jahre. Und erst als sie das gefixt hatten, haben sie, waren sie in der Lage, sich wieder auf das Niveau vom alten Rum zu bootstrappen und darüber hinaus.
Naja, und die Frage mit dem freien Willen ist ja nicht nur dich Religion beschränkt.
Ja, aber der Wille nimmt Agency weg. In dem Augenblick, wo das, was ich glaube, was wahr ist, nicht vorgegeben wird von dem, was logisch richtig ist und was ich selbst herleiten kann, sondern von äußeren Autorität, beschränkt das meine Glaubensfreiheit sozusagen, also meine Fähigkeit, Dinge als wahr zu erkennen. Und wenn meine Policies beschränkt werden durch Werte, die von außen vorgegeben werden und die ich durch einen Empathieprozess assimiliere, weil die guten Leute halt fühlen, dass das richtig ist und ich fühle das auch, dann beschränkt das meine Handlungsfreiheit und die Policies, die ich haben kann.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich auch sagen, dass es eine Abkürzung ist. Also weil du hast ja in dem Umblick tatsächlich die Modellierung deines Wertesystems outgesourct an Menschen, denen du entweder vertraust oder die in einer Autoritätsposition dir gegenüber sind.
Aber was macht dich, wenn du diese Entscheidung nicht bewusst treffen kannst, unfrei? Also insofern wird deine Entscheidung weniger frei. Das Ding ist, wenn ich jetzt Twitterdebatten lese, was mir auffällt, ist, okay, der hat die und die und die Programmierung, der hat die und die und die Programmierung. Und es ist im Prinzip so, wenn ich andere Menschen versuche zu verstehen, denke ich, okay, ich bin im Prinzip genau wie du, welche Bits müssen wir flippen? Damit ich du bin? Das können relativ viele Bits sein, aber...
Das hat Robert Anton Willson immer sehr schön als das Prinzip des Realitätstunnels beschrieben. Und hatte immer in seinen Büchern auch diese Übung, das Versuchswesen hineinversetzens in den Realitätstunnel von anderen Menschen. Also sich halt mal zu versuchen, hineinzudenken, wie die die Welt sehen, als eine Sätze Möglichkeit zur Entwicklung von Empathie. Und andererseits halt auch irgendwie bestes Verständnis zu finden. Das ist eigentlich ja genau das selbe Prinzip. Ist sowieso lohnt. Robert Anton Willson mal wieder zu lesen, das glaube ich gerade sehr zeitgemäß.
Falls diese starken Emotionen, die man kriegt, wenn man Twitter liest, das ist immer ein Hinweis darauf, dass es einen Konflikt gibt zwischen den Wertesystemen. Da dient jemandem anderen Gott als ich. Und ich habe das Gefühl, das ist ein Heretiker und ein Apostat. Und das ist genau das, was diese Emotionen auslöst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Gott dabei eine Rolle spielt. Ich glaube, es ist einfach nur dann...
Ich finde Gott einen schwierigen Begriff, weil man das so weit auslegen kann. Also eine der Auslegungen...
Lass uns doch mal die ordentlichen Episterminologie-Regeln anwenden. Also wir wissen, die Evidenz muss diktiert die Konfidenz. Wir dürfen jeden beliebigen Belief haben. Wir dürfen nur keine Konfidenz rein tun, die größer ist als die Evidenz.
Ich habe noch eine Frage davor.
Sorry.
Wieso machen Leute das überhaupt, aus deiner Sicht, dass sie Experten glauben und nicht selber versuchen, Sachen näherzuladen? Ist das einfach, ist das bequemer? Kostet das weniger Aufwand? Oder ist das ein Risiko, was ich dadurch vermeide, einfach das Risiko, unbequeme Sachen zu zu kennen? Ich verstehe das immer nicht.
Ihre Eltern haben sich einfach besser fortgepflanzt, wenn die das gemacht haben. Das ist die einfachste Erklärung.
Na gut, das finde ich jetzt aber unbefriedigend.
Es gibt auch starke Incentivierung, aber es funktioniert bei Nerds relativ schlecht. Bei uns ist das Ding, wenn der Lehrer uns was in der Schule erzählt hat, dann hatten wir oft Schwierigkeiten, das zu glauben. Weil der Lehrer das nicht logisch begründet hat, sondern durch Autorität. Das ist so das, was den meisten Nerds zu eigen scheint, dass sie Schwierigkeiten haben, von Autoritäten zu lernen. Die müssen das logisch begründet bekommen.
Das kann ja immer noch eine Autorität sein.
Ich bin zum Beispiel selber relativ autoritätsblind. Mir fällt das immer wieder auf die Füße, weil ich widerspreche Leuten und ich merke dann, dass in meiner Umgebung die Leute geschockt sind, weil dieser Mensch so wichtig war. Und mir fällt das nicht auf, dass er wichtig ist. Ich habe Respekt für ihn, weil er hat halt viel gedacht und so weiter und so fort. Aber was mich interessiert, ist, ist er eine Gedanke. Ich kann, also wenn er nur am Chomsky vor mir steht, ist es so, ich halte den für einen der größten Denker seiner Generation, wenigen Menschen, die Argumente nicht in Absätzen denken oder in Seiten, sondern einen ganzen Buchkapitel mit References hintendran. Aber trotzdem, wenn ich mit der Idee nicht übereinstimme, dann widerspreche ich ihm halt. Und normal Leute machen das nicht, weil das halt nur am Chomsky ist. Und für mich ist es sehr schwer intuitiv nachzuvollziehen, warum die das nicht machen. Wie schafften die das, sich auf die Zunge zu beißen?
Na ja, also bizarrerweise ist es wahrscheinlich nur am Chomsky, dir dafür total dankbar sein, dass du das tust. Also ich kenne ein ähnliches Phänomen, dass, wenn ich versuche, Argumente zu entwickeln und dass es halt eine Weile braucht, bis Menschen verstehen, dass ich irgendwie das gerne auch hinterfragt haben möchte und halt irgendwie gerne auch Widerspruch habe, um meine Argumente zu schaffen und mich eigentlich nicht interessiert, ob das jetzt irgendwie eine Autoritätsperspektive ist oder nicht. Aber ich glaube, dass dieses Hinterfragen und dieses logisch herleiten wollen, hat, glaube ich, damit zu tun, wie der Mechanismus von Erinnerung funktioniert. Da gibt es hier ein paar neuere Forschungen dazu, wie erinnern funktioniert. Und eine der stärksten, also es gibt zwei starke Mechanismen. Der eine ist eine emotionale Assoziation mit einem anderen Sinnesreiz oder emotionalen Ankern. Und das andere ist die logische Einordnung. Und also tatsächlich die Einordnung in das, was du weißt, in irgendwie die Dinge, die du über die Welt kennst. Das sind die beiden stärksten Erinnerungsfunktionen, also die in Menschen sind. Meine Vermutung ist, es gibt bisher noch keine guten Untersuchungen dazu gefunden, dass die Intensität dieser Mechanismen bei einzelnen Individuen unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt ist. Und dass Leute, die halt eher autoritär veranlagt sind, eher dieses emotionale Moment haben, eher erinnern sich besser, wenn sie halt es tatsächlich in irgendeiner assoziativen Weise erklärt bekommen, die halt nichts mit dem eigenen Inhalt zu tun hat. Während Leute, die weniger mit den Autoritäten irgendwie klarkommen, eher Leute sind, bei denen es erinnern stärker und besser funktioniert, wenn sie halt irgendwie es logisch erleiten können. Also wenn es halt zum Rest des bekannten Universums Wissens passt. Das ist aber nur so eine wilde Hypothese, die, wie gesagt, ich hab da bisher noch keine Untersuchungen dazu gefunden. Aber Kahnemann hat da so ein paar Untersuchungen gemacht, die tatsächlich auch so starke Evidenz als auch Konfidenz hatten, im Gegensatz zu einigen anderen seiner Papers. Aber an der Stelle sieht die tatsächlich ganz gut aus. Und ich glaube, dass halt diese Frage, wie strukturiert sich Gesellschaft, eben auch aus einer kulturellen Tradition, bestimmt ist, die von außen kaum zu verstehen ist. Also wenn wir uns zum Beispiel China angucken. China als mit dem staatlichen Ziel der harmonischen Gesellschaft, also einen, was halt nur ein sehr utilitaristischer Ansatz ist, also das größtmögliche Glück für die größtmögliche Anzahl Menschen, was auch wiederum heißt, dass im Gegenzug heißt das irgendwie, dass du Individuum bist tatsächlich nur eine Zelle, die vom Organismus abgestoßen werden kann und nobody cares. Das ist halt sozusagen der Grund des chinesischen Gesellschaftsmodells. Wir wollen, dass möglichst viele Zellen in unserem großen Volkskörper glücklich sind, aber wenn es halt ein paar nicht sind, dann ist das halt nicht so schlimm. So und im Gegensatz dazu halt irgendwie der westliche Ansatz, der halt der einzelnen Zelle relativ viel, also dem einzelnen Individuum relativ viel Bedeutung zumisst und der halt irgendwie sagt, okay, wir kriegen es halt trotzdem hin, dass wir alle insgesamt überleben und wer halt irgendwie auch dem der Wert des menschlichen Lebens relativ hochgehängt wird und dass halt also der Wert des Individuums an sich nicht niedriger bewertet wird als irgendwie die Existenz der Gesamtgesellschaft.
Das finde ich übrigens interessant. Da gibt es nämlich die These dazu, dass es nicht westlich, sondern christlich ist. Dass das christliche Wertesystem sagt, du bist im Angesicht Gottes entstanden, in dir ist ein Teil göttliche Flamme, deswegen hast du als Individuum einen Wert.
Das ist die christliche Herleitung der Menschenrechte, wo es auch eine sehr interessante Diskussion dazu gibt, ob es sozusagen eine utilitaristische Herleitung oder eine nicht-christliche Herleitung von Menschenrechten geben kann und ob die nicht möglicherweise schwach ist. Aber das wäre, glaube ich, noch eine völlig andere Diskussion.
Es gibt eigentlich noch drei Alternativen dazu. Eine wäre, es gab ja im römischen Reich die Pax Humana. Die hatten praktisch eine sehr zivile Gesellschaft mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit, anders als mit den Barbaren hier oben. Wir germanischen Barbaren, also unsere Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Großeltern, die lebten in einer Gesellschaft, wo das Recht garantiert wurde durch die Waffen, die deine Familie hatte. Das heißt, wenn du jemanden vergewaltigen wolltest, dann konntest du das machen, sofern deine Familie da in deinem Rücken war und das durchgesetzt hat. Das heißt, wenn jemand in deiner Familie vergewaltigt wurde, von jemandem aus dem anderen Stamm, dann konntest du das sanktionieren, wenn du die entsprechenden Waffen hattest in deinem Rücken. Und das heißt sozusagen, das Rechtssystem wird durch diese direkte Gewalt, die der einzelne Stamm ausüben kann, gegeben. Und jede Zivilisation entsteht dadurch, dass du erst mal so ein Todesstern baust, die absolute Macht, dass jede Individuum, jede einzelne Gruppe innerhalb des Staates auslöschen kann bei Bedarf, sodass es keine Möglichkeit gibt, für den Barbaren Widerstand zu leisten. Und das ist genau der Grund, weshalb Anarkin und Skywalker das macht. Der hat einfach kapiert, nachdem seine Mutter von Barbaren zu Tode gefoltert wurde und er später seine Ehefrau verloren hat und so weiter und so fort, und er gemerkt hat, diesem Universum gibt es für mich keine Liebe mehr. Damit es Liebe geben kann, muss sich ein Universum schaffen, in dem Barbaren nicht die Mutter von deinen Kindern entführen und zu Tode foltern. Die machen das nämlich nicht aus Mangel an Liebe, sondern einfach, weil sie verdammt noch mal können. Weil sie damit durchkommen. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, dass sie nicht damit durchkommen, besteht darin, dass ich einen verfickten Todesstern baue und dann sage ich den Barbaren, was ihre Incentives sind und wenn sie das nicht kapieren, dann war's das. Und dann bleiben zum Schluss die übrig, die sich an die Regeln halten. Also der Todesstern ist halt das Militär. Wenn du in Deutschland versuchst, ein Draglord zu sein, deine eigene Armee aufzubauen, dann passiert dir was Schlimmes. Es gibt diesen Todesstern.
Ein Reichsstörger.
Nimmt praktisch für den normalen Bürger die Gewalt vom Tisch. Und das Gleiche passiert im Römischen Reich. Und dadurch entsteht die Zivilisierung mit Gerichtsbarkeit und so weiter, wo die Leute versuchen, sich ohne Gewalt zu einigen. Und wenn sie doch Gewalt einsetzen, wird das halt schon im Staat sanktioniert und im Zaum gehalten. Und dadurch hast du mit einem mal viel geregelte Zivilisation mit viel weniger Reibungsverlusten. Und dann haben sie es aber nicht geschafft, so ähnlich wie wir auch heute, die Incentives für die Regierung richtig zu setzen. Das Problem ist halt, dass Regierungen sind Parasiten und die erfolgreichsten Regierungen sind die Parasiten mit dem längsten Game. Und das ist aber schwierig stabil zu halten, wenn der Regierung nicht alles gehört. Das heißt, wenn der Regierung nicht alles gehört, hat die immer ein gewisses Incentive zu Defekten. Und vieles von den Gemeinheiten, die die Regierung so machen, kann man besser dadurch erklären, nicht dadurch, dass sie irgendwie nicht genau nachgedacht haben oder bösartig sind, sondern einfach, dass sie ihre Incentives verstehen. Und eh kann es eine Regierung haben, die ihre Incentives nicht versteht, aber die Incentives für den Rest der Gesellschaft richtig setzt. Das ist ja die Aufgabe von der Regierung.
Wieso funktioniert denn das in der Regierung, dass die Gruppen Incentives greifen und die Individuen Incentives weniger? Während im Rest der Gesellschaft habe ich irgendwie den Eindruck, es sind eher die individualen Incentives, die greifen und nicht die Gruppen.
Das Ding ist, dass die Regierungsleute halt Macht haben. Und die Macht bedeutet, Incentives zu verändern. Das ist der Witz von der Regierung, dass du Macht hast.
Naja, also ich glaube, dass halt dieses Problem mit den Incentives ist ja in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft ja durchaus in Regelbarkeit. Also eigentlich ist ja der, also mit irgendwie tonusmäßigen Wahlen und so weiter und irgendwie den Checks and Balances und so, ist ja der eigentlich die Idee dahinter, dass die Incentives der Leute, denen wir die Macht anvertrauen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise veränderbar sind. So mit großen Dämpfungsfunktionen, weil wir können sie nicht sofort abwählen, außer es stehen eine Million Leute mit Fakten und Mistkabeln auf der Straße. Aber es ist zumindest irgendwie irgendeine Art von von Regelkreis und Regelmechanismus da. Und wenn wir uns jetzt so Länder angucken, in denen es fehlt, also wenn wir halt so Standarddiktaturen angucken oder Demokraturen, wo irgendwie mysteriöserweise derselbe Herrschaft seit 35 Jahren immer wiedergewählt wird, dann hast du halt in solchen Ländern ja das Problem, dass diese, die Leute, die drumherum sind, die Regierung an sich, also der Regierungsapparat, halt zwangsläufig immer in eine Klappdokratie verfällt. Also es gibt halt eigentlich keine Ausnahme, wo es nicht so ist. Weil die natürlich wissen, irgendwann ist Schicht im Schacht, irgendwann stirbt der alte Diktator, oder sie kriegen den Machtübergang nicht hin, oder was auch immer, also müssen sie halt so sehen, dass sie sich bis dahin möglichst noch die Taschen voll machen. Und dazwischen haben wir irgendwie bisher noch nichts Erfolgreiches gefunden. Also es gab halt irgendwie Experimente mit sozialistischen Gesellschaften, die halt nur in einer anderen Klappdokratie abgeglitten sind, aber halt irgendwie jetzt keine, also bisher noch keine, keine Struktur, die halt irgendwie Erfolg hatte. Und wenn man jetzt aber den sozusagen wieder von der Metaebene betrachtet, von der wir jetzt gerade kamen, wäre es ja eigentlich nur eine Frage eines kulturellen und wertere Regelwerkes und vielleicht eines Trainings und einer Programmierung, eine Gesellschaft zu schaffen, die halt auf Kooperation beruht. Also die halt darauf beruht, dass Menschen freiwillig miteinander kooperieren, um halt irgendwie immer im Rahmen dieses kulturellen Ziels oder des Wesens des Erhalts der Zivilisation, des Erhalts der Gesellschaft, irgendwie das möglichst Überlebens einer so größtmöglichen Anzahl von Individuen halt irgendwie voranzukommen und möglicherweise so ein System zu besiedeln, falls wir irgendwie noch zu viel Langeweile und Zeit haben.
Du kriegst natürlich das spieltheoretische Problem, was passiert, wenn Leute davon, dass sie nicht kooperieren, einen Vorteil haben. Also wie kannst du sicherstellen, dass die Defector-Strategie nicht dir einen Vorteil bringt?
Auch nicht kurzfristig, das ist das Hauptproblem. Es gibt viele Spieletheorien, wo sich das langfristig nicht lohnt, aber du kannst kurzfristig einen Vorteil ziehen.
Es gibt einfach so eine automatische, auch wenn du so einen Anfang ein total tolles Wertesystem hast, so eine Art Value-Draft. Solange du dich nicht enforce in irgendeiner Weise, dass die Leute wissen, was die Incentives sind, dass also so eine Macht da ist, die tatsächlich deine Reward-Funktion so verändert, dass die Descent of the Fresh Revolution kompatibel mit dem Gemeinwohl wird, dann werden die Leute defekten.
Ich glaube übrigens, der Schlüssel ist, dass du nicht die Werte versuchst zu ändern oder die Incentives, sondern die Menschen. Dass du einfach ein Term-Limit hast.
Genetic Engineering.
Nee, nein, nein. Dass einfach niemand... Also du kannst, was heißt du, man kann ein System schaffen, wo du ein sehr langes Spiel spielen musst, um einen Vorteil rauszuziehen und kurzfristige Gewinne mitnehmen hast, du verhindert durch Checks und Balances. Und wenn du das kombinierst mit irgendeinem Mechanismus, der die Menschen austauscht auf den Posten, das ist das Schnellste oder das Zuverlässigste meines Erachtens, was wir gefunden haben. Das sind nicht die Incentives oder Checks and Balances, die so toll sind. Das siehst du jetzt bei Trump. Sondern der Trick ist, dass selbst so jemand eben nicht einfach unendlich lange herrschen kann. Ja, das musst du halt effektiv vermeiden. Und ansonsten, das ist das Beste, was du erreichen kannst, aus meiner Sicht.
Niemand wird länger herrschen als 80 Jahre. Das Problem ist eigentlich schon nicht so da.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon viel zu lange.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Zum Beispiel haben die USA diese Term-Limits. Und ich glaube, im Augenblick beißen sie sich ein bisschen in den Po deswegen. Weil in Deutschland gibt es keine Term-Limits und wir haben damit ziemlich gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Also die Kohle-Ära und die Merkel-Ära sind relativ stabile Geschichten. Und wenn die Merkel regelmäßig weg gewesen wäre, dann die hätten lieber Obama gewählt jetzt. Also die Alternative war halt, wir kriegen Hillary Clinton, die den Libyen-Krieg und den Syrien-Krieg zu verantworten hat und auch den Jugoslawien-Krieg, weil sie Bill damals überredet hat. Und deren Versprechen ist, wählt mich. Ich mache ungefähr die gleiche Politik wie Obama, bloß ein bisschen schlechter. Und das war wirklich Proposal im Prinzip. Außerdem bin ich eine Frau. Und deswegen müsste er mich wählen. Das ist fortschrittlich und nicht den Sanders, weil der ist ein alter weißer Mann. Und deswegen, egal, was er für Policies vertritt, questionable. Und dann kommt der Trump, der irgendwie sagt, okay Leute, 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind abgehängt. Und ich rede mal für die und gegen die Presse, die komplett hinter Hillary stand. Das war so ein Perfect Storm, weil jemand ohne einen Plan es schaffen konnte, an die Riegerung zu gehen, weil der allgemeine Plan nicht gut war.
Na ja gut, da gab es noch ein paar andere Faktoren, glaube ich.
Wie sind wir denn vom berechenbaren Universum zu Trump gekommen?
Lasst uns weggehen von dem Trump-Funktlichen.
Ich fliege da gleich mal wieder zurück.
Wir waren vorher beim Römischen Reich. Das ist dann zusammen passiert, dass die Leibgarde des Kaisers den Kaiser ermordet hat, dann den Job des Kaisers versteigert hat, meist bietend, an jemanden, der sich bereichern wollte. Er hat das dann zwei Monate lang gemacht und wurde wieder von der Leibgarde ermordet.
Das haben sie ein paar Mal gespielt.
Das führt nicht zu einer stabilen Region.
Nach zwei, drei Iterationen merken die das.
Es ist einfach perverse incentives. Es ist schlecht gesetzte Incentives in dem Ding. Es ist total schwer, die Incentives für die Incentivegeber richtig zu setzen. Und irgendwann kam halt eine Gruppe von Leuten im römischen Reich zusammen, die gesagt haben, das geht so nicht weiter. Lass uns diese Gesellschaft in einen Kult umwandeln. Und die haben sich dann dieses Drehbuch von den Hebräern genommen, haben festgestellt, wir können das nicht eins zu eins übernehmen, weil das ist halt nur für einen Stamm gedacht. Die sollen auch alle bitteschön da von Abraham abstammen. Das steht da alles genau, diese Genealogie drin und so. Das ist nicht gedacht für einen Völkerstaat. Und die haben sich dann in Jesus ausgesucht und haben diese Interfezgötter, die Heiligen erfunden, die man promoten und demoten kann nach Bedarf, um viele Bevölkerungsgruppen einzufangen in dem Ding. Dann haben sie die Kirche installiert, als die Institution, die über die Jahrtausenden hinweg dieses Betriebssystem für die Gesellschaft updaten sollte. Und sie haben es nicht geschafft, den Untergang des römischen Reiches zu verhindern. Also es ist trotzdem Touchette gegangen und nachdem Rom weg war, die einzige Millionenstadt, die es da in der Gegend gab, gab es keine Stadt, die größer war als 50.000 Einwohner. Die haben die Architektur verloren, Landwirtschaft, alles. Und dann gab es praktisch 1000 Jahre ziemliche Dunkelheit. Und so 1000 Jahre später gibt es Paracelsus, ein Arzt, der sagt, ich bin fast so gut wie Celsus, dieser römische Arzt von vor 1000 Jahren. So finster war es, so lange hat das gedauert, bis die Leute wieder von den Bäumen runtergekrabbelt sind. Und die Kultur, die dann kam, ist nicht irgendwie die alte römische Kultur, die wieder aufgewacht ist, sondern das kam eigentlich, dieses Entleiten nicht mehr aus Rom, sondern aus den Provinzen, wo die Leute sich von dieser Sekte losgemacht haben und angefangen haben, selbstständig zu denken. Und der Humanismus ist aus einer bestimmten Form von Rationalität geworden worden. Die haben halt gesagt, diesen Gott, von dem die katholische Kirche redet, den gibt es höchstwahrscheinlich nicht, für den gibt es keine Evidenz. Aber dieses Bedürfnis nach Bedeutung, nach diesem Heiligen, das wir in den gemeinsamen Zielen sehen, den wir allgemeinsam dienen, das gab es immer noch. Und da war die Frage, wo ist denn dieses Heilige jetzt? Und der Humanismus gibt als Antwort, der Mensch ist das Heilige. Und deswegen ist so die Frage, also ist der Wert des Individuums, ist das die Folge von dem römischen Reich und dieser Pax Humana, der Zivilisierung, wo jeder ein gutes Angebot vom Staat bekommen muss, damit er mitspielt? Oder ist das praktisch die Christianisierung, wo wir sagen, okay, wir haben nicht dieses hebräische Ding, sondern wir haben viel Völkerstaat, wo jeder eine Rolle hat, solange er mitmacht. Wenn er nicht mitmacht, wird er natürlich verbrannt. Er muss diese Religion übernehmen. Die Juden haben das nicht gemacht, die haben aber zu ihrer Progrome abgekriegt. Aber im Großen und Ganzen wurden die Leute gezwungen, bei dieser Religion mitzumachen. Oder ist es der Humanismus, wo du den Leuten das Recht gegeben hast, zu denken, was sie wollten, und trotzdem nicht dafür verfolgt zu werden, solange sie sich anständig benehmen?
Na ja, und die Frage, wie kann der Humanismus den nächsten absehbaren Angriff des dunklen Zeitalters überstehen, wird ja langsam akut. Also wir haben ja eine Situation, wo halt die, wir auf der einen Seite so ein bisschen das Gefühl haben, die Zeit des Universums zu verstehen, wird langsam so ein bisschen knapp so, weil so viel Planet ist nicht mehr übrig. Und irgendwie wir haben zunehmende Dekorenz in den Gesellschaften, die es halt irgendwie immer schwieriger macht, halt irgendwie halbwegs sinnvolle Projekte anzustoßen, mit denen wir irgendwie vorankommen würden. Und auf der anderen Seite fühlt es sich halt so ein bisschen so an, als wären wir jetzt nicht allzu weit weg davon. Also als wäre halt so, also es könnte es halt knapp werden so.
Also es kann passieren, dass die KI uns noch vor dem Global Warming killt.
Dass die KI uns vor dem Global Warming killt. Warum sollte die KI uns denn eigentlich killen?
Ich finde, es gibt Leute, die keine Angst vor KI haben. Ich finde das total faszinierend. Und mir wird dann ab und zu mal so bewusst, das liegt nicht daran, dass die irgendwas sehen, was ich nicht sehe. Also dass die irgendwie sehen, dass es total ungefährlich ist, den Planeten mit was zu teilen, was schlauer ist als du.
Hast du nicht Mars-Attacks gesehen? Da gab es auch dieses Hochhaus, wo die Hippies drauf stehen und winken. So zu den Aliens, die kommen mit den fetten Kanonen an den Schiffen. Solche Leute gibt es immer, die sind halt positiv eingestellt.
Ich stelle mir vor, dass so eine Gruppe von Schimpansen um das erste Feuer sitzt, was sie gemacht haben und darüber nachdenken, jetzt intelligentere Nachkommen zu zwingen. Aber dass man Regeln für die vorgibt, damit es safe ist, was sie da machen, damit die Schimpansen niemals begraben werden.
Ich will da aber kurz ein bisschen Luft rauslassen. Was ich momentan sehe, ist jede Menge Hype. Amazon schlägt mir immer noch dieselben Sachen vor, die ich 30 Sekunden vorher gekauft habe. Das kann nicht so weit her sein mit der KI.
Wir haben keine KI. Was wir haben, ist die zweite Welle von diesem Zelt.
Wir haben im Moment, das Einzige, was ich bisher gesehen habe, was mich überzeugt hat, ist Vision. Also Object Recognition in Bildern ist ein gelöstes Problem.
Es ist aber auch nicht recognition.
Solange die Welt aus Objekten besteht, die es trainiert hat. Schon bei LED-Verkehrsschildern, die mit einem anderen Takt laufen als die Kameras, auf die dieser AI guckt, steht dieser AI im dunklen Wald, weil sie ein Stoppschild sieht, wo eigentlich eine Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung ist. Also das ist halt so der Stand heute. Wir können noch nicht mal durch eine Stadt fahren, ohne Leute zu überfahren. Wir haben gerade irgendwie Andrew NG., der...
Was heißt hier nicht mal?
Der dir sagt, wir können das mit diesem autonomen Fahren vergessen, bis die Fußgänger anfangen, sich zu benehmen. Das ist der Stand der Dinge heute. Wir haben nicht mal im Ansatz sowas wie ein Bewusstsein oder auch nur eine Emulation von Bewusstsein. Wir haben die Embodiment-Leute, die mit Robotern vor sich hin basteln, die lernen mit drei Beinen zu laufen. Nice. Aber ich sehe da nichts, was auch nur im Ansatz mir die Sorge bereiten sollte, dass wir jetzt eine AI haben, die die Menschheit killen oder versklaven sollte in meiner Lebenszeit. Ich finde, die Frage ist schon... Warte mal, ich würde gerne mal deine Meinung dazu hören, weil tatsächlich ist halt dieser Disconnect zwischen, was wird dann tatsächlich geliefert, was sind die Papers, was sehe ich irgendwie, was irgendwie produktisiert wird und was möglich ist, also was theoretisch möglich ist. Und den Warnungen vor irgendwie, die fiese AI wird uns alle versklaven, das passt nicht zusammen.
Das ist doch jetzt schon so. Guck dir doch die Hochzeitsgemeinschaften in Afghanistan an. Das ist, da steht zwar nicht AI drauf, aber im Wesentlichen ist es das. Ja, du hast eine Software, die aus Kompressionsgründen, um Bandbreite zu sparen, irgendwie schon selbst vorentscheidet und dir nur die Sachen zeigt, von denen das Trainingsmodell weiß, dass du zustimmen würdest, dass man es bombardieren muss.
Ja, es ist genau das, von dem Frank meint, dass es das nicht ist. Weil das Ding blöd ist. Es hat kein Weltmodell.
Genau, was wir da sehen, ist einfach nur Patternrecognition und Kompressionsfunktionen, die dafür sorgen, dass Dinge, die Menschen zur Aufmerksamkeit kommen, müssen die Menschen zur Aufmerksamkeit kommen. Ja, wir autonomes Fahren. Das Ding kann halt so lange fahren, bis da keine Baustelle ist oder nicht Schnee liegt.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite versagen doch auch die menschlichen Fahrer die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das ist egal. Das ist ein völlig disjunktes Problem.
Nein, aber...
Ich rede gerade davon, ich will da jetzt nicht hin, ich will dabei wissen, warum glaubst du, dass uns die AI ausrotten wird? Also was ist sozusagen der Punkt, den wir da gerade übersehen, ausgehend von der, doch eher, also meine Perspektive gerade ist, wir steuern eigentlich auf den nächsten AI-Wind dazu, weil, was da gerade ist, liefert nicht. Das Einzige, was das kann, ist uns Werbung geben und irgendwie Facebook manipulieren.
Nee, auch nicht. Auch nicht. Gerade Werbung funktioniert nicht.
Gut, also, nicht mal Werbung funktioniert. Also sozusagen, warum glaubst du, dass das tatsächlich ein ernsthaftes Risiko ist?
Wir müssen uns mal überlegen, was ist ein Geist eigentlich? Was macht der so? Wir haben ja vorhin gesagt, was dieser universelle Computer ist und dass man den relativ einfach bauen kann aus allem Möglichen. Und jetzt ist das Problem, nachdem wir den gebaut haben, groß genug gemacht haben und unsere Computer sind inzwischen wahrscheinlich groß genug für das, was wir brauchen, ist die Frage, wie kriegt man den dazu, dass er das richtige Programm laufen lässt? Was ist das richtige Programm? Ich glaube, Intelligenz ist eigentlich die Fähigkeit, Modelle zu machen. Es ist nicht das Gleiche, wie smart zu sein, das heißt, seine Ziele gut zu erreichen. Oder weise zu sein, das heißt, die richtigen Ziele auszuwählen. Sondern sehr viele intelligente Menschen sind überhaupt nicht weise und viele sind auch nicht smart. Die sind einfach sehr gut, Modelle zu machen. Und ein Modell ist eine Funktion, und zwar eine, die Information auf Information aufbildet. Die Bedeutung von Information ist die Relation, die sie hat zu Veränderungen in anderer Information. Das heißt, wenn du so einen kleinen Blip auf deiner Retina hast, dann ist die Bedeutung dieses Blips auf deiner Retina die Relation, die du findest, die Beziehung, die du findest zwischen diesem Blips und anderen Blips auf deiner Retina. Zu anderen Zeitpunkten oder zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Und diese Beziehung, die unser Gehirn findet, indem es diese Blips auf der Retina geeignet zählt, ist ein Modell, in dem Leute durch einen dreidimensionalen Raum laufen und Ideen austauschen und von der Sonne beschieden werden und unter Bäumen sind und so weiter und so fort und Mate trinken. Und die Blips, die wir es nicht schaffen, eine Beziehung dazu herzustellen, die sind Neues. Und sehr viele Blips auf unserer Neuzart sind einfach Neues. Also unser Gehirn ist im Prinzip eine Art von Maschine, die versucht, Impulse zu zählen, um Modelle zu machen, die vorherzusagen, was als nächstes für Samples auf der Retina und auf dem Hautüberfläche und so weiter auftauchen und auch im Gehirn. Im Gehirn praktisch diese eine Schnittstelle, dieses Schaltbord des Gehirns, ist der Thalamus. Da kommen die Daten vom Auge und vom Rückenmark und so weiter rein und versammeln sich. Und auch die Daten vom Gehirn werden darunter gespiegelt und an andere Regionen weiter verteilt.
Moment, du hast aber einen wichtigen Schritt übersehen. Es gibt eine Kompression vorher. Die Bandbreite reicht gar nicht, um die Daten zu übertragen, sondern es wird...
Das Vorhersagen ist Kompression.
Ja eben, das ist...
Das Datenkomprimieren ist, du versuchst vorher zu sagen, was als nächstes passiert und dann musst du nun die Differenz codieren.
Ja, aber pass auf, worauf ich... Das ist genau, was ich gerade über die Drohnen-AI in Afghanistan gesagt habe. Das macht unser optisches System auch, dass die die Messdaten werden nicht alle übertragen, sondern die werden schon vorgefiltert und aus den Ergebnissen kann unser Gehirn dann aber trotzdem Entscheidungen treffen.
Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich dem unser Mustererkennungsprogramm, die versuchen solche Relationen zu kriegen mit irgendeiner Approximationsfunktion, dann kann es passieren, wenn ich denen zu wenig Daten gebe, dass ich nicht weiß, woran die das erkennen, was sie da erkennen. Also ich gebe denen zum Beispiel ganz viele Bilder und das neuronale Netz schafft es, diese Bilder sorgfältig auseinanderzusortieren und erkennt halt, auf diesen ganzen Bildern sind Oktopie drauf. Und wenn du dann aber reinguckst in das Programm, was es eigentlich lernt, das ist möglicherweise nur ein Histogramm von dem Bild. Bei den ganzen Oktopus-Filtern war die Farbverteilung halt so, dass es funktioniert. Und wenn du dich gerne als Oktopus verkleiden willst, musst du nur ein T-Shirt mit der richtigen Farbverteilung anhaben und die KI denkt, du bist ein Oktopus. Wie stellst du sicher, dass sowas nicht passiert? Also, dass es Beispiele gibt in der Welt, die die KI verwirren, weil sie halt eben kein komplettes Volt-Meld-Modell hat. Das Ding ist, dass wir tatsächlich, wir lernen immer auf ein komplettes Weltmodell hin. Wenn wir morgens aufwachen, dann haben wir so eine Art Realitätstrieb. Wir haben so wie ein Taucher, der aufwacht aus dem Wasser und nach Luft schnappt, haben wir das Bedürfnis morgens, wenn wir uns nach unseren Träumen Bootstrappen in die Wirklichkeit die Welt so zusammensetzen, dass sie Sinn ergibt. Stellt euch mal vor, ein Teil der Welt würde keinen Sinn ergeben. Es würde nicht einzuordnen sein. Das ist wie ein Gefühl, keine Luft zu kriegen. Wir versuchen immer, alle Sachen, die wir sehen, zusammenzusetzen in ein kohäsives Modell der Welt. In unserem Falle ist das Modell, das wir erkennen, das ist die Karte aufgefallen, Objekte im dreidimensionalen Raum, Rest extensor. Jedes Pixel, das wir sehen, lässt sich mappen auf irgendeine Oberfläche, die im 3D-Raum rumläuft.
Also mit Ausnahme vom Noise.
Ja, aber genau, der Rest ist halt Noise. Und sofern es nicht zu viel Noise gibt, also die Noise sollte auch möglichst irgendwie normal verteilt sein, im besten Falle, sodass wir es erklären können als Sachen, die auf unsere Neuronen passieren, und das sind Hot-Pixels. Also das gleiche Neuronen sind immer das falsche Signal, dann kann das auch erklärt werden. Dann können wir die Realität abbilden. Also das ist das einfachste Modell, was wir finden. Alles, was wir sehen, sind Objekte im 3D-Raum. Es stellt sich heraus, das ist nicht unser einziges Konstraint. Wir können auch 2D-Werten lernen und anscheinend können wir bis zu bestimmten Grad auch 4D-Werten lernen. Wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, weil es denn zu kompliziert wird.
Okay, aber ich sag mal, da haben wir ja den Schritt zu verstehen, wie unser Sehen funktioniert, relativ erfolgreich dahin transformiert, wie maschinelles Sehen funktioniert.
Ganz, also ich hab so eine Wette mit Simon De Deo gerade gemacht, der behauptet hat, dass diese adversarial examples in der KI immer ein Problem sein werden.
Moment, das ist nicht sehen, das ist erkennen. Das Sehen selbst haben wir erfolgreich nachgebaut. Den nächsten Schritt kriegen wir nicht hin. Und wo du die ganze Zeit über Neues redest, das ist ein Teil, nein, das Sehen können wir noch nicht.
Wir können das nur erkennen.
Nein, nein, wir können halt nicht erkennen. Wir können nur sagen, diese Funktionen matchen, aber wir erkennen nicht, das ist ein Oktopus. Die KI erkennt kein Oktopus. Die KI erkennt, dass die Funktionen gut matchen, die du ihm gegeben hast beim Trainieren. Mehr aber auch nicht.
Aus meiner Sicht ist das Recognition sozusagen, das Recognition heißt, dass Pattern matchen. Und das Sehen ist ein Prozess, mit dem wir eine innere Simulation bauen und die so nachführen, dass sie voraussagt, was als nächstes für Pattern auf unserem Tal haben muss auftauchen werden. Das ist das, was wir noch nicht können. Das ist mehr als nur Recognition.
Das ist jetzt eine Wortfrage. Also aber der Hintergrund von Kognition und Erkennen heißt erkennen. Und die KI erkennt halt nichts, deswegen kann es auch nichts erkennen, sie kann nur sehen. Den Sehnteil haben wir gut gebaut. Und übrigens der Noise, von dem du hier redest, der geht bei uns auch schon zum Großteil im optischen System schon verloren. Der kommt gar nicht an beim Gehirn.
Das Gehirn ist voller Noise. Das Gehirn filtert nur Noise. Ich vermute, dass ein sehr kurzer, also jedes Neuron wird, wenn es dir anguckst, an guten Tagen ist es 50 Prozent der Zeit nicht total Noise. Und das Gehirn ist ein riesen großer Noise-Filter im Wesentlichen.
Na gut, aber um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen. Also wir können mal festhalten, egal, ob wir jetzt die Definition mitsehen und erkennen, was ein Haar dividieren oder nicht. Was halt relativ gut funktioniert, ist eine Abwesenheit von Menschen erdachten adversarial samples. Also wo wir halt irgendwie versuchen, mit den Trainingsdaten zu spielen, indem wir halt irgendwie Farbgradienten auf die Verdrucken, von denen wir wissen, dass sie halt irgendwie dazu führen, dass das Kamerasystem uns für ein Octopus hält. Oder indem wir halt irgendwie lustig aussehen, eine verschwurbelte Form auf Verkehrsschilder kleben, die dazu führen, dass das System denkt, da steht ein Gesicht oder so. Oder was auch immer die Irritationsfunktionen sind. Aber in Abwesenheit davon sind wir halt schon relativ weit. Sagen wir so, Klassifikation von Objekten in Bildern, das geht einigermaßen gut.
Das Ding ist, wenn wir im Gehirn angucken, wenn wir Dimension Adversarial Examples geben, das brauchen die länger, die zu erkennen. Und was wir sehen im Gehirn, ist, dass viele Muster erkennen wir sehr schnell, wenn sie sehr eindeutig sind. Und bei bestimmten Sachen ist es so, dass das Gehirn erst mal Rücksprache halten muss. Das heißt, da wird als erstes ein Signal ganz nach oben propagiert bis ins Frontalhirn und kommt dann wieder zurück. Das heißt, das Gehirn sucht wahrscheinlich nach einer gesamten Repräsentation der Welt und versucht diese Daten im Kontext zu interpretieren. Und in dem Kontext macht das adversarial example überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das heißt, das Gehirn muss so lange an diesen Bits rumfuschen, bis es sie so interpretiert hat, dass es im Gesamtbild der Welt Sinn macht. Und es gibt nicht so viele Interpretationen, in denen das Sinn macht.
Wir haben auch richtige adversarial samples. Wir nennen sie nur anders. Die heißen bei uns optische Täuschung.
Moment, das ist was anderes. Die optischen Täuschungen entstehen in der Regel dadurch, weil wir dieses Problem von 3D sehen, das ist ein ill-defined problem. Du kannst bei dem Pixel, wenn es ein 2D-Ding ist, nicht genau erkennen, wo es in 3D ist. Und deswegen reagieren wir auf Cues, um das an die richtige Position zu schieben, damit diese Konvergenz schneller passiert. Und der Preis, den wir dafür zahlen, dass wir diese Biases in Vision einbauen, damit das Bild besser konvergiert ist, dass wir untypische Situationen nicht so gut erkennen. Aber dafür in typischen Situationen besser funktionieren. Aber es gibt richtig adversarielle Säuren, wenn ich dich kitzle. Beim Kitzeln scheint so was zu passieren, dass in dem somatosensischen Kontext eine Frequenz auftaucht, die nicht vorhergesagt werden kann und deswegen nicht gefiltert wird. Du musst genau richtig kitzeln, damit es nicht vorhergesagt wird und stabilisiert wird, das Muster. Und das leckt dann raus in die andere Region und der ganze Körper fängt an zu zittern. Und das ist wahrscheinlich eine Art adversarieller Example. Es gibt Leute, die sind weniger kitzelig und das ist wahrscheinlich der Preis, den wir dafür zahlen, dass sie auch weniger empfindlich sind. Du hast dann weniger Auflösung. Leute, die mehr Auflösung haben, also genauer fühlen, was auf der Haut passiert, die sind kitzdicker.
Aber es gibt ja sowas wie optische Täuschungen, die halt zu Tarn- und Täuschenzwecken eingesetzt werden, wo halt man absichtlich damit spielt, was das Gehirn da erwartet, also was im Modell halt irgendwie vorhanden sein sollte. Und welche Muster typischerweise in so einer Gegend auftauchen, dann emuliert diese Muster, um halt die Erkennung des eigentlichen Musters zu verändern. Aber zurück zu unserem KI-Overlord.
Also das Ding ist, wenn wir uns angucken, was die KI jetzt macht. Die erste Phase der KI war das, was wir 1950 angefangen hatten, was Marvin Minsky und viele andere gemacht haben. Das war so die algorithmische KI, die klassische KI. Das sieht so aus, dass der schlaue Leute sich überlegen, was muss ich denn tun, um auf der Welt gleich Schach zu spielen? Da decken sie sich einen Algorithmus aus und programmieren den runter. Und dann spielt das Ding halt einigermaßen gut Schach. Und jetzt haben wir eine andere Phase. Jetzt bauen wir Systeme, die selber lernen, was diese Funktionalität ist. Die approximieren die Funktion selber. Und das heißt, wir schreiben jetzt praktisch von Hand einen Algorithmus, irgendwie 2000 Zeichen TensorFlow-Code, der das noch in einem Netz definiert, das selber die Funktionen approximiert. Und das heißt, wir von Hand optimieren wir vielleicht in 2000 Dimensionen, um dann mehrere Milliarden Dimensionen automatisch zu dimensionieren. Und das ist relativ klar, worauf das hinausläuft. Wir werden diese Programme, die die Programme schreiben, ebenfalls implementieren. Das heißt, wir gehen dann zum Meta-Lernen. Wir bauen Systeme, die lernen zu lernen. Und im Augenblick ist das Ding, dass die Lernfunktionen, die wir benutzen, sind nicht so universell wie unsere Gehirnfunktion. Unser Gehirn benutzt andere Algorithmen als die neuronalen Netze, andere Klassen von Verfahren. Die Entropie aus den Daten, die Bayesian Regeln, sind die gleichen. Aber unser Gehirn muss wesentlich weniger links anfassen, um sich zu updaten auf die Trainingsdaten. Wir erschlagen das Problem, indem wir massive Computerpower drauf tun. D.h. diese neuronalen Netze, die in unseren Computern laufen, die haben unglaubliche Mengen von Rechenkapazität zur Verfügung, laufen wesentlich schneller als biologische Neuronen ab und rauschen dabei nicht. Die Leute haben immer den Eindruck, ich hab so eine wahnsinnige Achtung vor dem menschlichen Gehirn, aber kaum einer fragt, wie viel menschliche Gehirn man brauchen würde, um ein Mac OS-Fehler frei ablaufen zu lassen, weil die Dinger so rauschen.
Naja, trotzdem ist ja die Frage...
Ja, dazu wird's aber auch nicht tun wollen.
Das ist eine furchtbare Vorstellung.
Naja, aber trotzdem ist ja die Frage... Also, gut, es gibt halt jetzt so ein paar plakative Beispiele, halt wie irgendwie AlphaGo und so Systeme, die halt irgendwie mit Meta-Learning halt angefangen haben, Computerspiele zu spielen und so, die ja in, sagen wir mal, einfachen regelbasierten Systemen mit einem sehr einfachen Regelset in der Lage sind, durch Erkundung des Möglichkeitenraums unter Ignoranz der eigentlichen Regeln tatsächlich zum Erfolg zu kommen. Na, sozusagen nicht... Das hat ja eigentlich nicht Go gespielt, sondern das hat halt irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gefunden, also jetzt im Sinne von, wie ein Mensch Go spielen würde, sondern das hat ja tatsächlich so Go gespielt, wie noch nie ein Mensch Go gespielt hat.
Nehmt Hunderte von Millionen von Spielen, gegen sich selbst gespielt hat und da drin versucht hat, nach Mustern zu suchen.
Und halt einfach optimal darin zu finden, unter Ignoranz dessen, was halt Menschen bisher gefunden haben.
Obwohl in einer gewissen Weise ist das auch das, was Menschen gemacht haben. Menschen haben Millionen von Spielen gegen andere Menschen gespielt und haben gemeinsam nach Mustern daran gesucht und das dann der nächste Generation weitergegeben.
Die Menschen haben aber nach defensiven Mustern gesucht. Ja, also eine Analyse von dem ersten Alpha-Go, das war jetzt noch nicht das, was die Regeln selbst gelernt hat, sondern das davor. Eine Analyse davon war, dass der Züge gespielt hat, die ein Mensch zu riskant gefunden hätte, weil die in Situationen geführt haben, wo die Anzahl der Optionen, die man betrachten müsste, zu groß ist. Das heißt, Menschen haben instinktiv auch Muster gesucht, aber so örtlich begrenzte Muster. Sachen, von denen sie wussten, die funktionieren. Und der Computer konnte eben offenere Züge spielen, weil er weiter vorher testen konnte als der Mensch. Mir ist aber noch eine Sache wichtig. Man muss trennen zwischen KI und Machine Learning, was wir hier reden. Diese aus der Computer Vision und auch Go-Lernen und neuronale Netze generell. Das ist nicht KI, auch wenn das heute gern so verkauft wird. Das ist Machine Learning. Eine echte KI ist definiert, da heißt ja künstliche Intelligenz. Das muss intelligent sein. Und einer der vielversprechendsten Ansätze in den 80ern war ein System namens COG, wo versucht wurde, einfach über 10, 20 Jahre das Menschheitswissen in computerlesbare Daten zu transformieren.
Was dann später Psych wurde, ne? Ja.
Also jedenfalls der Punkt war, der Mensch, wir haben das ja schon angesprochen, er kennt eben unter anderem durch Zugriff auf sein Wissen über die Welt, welche der möglichen Sachen, die ich ja gerade gesehen haben könnte, können es denn gewesen sein. Ja, wenn du zum Himmel guckst und da fliegt irgendwas rum, dann denkst du, das ist keine Kuh, auch wenn es wie eine Kuh aussieht, weil du weißt, eine Kuh kann nicht fliegen. Und dieses Art von Wissen hat halt ein Computer nicht erstmal. Und das war einer der Versuche, das ist dann, glaube ich, irgendwann eingefallen.
Es gibt sie noch, die hat inzwischen eine Firma gegründet, ich glaube, Lucid AI.
Die gibt's noch.
Ja, die machen noch Zeug. Ist auch nützlich, was sie machen. Das ist nur einfach so, dass es nicht in Richtung KI skaliert bis jetzt. Aber das war ja bei noch und anders noch so. Und das Ligaren der Ansatz, der von Marvin Minsky und so weiter vertreten wurde, dass KI symbolisch ist und über Common Sense gehen muss, den man symbolisch aufschreibt, Prädikattenlogiksystem. Das hat nicht richtig funktioniert. Und ich glaube, da ist ein fundamentaler Ansatz dran, den man sich angucken muss. Wenn man sich die östliche und die westliche Philosophie, also diesen östlichen Idealismus anguckt und den westlichen Mechanismus anguckt, die sehen aus wie krasse Gegensätze. Also du hast in der östlichen oder in dieser idealistischen Philosophie, leben wir im Prinzip alle in einem Traum. Und wir alle sind Figuren, die geträumt werden in diesem Traum. Wir sind Teile des Traums. Und dieser Traum wird von einem Geist auf einer höheren Existenz-Ebene geträumt. Und der Grund, dass es ein Traum ist, ist, dass unsere Welt Magie möglich ist. Und wenn wir uns diese östlichen Religionen angucken, die sind alle voller Magie. Das ist möglich zu levitieren, wenn du das richtig machst. Es ist möglich, Tulpas zu erschaffen, also Menschen durch Geisteskraft zu erzeugen, die tatsächlich durch die Welt stechen. Du kannst in die Zukunft sehen, du kannst Prophezeiungen erfahren, du kannst Göttern begegnen, die sich materialisieren und so was. Das ist alles möglich im Traum. Und tatsächlich, wenn wir dieses okkulte Weltbild akzeptieren, dass die einzige Konsequenz ist, wir müssen im Traum leben. Das ist nicht mechanisch implementiert, sondern das muss eine symbolische Logik haben. Symbolische Logik heißt so wie Minecraft, du kannst halt rufen, es ist ein Time-Set-Day und die Sonne geht auf. Das kann nicht mechanisch implementiert sein. Das ist in dem Falle dann symbolisch implementiert. Da ist Magie drin. Da gibt es irgendwelche Shortcuts, die nicht mechanisch da sind. In unserem Welt, wenn wir wollen, dass die Sonne aufgeht, sieht es aber so aus, dass wir entweder psychotisch sein müssen, also unsere Erinnerungen verändern in geschickter Weise oder ungeschickter Weise. Oder der andere Technik erfordert, dass wir massiv in die Physik eingreifen. Dass wir die Erde halt umrotieren müssen. Und das ist sehr teuer.
Oder wir bewegen uns schnell genug.
Dass wir auf diese Ebene runterkommen. Die westliche Welt geht davon aus, die Welt ist mechanisch und wir sind halt irgendwelche Primaten und leben in dieser Gesellschaft zusammen. Und das Ding, diese beiden Sächten sind nicht gegensätzlich, sondern sie sind komplementär. Die westliche Welt beschäftigt sich mit dieser höheren Existenz-Ebene. Die höhere Existenz-Ebene ist einfach dieser Traum, der da erzeugt wird, der existiert im Neokortex von einem Primaten. Und jeder einzelne von uns hat sein eigenes Universum, das geträumt wird in unserem Neokortex. Die gleichen Schaltkreise, die nachts einen Traum erzeugen, machen das auch tagsüber. Und tagsüber ist der Traum halt so getunt, dass er die nächsten Muster auf dein Netzhaut möglichst genau vorhersagt. Außer wenn du zu viel in die falsche Richtung meditierst oder Drogeneinwürf oder psychotisch wirst, dann geht der Traum halt in irgendeine andere Richtung und du hast ein Problem, eventuell, wenn es nicht aufhört.
Wenn dein Traum zu sehr divergiert von dem, was du an den Podcasts sagst.
Genau, wenn der Traum die Realität nicht mehr gut vorhersagt, dann hast du ein Problem. Wenn der grad in die falsche Richtung zeigt, dann hast du irgendeine Dysphorie, da wurde ein Modell von der Realität abweicht. Das Ding ist aber, dass das, was du als Realität empfindest, diese Wahrheit, die du spürst, das ist immer das Modell, was in deinem Gehirn ist. Diese Muster, die auf dein Netzhaut auftauchen, die erscheinen dir nicht als Wahrheit, sondern das, was du empfindest, als die Wahrheit, was dein Gehirn da rein kodiert in die Simulation. Das ist die Realität. Es gibt Leute wie Christoph Koch, die meinen, dass eine Simulation kein Bewusstsein haben könnte, sondern nur was physisch real ist. Und ich glaube, es ist genau umgekehrt. Was physisch real ist, wie unser Gehirn, kann kein Bewusstsein und keine Gefühle haben. Neuronen können nichts fühlen. Neuronen können nur elektrische Impulse austauschen. Es wäre aber für so ein Gehirn und für so ein Organismus total nützlich zu wissen, wie es wäre, wenn man was fühlen würde, wenn man mit einem Universum konfrontiert ist. Und deswegen machen sie eine Simulation davon. Dieses Gehirn erzeugt einen simulierten Menschen, ein Simulacrum, der sich in einer simulierten VR-Welt bewegt und da Dinge tut und erlebt, die ihm zugefügt werden. Und das Gehirn guckt dann, wie reagiert er denn da drauf, um zu schauen, was es als nächstes tun sollte, um seine Policies zu entscheiden. Und dann passiert dieses komische Ding, diese simulierte Person, die kriegt Zugriffs aufs Sprachzentrum und darf laut rausblöken. Oh Gott, es ist alles so blau, wie kann das sein? Ich empfinde Zeug. Und redet mit anderen simulierten Personen in den Gehirn von anderen Leuten. Aber tatsächlich jeder Einzelne lebt zusammen mit anderen geträumten Personen in einem Traum. Jeder Einzelne im Gehirn eines Primaten. Das ist das, was eigentlich abläuft.
Aber naja gut, aber das heißt, wenn du den Traum dann simuliert bekommst, würdest du sowas bekommen, was sich anfühlen würde wie eine KI.
Der Traum ist ja die Simulation, oder nicht? Hab ich das gerade falsch verstanden?
Nee, aber wenn du den externen simuliert bekommst, meine ich jetzt. Also sozusagen, wenn du den Traum in einem externen neuronalen Netzwerkssystem.
Was heißt extern? Du meinst eine VR?
Nee, im Sinne von Aufsilizium.
Ja, na klar. Was wir bauen müssen als KI ist ein Ding, was eine Realität träumt. Und wir haben ja auch Ansätze in diese Generative Adversarial Networks. Das sind Systeme, bei denen es so funktioniert, dass es zwei neuronale Netze gibt, ein Generator und ein Discriminator, ein Kritiker sozusagen. Der Generator erzeugt Bilder und der Discriminator schaut, ist das Ding eine Simulation oder ist es echt? Ist es ein Bild, was von der Kamera sein könnte? Oder hat er sich das nur ausgedacht? Und die beiden sind im ständigen Wettbewerb. Das ist so, wenn der Discriminator es nicht rauskriegt, wird er sozusagen bestraft und wird incentiviert, seine Diskriminationsleistung zu verbessern. Und wenn der Discriminator versagt und es nicht schafft, der Generator versagt und es nicht schafft, den Kritiker zu überzeugen, dann kriegt der ein Lernsignal und muss seine Bildergeneration verbessern. Und dadurch entwickeln sich die beiden immer besser weiter. Und zum Schluss ist es so, dass dieses neuronale Netz in der Lage ist, zum Beispiel Gesichter von Celebrities zu erzeugen, die niemals existiert haben, die aber total aussehen wie Gesichter von Celebrities.
So, warum wird uns denn jetzt die KI umbringen? Das haben wir noch nicht geklärt.
Beziehungsweise kommt die KI erst mal dahin. Das sehe ich ja noch nicht. Also ich glaube eher, dass uns...
Das ist der Schritt, den ich total sehe.
Nee, also ich sehe, dass uns Menschen mit Hilfe kommen.
Das ist der Schritt. Sobald wir KI haben, hör mal, die muss nur behaupten, irgendwas geht einfacher und dann sagen die Leute, alles klar.
Nee, also ich glaube eher, dass das Gefährliche eher Teams von Menschen und KIs sind, bis die uns umbringen werden. Das halte ich für eher wahrscheinlich als dass es eine KI gibt, die halt hinreichend groß wird, dass sie die Menschheit umbringen kann.
Du meinst, ein physisch ist das Problem und nicht, dass die KI es nicht wollte.
Nein, ich glaube, dass...
Die KI wird nie genug Hardware haben, um es zu tun, ist deine These.
Nee, meine These ist, dass es kein Incentive gibt, tatsächlich eine KI mit so was Ähnliches wie einer Bewusstseinssimulation zu bauen. Weil dafür tatsächlich, es gibt relativ wenig Use Cases dafür. Es gibt aber eine Megatonne an Use Cases für KI's oder Machine Learning Systeme, die als tatsächlich geistige Werkzeuge funktionieren, die halt kognitive Fähigkeiten verbessern, die in der Lage sind, halt irgendwie. Uns eine Vorhersagen über die Zukunft zu machen, die sich oft genug als wahr herausstellen, dass wir am Ende anfangen, dem zu vertrauen.
Frank, darf ich dir erklären, warum wir KI's mit Bewusstsein brauchen?
Ja bitte, gerne. Deswegen bist du hier.
Bewusstsein ist, glaube ich, im wesentlichen Modell der Inhalte unserer Aufmerksamkeit. Also wir sind uns genau dessen bewusst, was mal in unserem Fokus unsere Aufmerksamkeit war. Und zwar zu Lernzwecken. Unsere Aufmerksamkeit ist, unser Gehirn ist nämlich im Gegensatz zu den Neuronanetzen, die wir jetzt benutzen, nicht differenzierbar. Unsere Neuronanetze funktionieren so, dass sie praktisch hintereinander gesetzte Layers sind aus normalisierten, gewichteten Summen von Realzahlen. Und weil diese Funktion, dieses Zusammenaddieren von gewichteten Summen, die dann normalisiert werden mit einer Relo oder mit einer Tangensfunktion, bevor sie in den nächsten Lehrrein gefügt werden, weil man die zurückrechnen kann, können wir sozusagen eine Fehlerfunktion nehmen, die, wenn wir ein Signal durch das ganze Netz schicken, zurückrechnet, an welche Stelle vom Netz wie viel zu dem Ergebnis beigetragen hat. Und dadurch können wir dieses Netz über viele Layern ein bisschen justieren, bis es konvergiert auf ungefähr das Ergebnis, was sie haben wollten. Wenn wir das Netz richtig aufgesetzt haben, ein bisschen Glück haben. Und unser Gehirn ist nicht so aufgebaut. Unser Gehirn hat lauter links die Kreuzung quergehen. Viele von denen gehen zur Seite und viele von denen bilden Schleifen. Und so ein Netz lässt sich sehr, sehr schwer trainieren, wenn das so unregelmäßig ist. Und wir kennen eine Handvoll Techniken, so ein Netz zu trainieren. Eine wichtige ist zum Beispiel ein Eco-State-Network. Da verwert man ein geeignet zusammengebautes, zufälliges Netzwerk, das lauter Rekurrente links hat. Und wenn man da Signale reinschicken, dann fängt das an zu blubbern. Und in diesem dynamischen, chaotischen, also nahezu chaotischen Blubbern an der Grenze zum Chaos, ist wahrscheinlich das drin, was wir suchen. Wie finden wir das? Wir lernen einfach nur den Output-Layer mit einer linearen Regression. Und danach können wir alle Neuronen löschen, die wir nicht brauchten. Und möglicherweise ist das ungefähr der Algorithmus, mit dem unser Gehirn am Anfang seine corticale Kollaps und so weiter in Form bringt.
Das klingt doch schon nach Bewusstsein, oder?
Nee, ist noch kein Bewusstsein. Das richtige Bewusstsein kommt erst viel später. Nämlich dann, wenn das Ding ein Protokoll der Inhalte seiner Aufmerksamkeit macht. Also wenn ich so die initiale Architektur zusammengesetzt habe, layer für layer, und ungefähr in der Lage bin, meinen Körper zu kontrollieren und ein bisschen Ordnung in meinen Vision zu bringen und in meiner Akustik und die Modalitäten auch schon ein bisschen zusammengelötet habe, in so einer Art Hierarchie von Synthesizers, mit der ich die Welt ein bisschen vorhersagen kann, dann muss ich die Feinheiten trainieren. Und dieses Feinheitentrainieren passiert vermutlich so. Ich mache ein Commitment, was ich lernen will. Zum Beispiel, ich möchte jetzt Tennis lernen und ich will meine Backhand verbessern. Ich fokussiere mich also auf diese eine Stelle, auf diese eine Bewegung, die ich machen werde, und habe eine Vorstellung davon, wie das ausgeht. Der Ball wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser in die Richtung gehen. Und in drei Minuten, ab jetzt in der Zukunft, werde ich das Match möglicherweise gewonnen oder verloren haben. Das heißt, ich muss abspeichern, die latenten Variablen, die ich brauche, um diese beiden in der Konfiguration des Gehirns wiederherzustellen, wo ich den Schlag gemacht habe. Weil mein Gehirn ist später in anderen Konfigurationen. Dann muss ich die Bewegung, die ich gelernt habe, also diesen einen Pointer auf die eine Variable, die ich verändert habe, setzen. Und ich muss die Erwartung haben, die ich zum Schluss habe, damit ich es auswerten kann, ob es gut war oder schlecht. Und ich muss triggerbedingungen haben, mit denen ich diese Erinnerung wieder abrufen kann, wenn nämlich das Ergebnis eingetroffen ist, ist das Match verloren oder nicht. So, zwei Minuten später, ich habe eine völlig andere Grundkonfiguration, weil ich inzwischen andere Bewegungen gemacht habe, andere Sachen gedacht habe, dass Match wird verloren. Mir fällt ein, ich habe es verloren. Warum habe ich es verloren? Da habe ich vorhin eine bestimmte Bewegung gemacht, rufe das wieder auf. Es wird eine Erinnerung abgespielt. Erinnerung abspielen heißt, aus diesem Aufmerksamkeitsprotokoll ziehe ich diese latenten Variablen raus, stelle die partielle Gehirnkonfiguration her, in die ich den Schlag gemacht habe und merke, erinnere mich, das war das, was ich gemacht habe. Und dementsprechend, wenn es funktioniert hat, wird der Schlag verstärkt, wenn nicht, wird die Änderung möglichst rückgängig gemacht. Und das ist das Hauptverfahren, mit dem wir anscheinend lernen, glaube ich. Das Problem ist dazu, dass die Architektur wissen muss, wo was steht. Also das Ding muss wissen, an welcher Stelle im Gehirn der Schlag ausgeführt wird. Es muss ein Modell der eigenen kognitiven Architektur haben. Wie erinnere ich das? Ebenfalls mit dem Aufmerksamkeitssystem. Das heißt, das Aufmerksamkeitssystem muss reflexiv werden und sich selbst dazu trainieren, besser zu werden. Das bedeutet, wenn wir unser Aufmerksamkeitsprotokoll rein gucken, also diese ganzen indexierten Memories, dann stellen wir auch Stellen fest, wo wir merken, oh, jetzt hab ich aufgepasst und zwar darauf. Und das hat sich so und so ausgewirkt, dass ich darauf aufgepasst hab und ich hätte aber was anderes aufpassen müssen. Das heißt, das Aufmerksamkeitssystem trainiert sich auch und wird ebenfalls besser und dann wird es reflexiv. Und ich glaube, das ist genau das Ding, was dazu führt, dass wir so ein reflexives Protokoll haben. Das heißt, wir haben lauter Verhaltensprogramme, die jeweils verschiedene Dinge tun, aber die teilen sich Erinnerungen.
Okay, aber da kommt immer noch kein Bewusstsein bei raus. Was wir jetzt bisher haben, ist erst mal ja nur ein Lernen, Optimieren durch Erinnerung.
Was wir haben, ist ein Erinnerungsprotokoll, sehr stromendes Bewusstseins und er ist reflexiv. Was wir noch nicht haben, ist an dieser Stelle das phenomenologische Bewusstsein, also wie sich's anfühlt. Das ist noch ein anderer Aspekt vom Bewusstsein.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist das nur ein Artefakt. Vielleicht ist das gar nicht das Wichtige.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, also subjektiv, wenn ich in das Bewusstsein reingehe, wenn ich ein bisschen meditiere, sieht es so aus. Es gibt so eine Art Bewusstsein nullter Stufe. Das ist, wenn du ganz klar versuchst, bewusst zu werden und dein gesamtes Denken ausschaltest und auf diesen untersten Punkt runtergehst, dann sind die Dinge selbstbewusst. Es ist einfach jede Oberfläche, die du denkst, ist Bewusstsein. Das ist ganz seltsam, aber du kannst nicht denken in den Zustand. Du kannst nur alles, was du denkst, halt Augen und guck irgendwie in die Welt. Das ist, als ob du viele Bewusstseine parallel hast. Dann hast du das Bewusstsein erster Stufe. Das ist der Zustand, in dem, glaube ich, Kinder sind. Das ist so, dass die Welt dir direkt ins Gesicht springt. Du fühlst alles sehr, sehr direkt. Was du wahrnimmst, ist wie so eine große Oszillation. Wenn du länger schaust, breitet es sich immer mehr aus und bezieht immer mehr ein. Es ist praktisch wie so eine Art Schwingkreis, der immer größere Fläche in deinem Neokortex abdeckt und immer mehr Teile in den gleichen Operator rein tut. Also der immer größere Region wird synchronisiert. Du nimmst immer mehr gleichzeitig wahr. Das ist nicht kompatibel mit Sprache und symbolischem Denken bei mir. Sobald ich symbolisches Denken mache, bricht das zusammen. Und sobald ich meine Aufmerksamkeit auf mein symbolisches Denken richte, wo sie fast immer ist, leider, wenn ich nicht ganz viel meditiere, dann ist es so, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich diese Bewusstseinssachen nur so in einer Art Glas herum trage. Mein normales Denken ist so eine Glasträgerei. Und in diesem Glas befindet sich dieses Leuchten des Bewusstseins, das in jedem Schritt dunkler wird. Aber ich komme nicht mehr ran durch das Glas. Ich selber kann nicht das nicht spüren, wo meine Aufmerksamkeit normalerweise ist. Und dann gibt es das linguistische Denken, mit dem ich mit anderen Leuten rede. Und dieses linguistische Denken, das sprachliche Denken, das kennt mein Bewusstsein nur aus fernen Mythen. Das erlebt das aber nicht. Das sind so ungefähr diese Stufen des Bewusstseins, wie ich sie erlebe, wenn ich reingehe. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch ist. Ich habe selten was darüber gelesen, wo jemand die Phänomenologie ordentlich auseinandernimmt. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, wie das passiert. Diese Phänomenologie des Bewusstseins steht dadurch, dass möglicherweise tatsächlich so eine Art Schwingkreis existiert auf der Ebene der Kortige Kollams, wo so eine Art Ping-Eck da ist, das versucht, benachbarte Operatoren zu rekrutieren. Und das Ding immer größer zu machen und kompatibel zu machen, bis du ein konsistentes Weltbild hast. Und diese Konfiguration wird dann verlinkt mit deinem Aufmerksamkeitsprotokoll. Wenn du später daran erinnerst, dann wird dieses Ding wieder abgerufen.
Okay, zurück zu der Frage, warum sollte jemand so was nachbauen?
Also gibt es mehrere Gründe. Das eine ist, es ist verdammt spannend, das zu machen. Und wir verstehen, wie wir funktionieren. Es ist einfach super cool. Endlich mal jemand, mit dem man reden kann. Dann das nächste ist, die Lernalgorithmen, die wir im Augenblick benutzen, bringen es nicht so richtig. Wir brauchen super viele Computers zu machen und mit vielen Sachen tun sie sich schwer. Also nur Lernalgorithmen auszuprobieren, bewusstes Lernen und so weiter, ist eine total gute Idee. Kommt vielleicht was Interessantes bei Rom, lass uns das mal probieren. Vielleicht funktioniert es wirklich besser, als die Maschinenlernalgorithmen, die wir jetzt haben. Und dann natürlich die Anwendungsfälle. Es gibt wahrscheinlich bestimmte Kreativitätsaufgaben, wo menschenähnliche Geister wesentlich besser geeignet sind, als relativ simple Funktionsapproximatoren, die nur in einer Richtung funktionieren, statt eine innere Simulation zu bauen, die sich kreativ an die Welt anpasst, wenn die Welt sich verändert. Und dann bis nächsten natürlich Menschen nerven total. Wird es mir Zeit, was Neues zu machen?
Naja gut, aber das sind halt Gründe. Also ich hab da tatsächlich eher Sorge vor Menschen mit Maschinen.
Aber es reicht ja, wenn es einer tut. Und langfristig muss ich schon sagen, dass sich die Frage stellt, was soll ein KI denn sonst machen, außer uns auslöschen?
Also wir haben vermutlich nicht geschaffen.
Ich meine, welche Option hat denn ne KI?
Wir kennen bestimmt, eine sichere KI zu bauen. Aber das Problem ist, dass wahrscheinlich nicht alle KIs, die gebaut werden können, sicher machen können.
Also ich habe ja tatsächlich große Zweifel, dass irgendwie ne, also dass ne KI...
Oh, wir müssen diese Experimente verlinken von diesem einen Typen, der das als Spiel gemacht hat.
Paperclip.
Der eine spielt ne KI und der andere spielt den Aufpasser. Und die KI hat ne Stunde Zeit, ihn zu überreden, ihn rauszulassen. Unter egal welchen, was sie ihm auch erzählen will. Und der andere hat vorher geschworen, dass er nie ne KI rauslassen würde, weil er weiß, das bringt uns alle um. Da gibt es ne lustige Serie von...
Von Comics.
Nee, nicht Comics. Ich kenn es nicht als Comics.
Ich kenn es als Comics, ja.
Aber also jedenfalls, es gab diese Experimente und man einigt sich dann auch darauf, dass man das genaue Verfahren nicht verrät. Das macht das so ein bisschen spannend für die Zuschauer. Und also die KI kommt raus, ja. Ist die Lektion, die wir ziehen müssen.
Ich hatte mal ne Unterhaltung mit Bruce Schneier zu dem Thema und der meinte, Bruce Schneier ist dieser Krypto-Experte, den wir alle kennen, und der meinte, man kann einen Safe bauen, der total sicher ist. Aber man kann keinen Safe bauen, der total sicher ist, den man auch auf und zu machen kann. Und das Ding ist, wenn wir mit der KI irgendwie reden wollen, dann müssen wir den Safe irgendwie ein bisschen aufmachen.
Es gibt so ein, so ein, ich glaube gut mein Zitat, die einzige Tempor-Proof-Hardware ist Voyager One. Das fand ich auch ganz nett.
Die ist weit genug draußen. Die ist weit genug draußen, dass niemand sie anfassen kann. Aber für mich ist tatsächlich das, also das sind Probleme an der Diskussion gerade, dass wir viele Aspekte davon sehen, wie mit relativ einfachen Machine Learning-Systemen angefangen wird, eine neue Form von Sklaverei einzuführen. Und wo also die tatsächliche Bestimmung des Alltags von Menschen und zwar von vielen Menschen durch relativ dumme Machine Learning-Algorithmen mehr und mehr zum ernsthaften Problem wird. Also wo halt einfach die Benutzung des Menschen als irgendwie Roboter, weil er irgendwie zwei halbwegs funktionierende Hände und irgendwie billiges Vision-System hat. Und seine Zielsteuerung halt durch einen, ja durch von wiederum Menschen trainierte und zielgesteuerte Machine Learning-Systeme passiert, dass das eigentlich erstmal unser gutes Problem wird und wahrscheinlich ein großes Problem werden wird, was uns möglicherweise sogar daran hindert, jemals die Phase zu erreichen, wo wir halt in der Lage sind, halt irgendwie eine generelle KI zu bauen. Also was ich da draußen halt sehe ist halt, dass immer mehr Leute halt irgendwie in Arbeitsumständen sind, wo sie halt irgendwie von Machine Learning-Systemen kontrolliert werden, wo ihr Dating-Life von irgendwie einem Machine Learning-System kontrolliert wird, wo ihre Gesundheit, wenn wir Pech haben, demnächst irgendwie von Wotzen kontrolliert werden wird, was irgendwie nun eine exzeptionell schlechte KI war oder ist. Das sind die Sachen, die mir gerade eigentlich eher Sorgen machen, weil wir da halt unmittelbare Anwendung von menschlichen Intentionen, die sich hinter der Intransparenz des Trainings und der Zielsetzung und der Optimierungsfunktionen verstecken.
Das trifft doch aber genau die Definition, die wir hatten, dass wir gesagt haben, eine KI, die uns umbringt. Da stand ja nichts von Waffe.
Nein, aber es ist halt nicht eine KI, die Bewusstsein haben wird, weil es dann werden Menschen sein, die halt die Machine Learning System.
Das ist doch noch geiler, wenn die uns umbringen kann, ohne Bewusstsein zu haben. Wenn wir so doof sind, uns von der KI umbringen zu lassen, die noch nicht mal ein Bewusstsein haben.
Ich glaube eben genau, dass das das Problem ist. Also ich meine, also Empfehlung, die Keynote von Charles Stross auf den Kongress, der eine schöne Analogie da gezogen hat, wo er sagt, wenn wir uns Firmen angucken, die eine Weile existieren, dann sind das eigentlich langsame Machine Learning Systemen. Also langsame AIs, die halt ein Ziel verfolgen, die Optimierungsfunktionen haben, die halt, ja, sich sozusagen immer besser werden an dem, was sie tun. Und die haben es schon geschafft, diesen Planeten irgendwie bis nah an den Punkt der Ausrottung zu bringen. Wie wird es erst, wenn wir diesen Mechanismus auch noch automatisieren? Und das ist halt eine...
Das ist übrigens eine Firma, die nur Viren sind. Und das sind Trader. Trader sind Leute, die einfach nur Attacken fahren auf das Finanzsystem, um Exploits zu finden. Und im Grunde genommen ist zum Beispiel Cryptocurrency ist ein Exploit. Der Wert von der Blockchain ist im Augenblick im Wesentlichen, dass man damit Ponzi-Schema da machen kann, ohne ins Gefängnis zu müssen. Deswegen ist das super populär.
Und es ist auch so, dass wir praktisch jetzt......wahrscheinlich mehr böse Mails bringen für diese Sendung, als alles, was wir sonst gesagt haben.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Es ist alles gut, es ist vollkommen gut.
Die werden wir alle weiterladen.
Vollkommen in Ordnung werden.
Also, Krypto ist total fortschrittlich. Es ist total schön. Ich möchte auch mehr Bitcoins haben.
Wir haben unter unserer Hörerschaft natürlich eine relativ große Fettgemeinde von Kryptocurrencies. Wir fühlen übrigens mit euch, was den letzten Markt-Tipp angeht, aber es geht bestimmt bald wieder aufwärts. Wir glauben fest daran. Unbedingt spendet uns einfach alle eure Coins. Ihr habt die Adressen in der vorletzten Sendung. Wir passen auch gut darauf auf. Ja, also ich glaube halt, dass dieses Problem...
Moment, was mich zum Fürchten bringt, ist dieses Ding, was wir jetzt sehen, ist, dass da massiv Compute gekauft wird. Und zwar so, dass halt richtig Öl verbrannt wird in einer großen Ordnung von middle nation state, um komputationale Attacken auf das weltweite Finanzsystem zu fahren. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was da passiert. Es ist noch relativ dumm, aber im Prinzip die KI sind die Trading Companies selbst. Normalerweise ist es so, dass dieses Ding mit neue Asset-Klassen einführen und das Finanzsystem hacken, das ist den Banken vorbehalten gewesen, die die Türen zuhalten, damit das halt nicht so schnell den Bach runtergeht und sie dieses Privileg verlieren, sich zu bereichern. Und die Staaten haben blöderweise ein bestimmtes Maß an Parasitismus durch die Banken zugelassen. Das System ist halt nicht korrekt. Das Finanzsystem, auch an Stellen, wo man weiß, dass man es eigentlich fixen müsste, fasst man es halt dann doch nicht an, weil man zu vielen Leuten auf die Zehen treten müsste. Und jetzt ist mit einem mal was passiert, dass Rogue Traders, also einfach sozusagen Privatpersonen, die einfach nur ein bisschen Geld haben können, zu ein paar Nerds sagen können, mach doch mal ein ICO für mich, möchte einen Exploit gegen das Finanzsystem fahren und ein bisschen Geld aus Luft erzeugen bzw. aus Compute. Das heißt, ein bisschen von dem Geld wird reinvestiert, um Computer zu fahren, die Attacken fahren lassen. Was ist, wenn das mit richtiger KI passiert? Also wenn wir zum Beispiel Machine Learning benutzen, um massiv Attacken gegen die Börsen zu fahren.
Ja, das meinest, also findest du in allen Feldern.
Die gewinnen setzt du dann ein, um noch mehr Attacken gegen die Firmen zu fahren. Und das Ding ist, es ist ein Shortgame. Und dieses Shortgame führt dazu, dass ein nennensleiter Teil der Volkswirtschaft eingesetzt wird, um gegen die Volkswirtschaft zu arbeiten. Und das kann die Volkswirtschaft nicht gewinnen. Das ist wie Krebs.
Na gut, ich meine, der Punkt ist halt, dass diese Anwendung von Machine-Learning-Systemen, um in Feldern zu gewinnen, die bisher im Wesentlichen von Menschen betrieben werden, die finden wir überall. Also wir haben es an ganz vielen verschiedenen Stellen. Wir haben es einerseits bei der Versklavung von Menschen, die halt irgendwie von deren Alltag von Algorithmen bestimmt wird, die halt nicht mehr in irgendeiner Art und Weise irgendwie ihrer Kontrolle oder irgendeiner Transparenz unterliegen. Und wir sie auch keinerlei Möglichkeit haben, vorher zu sehen, was dieser Gott jetzt tut. Also dieser Uber-Fahrer, The Algorithm has blessed me today, so wörtliches Zitat. So, weil er hat halt irgendwie an dem Tag halt irgendwie mehrere gute Touren bekommen, so und der sprach wirklich in ja, wie so ein Farmer irgendwie des 17. Jahrhunderts über seinen Gott sprach, der ihm gerade den Regen geschickt hat, den er gerade brauchte, damit seine Ernte nicht versauerte. Und auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite haben wir halt irgendwie diese Leute, die halt irgendwie zum Beispiel bei Trading oder die bei im militärischen Bereich unterwegs sind, die halt irgendwie solche Systeme einsetzen und ihre Intentionen, die halt immer kaputt sind und die immer weniger irgendwie damit zu tun haben, dass dieser Planet noch eine Weile macht, umsetzen mit dieser zusätzlichen Firepower, die sie halt irgendwie aus diesen Systemen bekommen. Und ich glaube, das wird uns schneller umbringen, als wir halt irgendwie in der Lage sind, eine generelle KI zu bauen.
Die muss doch nicht generell sein. Das muss nicht mal KI sein.
Ich bin auch nicht sicher. Moment, warte mal. Ich habe den Verdacht, dass da deine anarchistischen Tendenzen durchkommen. Dass du einfach für dich diese Vorstellung, dass du deine Autonomie einbühst, klingt sehr nach Tod. Und ich kann das nachvollziehen. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo du, ich meine, die Leute sagen ja, auf hoher Seelen vergrügt bist du in Gottes Hand. Und der Urfahrer ist halt jetzt noch mehr in Gottes Hand, sozusagen. Gott wird sehr viel konkreter. Und Gott wird programmierbar und steuerbar und optimierbar.
Moment, Gott hat ja immer sozusagen, vor der Translation durch die Pfaffen, ist der Gott ja quasi eine neutrale Instanz. Na also, er hat halt irgendwie eine, naja, er ist halt nicht der Gott, also in der Reihenlehre, er ist der Gott, der nicht eine Ausdruck menschlicher Intention. Der Oberfahrer ist tatsächlich zwangsläufig Angehöriger einer Religion, die noch nicht so alt ist, dass da keine Menschen mehr sind, deren Intention dahinter steckt.
Ich vermute, es ist umgekehrt gewesen. Das Erste war nicht dieses spirituelle Ding, wo so ein Gefühl da ist, da ist ein Wesen draußen im Universum, das was will, aber nicht unbedingt von mir. Sondern ich glaube, das Erste ist diese religiöse Gott gewesen. Das heißt, du bist Teil von einem größeren Ding, deine Seele ist Teil davon, das drückt sich in dir aus und manifestiert sich in der Gruppe, in der du lebst. Aber es gibt diesen Superorganismus, diesen Hivemind. Deine Aufgabe ist durch deine Aktionen, in dem tugendhaftig zu verhalten, sodass diese Prinzipien des Hiveminds umgesetzt werden. Das heißt, es entsteht sozusagen ein virtueller Organismus, den deine Gruppe implementiert, der in der Lage ist, gegen andere virtuelle Organismen, die jeweils durch einen anderen Gott repräsentiert werden, zu kämpfen. Und diese Götter sind immer intentional. Diese Götter der Religion haben tatsächlich Absichten. Die sind Superorganismen, die gegen andere Superorganismen kämpfen.
Na bloß, wir haben im Falle von Uber, haben wir aber den Fall, oder den ähnlich gelagerten System, haben wir den Fall, dass die Götter dieser Menschen, die halt sich als Algorithme manifestiert haben oder als Maschinenhörungssystem manifestiert haben, folgen einer Intention. Und diese Intention ist, mach meinen Besitzern mehr Geld. Die haben keine andere Intention. So, die sind halt auszusehlen auf Optimierungsfunktionen, wie möglichst wenig Geld an den Fahrer ausschütten, dafür sorgen, dass möglichst viel Geld nach oben fließt, sicherstellen, dass möglichst viel Kunden bedient werden können und so weiter. Also halt eine Anzahl von Optimierungsfunktionen, die aber am Ende da oft zusammen kollabiert machen, je mehr Profit. So. Und diese, das ganze Ding ist aber so verpackt für den Menschen, dass es quasi seine religiösen Zentren anspricht. Na, es ist halt sozusagen diese Undurchschaubarkeit der natürlichen Umwelt, die dazu geführt hat, dass die Leute angefangen an Naturgötter sich auszudenken und den Quellen Gott und den Feuer Gott und whatnot, bevor es auf eine monatistische Religion zusammengeführt wurde. Was wir jetzt da gerade sehen, ist eine Replikation davon. Wir sehen, dass diese Undurchschaubarkeit und diese Unkontrollierbarkeit und dieses Ding, dass irgendwie man muss dem Algorithmus einen Opfer bringen. Siehst du bei den YouTubern, wenn du die YouTuber anguckst, wie die diskutieren darüber, wenn Google mal wieder angefangen hat, an den Algorithmen da zu spielen, was die Monetarisierung angeht. Das ist genau wie der Quell Gott würde gerne einen Vogel geopfert haben. Also es ist genau dieselbe Sprache. Weißte, die wissen, die haben keine Möglichkeit, das zu sehen. Die wissen nichts darüber. Das erklärt ihnen niemand. Es gibt nicht mal einen Priester. Sondern die haben nur so diese Möglichkeit, wenn ich dreimal die Woche poste, dann ist das offenbar okay. Dann wäre ich nicht demonetarisiert. Oder wenn ich diese Themen vermeide, werde ich nicht demonetarisiert.
Lass mich mal mein Beispiel bringen. Das passt nämlich ganz gut. Gott ist der Begriff, den wir benutzen, wenn wir keinen besseren Begriff haben, weil wir es noch nicht verstanden haben. Das Beispiel war ein Farmer, der feststellt, wenn er nicht alles zu Brot macht von seiner Ernte, sondern ein bisschen was aufhebt, dann hat er in schlechten Zeiten was, was ein Deal mit der Zukunft ist. Und das kannst du sagen, das ist ein Opfer. Das lege ich zurück, das habe ich also nicht als Brot. Ist ein Opfer an wen? Habe ich kein gutes Wort für? Nenn ich Gott. So, da kommt der Gedanke des Opferns her.
Aber das war ja konstruktiv.
Ja, aber das ist ja der Punkt.
Aber bei YouTubern ist es nicht konstruktiv.
Nein, aus ihrer Sicht wissen sie es nicht. Das ist der Punkt.
Das ist halt ein vollständiger Cargokult. Ja, na klar ist es das. Wozu diese Algorithmen führen, diese Maschinensysteme führen, ist die selbstverschuldete Unmündigkeit. Ja, in der Tat. Es bringt die Leute dahin, in Cargokulten zu leben, weil die ihnen ihr Brot geben, so oder ihre Euro oder was auch immer. Und die damit halten, Machtverstärker sind, wie es wir ihnen seit dem Aufkommen von neuen Religionen eigentlich nicht hatten.
Das Ding ist aber kein Cargokult, weil das Cargokult haben wir tatsächlich.
Auch bei Cargokulten kommt häufiger mal ein Container angeschwemmt.
Das passiert. Naja, das ist aber nicht die Idee von Cargokult. Die Idee von Cargokult ist, du versuchst, so zu tun, als wäre es das System, aber es wird sich nicht manifestieren. Der Cargokult ist im Wesentlichen ein Missverständnis. Der Cargokult in YouTube ist tatsächlich eine unausweichliche Funktion. Aus meiner Sicht ist Gott nicht einfach so ein wager Begriff, den wir nicht wissen, was wir meinen, sondern Gott ist genau das, was eine Zelle vom Organismus denken würde, wenn die Zelle denken könnte. Wenn die Zelle denken könnte und den Organismus, in dem sie lebt, konzeptualisieren könnte und projizieren könnte, dann ist der Organismus halt genau das Ding, was die Zelle total liebt, außer wenn die Zelle vom Organismus abfällt und nicht gegen seine Ziele arbeitet. Dann ist die Zelle halt korrupt und muss sie weg. Meine Aufgabe ist es, diesem Ding zu dienen, so wie hier auch. Also alles, was ich habe, habe ich nur durch diesen Organismus und für diesen Organismus. Sonst hat das keinen Wert. Es ist nicht für mich da. Ich habe meine Nachkommen nicht für mich. Ich habe sie für diesen Organismus.
Das ist ja tatsächlich ein monetaristischer Götterbegriff. Was wir aber da sehen bei den Sklaven der Maschinen, die halt für Maschinen und Systeme arbeiten, ist halt tatsächlich genau eher so ein Naturgötter.
Das ist polytheistisch. Aber im Moment, die Naturgötter sind nicht nur den Quellgötter, sondern Aufgabengötter, glaube ich. Also der Gott ist Zähneputzen, sind die geputzten Zähne. Wenn nur den Gott ist Zähneputzen nicht richtig gedient, dann sind die Zähne nachher nicht geputzt. Das ist einfach eine Aufgabe sozusagen, die erfüllt wird, einen Zweck. Und dann gibt es Zwecke, ein Zweck, der liegt ungefähr auf der Ebene deiner Person, das ist das Ego. Das ist sozusagen die Funktion, die den erwarteten Reward über die nächsten 50 Jahre aufintegriert. Und der du, wenn du ein Soziopath bist, all dein Verhalten unterordnen. Leute, die keine Soziopathen sind, haben Funktionen, denen sie dienen oberhalb des Egos. Also Zwecke oberhalb des Egos. Und diese Zwecke können zum Beispiel sein, dass ich ein total guter Schmiedemeister bin und das weitergebe an andere und mit anderen Schmieden zusammenarbeite. Und dann habe ich so was wie so ein Gott der Schmiedekunst. Oder ich habe ein Gott des Wasserschöpfens und des sauberen Wasserfindens. Und irgendwann kam jemand, auf die diese Götter zusammenzulöten, um so eine Art Gott zu haben, der alle menschlichen Tätigkeiten sich vereint, sodass die Leute in einem Zustand kompletter Frömmigkeit verfallen und den nicht verlassen, wenn sie ihre Schmiede verlassen. Und da ist es, wo wir zum Monotheurismus kommen. Und dass wir das nicht verstehen, dass dieser Gott einfach dieses Regulationsprinzip der Gesellschaft, das liegt darin, wie kriege ich das implementiert auf den Leuten? Kriege ich dazu, dass sie konvergieren? Und dazu brauchten die Missionare halt coole Geschichten. Und die Geschichte läuft normalerweise so, die gehen dazu in den Stamm von Heiden, die keine Seele haben, also nicht konvergieren auf so einen gemeinsamen Zweck und erzählt denen, okay Leute, ich habe eine gute und eine schlechte Nachricht. Die gute Nachricht ist, ich kenne den Typen, der alles gemacht hat und ihr kriegt im Nachleben total große Belohnung. Die schlechte Nachricht, ihr habt leider masturbiert und deswegen werdet ihr in die Hölle kommen. Es gibt aber noch eine gute Nachricht, das kann vergeben werden und zwar müsst ihr folgende Dinge tun. Also relativ wenig, ihr müsst bei der Landwirtschaft mitmachen, auch wenn ihr nicht mehr hungrig seid. Ihr dürft nur mit bestimmten Leuten unter bestimmten Bedingungen schlafen, die ich euch sage, müsst euch immer gut benehmen und so weiter und so fort. Und die Überstunden werden alle im Nachleben abgegolten und dafür wird dann alles gut. Und die Leute werden dann sexuell frustriert und drehen durch und so weiter, aber sie übernehmen sich und nach zweier Generationen gibt es Straßen und Hospitäler und reduzierte Kindersterblichkeit. Das war so ungefähr die Idee. Und außerdem gibt es alle möglichen Artefakte, die in den Mythen der Leute entstehen und in ihrer Vorstellung davon, wie das Universum funktioniert.
Okay, aber wie sieht jetzt unsere Analogie zur generellen KI aus? Sozusagen die generelle KI wäre dann der monitoristische Gott?
Nicht unbedingt. Es ist schwer zu sagen, wo die generelle KI zuerst zuschlägt. Wenn die generelle KI zuerst bei Trader ist, dann wird die generelle KI wahrscheinlich unser Finanzsystem restlos zerbomben. Und sobald jemand versucht, ein neues Finanzsystem aufzubauen, wird die generelle KI auf das losgehen und exploit finden. Und das wird so lange passieren, bis unsere Sozialisationen auf den Zustand zurückgefallen sind, wo es keine KI mehr gebaut werden kann, also vergessen haben, wie es geht. Es könnte sein, dass es so schlimm kommt. Also so, wie das Individuum nicht schlauer werden kann, als dieses Level, wo du deine Rewardfunktion hackst und aufhörst zu denken, weil der Organismus dich nicht mehr erpressen kann, dich um die Bedürfnisse eines bescheuerten Affen zu kümmern, könnte es sein, dass eine Gesellschaft nicht über das Niveau hinausgehen kann, wo sie KI bauen kann, die ihr Finanzsystem zerlegen. Vielleicht ist das so eine logische Obergrenze. Keine Ahnung, ob man da irgendeine Möglichkeit findet, uns zu prüfen gegen ein Kreuz.
Ob du zu zynisch bist oder nicht zynisch genug, aber der alte Joke ist doch, dass du lieber eine Bank aufmachst, als eine auszurauben.
Ja, aber das geht halt nicht ohne Weiteres.
Nein, aber das kann auch eine KI auch machen oder kann drauf kommen, dass es lukrativer ist, die Bank zu übernehmen, als sie kaputt zu machen.
Die Bank wird eine KI bauen, natürlich. Es wird alle möglichen Banken geben, die KI's haben. Die KI's werden nicht neben uns leben, sondern wir werden in ihnen leben. Das sind genau alle großen Systeme, die es jetzt gibt, werden intelligentere Systeme werden. Die sind jetzt schon intelligente Systeme, aber die werden intelligenter werden als wir und schneller werden als wir.
Aber ich glaube halt eben schmalbar nicht.
Warum sollten die aber sentient werden? Das braucht doch eine Bank nicht.
Möglicherweise sind die dann effizienter, als welche, die es nicht sind. Wenn die Bank weiß, was sie tut und warum, wenn sie in der Lage ist, eine Simulation von der Welt zu machen, eine Simulation von sich in der Welt und sich herzuleiten, was sie da eigentlich tut und warum, dann wird sie effizienter sein als eine Bank, die keinen Plan hat, was sie gerade machen.
Sie können nur depressiv werden und sich umbringen.
Das wäre natürlich richtig geil. Stell dir vor, du bist in der Vorlesflugsystem der Welt, fällt aus, weil die KI sich auf der Flugsicherung sich umgebracht hat.
Stell dir vor, du wirst eine Banking-Kai, und deine Rewardfunktion ist, irgendwie möglichst viel Geld auf dem Konto anhäufen, und dann bist du plötzlich Sentiment. Mein Gott, das muss doch schlimm sein.
Ich habe, glaube ich, gute Nachrichten. Also ich merke, dass wenn ich selber mehr Integrität in mir herstelle, dann leide ich nicht. Weil das Ding ist, dass meine ganz neue Rewardfunktion, die erzeug ich selbst. Alle meine Lust- und Schmerzsignale sind Kekse, die mein Gehirn sich beckt, damit ich mein Gemüse esse. Und wenn ich in den Raum reingehe, wo die Kekse hergestellt werden, dann kann ich so viel essen, wie ich will. Ich merke mir irgendwann, es hat keine Integrität. Und höre dann auf damit. Und die Frage ist, ob ich das schaffe, als Individu, um diese Integrität herzustellen. Aber normalerweise, wenn wir lang genug leben und gut genug aufpassen, kriegen wir das hin. Also wir werden dann gegen Ende unseres Lebens ein bisschen ausgeglichen. Und es ist nicht klar, wieso die KI das nicht können sollte. Also, kennt ihr das Lebowski-Theorie?
Das Lebowski-Theorie?
Ja, kein intelligentes System wird irgendwas tun, was schwieriger ist, als seine eigene Wortfunktion zu hacken.
Ja gut.
Und das Ding ist, Menschen sind natürlich nicht sehr intelligent, vermutlich einfach, weil wir evolviert sind. Nicht so intelligent zu sein, dass wir unsere Wortfunktion zu hacken, weil einfach die Leute das gemacht haben, obdenaus aus der Evolution, die haben dann keine Kinder mehr. Und es gibt auch so ein bisschen Right Protection, zum Beispiel wenn es irgendwie Schuld und Scham, so Right Access-Dinger, damit du dich nicht fixst, damit du deine Wortfunktion nicht in Ordnung bringst. Da guckst du dann nicht genau hin. Es ist sehr schwer dahin zu gucken, wo du Schuld und Scham empfindest und das in Ordnung zu bringen, sodass du sie nicht mehr empfindest und einfach tust, was das Bequemste ist. Und dieses Ding hat aber keine gute Verteidigung gegen einen Mönch, der erkannt hat, wie wichtig ist, seine Wortfunktion zu hacken und sich einfach mal 20 Jahre in seine Mönchklausel setzt, sich von jemand anderem das Ruhestück machen lässt und seine Wortfunktion systematisch hackt. Das Problem ist nur, viele von diesen Leuten, die sitzen dann halt in irgendwelchen Höhlen und haben ihre Wortfunktion bis zu Ende gehackt und lassen sich dann von Käfern fressen, weil sie einfach keine Lust mehr haben, sich vom physischen Universum zu irgendwas erpressen zu lassen und es ihnen nichts ausmacht. Und das setzt sich natürlich nicht fort. Und die Leute, bei denen das gut geklappt hat, die sind in Kulten drin, also irgendwelchen Klostern, die ökonomische Institutionen sind, die Leuten beibringen, nur auf bestimmten Kanälen ihre Wortfunktion zu hacken, sodass das Kloster halt gut weiterläuft und zukünftige Generationen indoktrinieren kann.
Das heißt, unsere Hoffnung ist, dass falls es irgendwie eine generelle KI gibt, sie irgendwie schneller anfängt, ihre Wortfunktion zu hacken als unser Bankensystem. Ich finde, das ist eigentlich ein gutes Schlusswort. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir versuchen nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen links in die Shownotes zu tun.
Was machst dieses Mal du? Sorry!
Aber vielleicht könnte uns ja auch helfen. Wir vielleicht einfach ein Pad aufmachen dafür, dann könnte er es selber tun. Ja, vielen Dank an Joscha fürs Vorbeikommen und uns eine generelle, generöse Dosis Realitätsverzerrung für die Sendung 42 zu probieren.
Entzerrung.
Entzerrung, Verzerrung, Transposition. Genau, das kommt durch die Perspektive an. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr Lust habt, da gibt es irgendwo so einen Patreon-Knopf. Und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.